foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just yeah he did I'm Blown
Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
wait wait he just took money you panic I
told you I didn't like the position my
goodness the position is getting very
very bad for black
ding the Red Nose first hand with the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame 10 seconds one more
move remains whoa he made him with four
seconds on the clock and there's a draw
agreed but what a match we have
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 b-day World Championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
the finish line is inside as six games
remain to Crown the 17th Chess World
Champion and it's all happening in the
city of Astana Kazakhstan outside it's
beautiful but this is where it's getting
extremely dense this is the fish tank
the glass room off the Saint Regis Hotel
in just a few minutes the challenge is
England will walk out and take their
places for game nine welcome everyone
the action starts now I'm your host for
the day international Master Tanya and
I'm so thrilled to be joined once again
by my good friend our Master Robert Hess
and the one and only former World
Championship challenger super Grand
Master Fabiano caruana welcome guys such
a pleasure to have you here with us Fabi
first off how are you doing and where
are you joining us from thanks Sonia I'm
doing great I'm joining from Madrid and
I've been following all the games
closely I've been watching you guys
enjoying the commentary and I'm glad to
be joining
we're so happy to have you here with us
Fabi Robert such a dramatic date in this
world championship match it's hard to
predict anything oh you're gonna have
more of the same unpredictable action
today
oh for sure there is drama in Astana you
can't help but know that and for dingley
Ren he didn't lose yesterday that's a
good sign but he did struggle it wasn't
up and down game we'll see if his nerves
are in check
so many twists and turns in game eight
it ended peacefully but the game itself
was anything but and with that the four
white wind streak was halted at the
world championship match and currently
yeah napomnushi leads with a one point
margin the smallest of margins he's at
four and a half points the first player
to reach seven and a half will become
world champion Bobby
game eight so many twists and turns big
opportunity missed how big a Miss was it
for ding to let that one slip
I think it was absolutely huge and I
think this is saying a lot because of
all the excitement and drama we've seen
in this match so far but for me game 8
was the most unpredictable the most
exciting and even the most dramatic
despite it being a draw because we saw
the opening fight was so intense the
twists and turns and we couldn't predict
we were then going to win was the young
going to escape it was it was so close
to a win and even at the end I was
wondering will Jan suddenly win this
game uh there were a lot of emotions for
both players for all the people watching
as well it was a super exciting game
yeah excuse me losing my voice that's
how exciting it was yesterday in game
eight the players I mean they have to be
super nervous at this stage because the
world championship title is within sight
but the players have to just get back at
it it's a new day the pass is the past
we'll see what happens in Game nine
yes it really could have gone anywhere
that game it's super exciting stuff we
witnessed Players missed opportunity
twists and done some Bluff there lock on
the inside as he started to survive that
one a huge missed opportunity there by
ding to level the score the drama was
not only over the board we saw rumors of
elite preparation which was very
dramatic at the press conference and
we've got my client with an update on
that
foreign
thanks guys and could it really be
possible that one of the few games not
to produce a winner actually produced
the most drama of the match that's
exactly what happened drama on the board
and drama off the board let's first talk
about the game Grand Master ding Loren
with some sparkling opening preparation
and he found himself in a winning
position for the second straight game
but just like in round seven he failed
to convert he did hold the draw but
thanks to a yon napomnishi sort of
Desperado he got back in the match ding
running low on time also for the second
straight game could not navigate the
complications before the first time
control Dean could not find a way to
escape the checks and so did not play
the critical move Queen takes Rook the
game resulted in a draw but there was
news off the board it looks like some
opening preparation may have been leaked
online there are several games found
that greatly resemble the exact moves of
the world championship so the question
lingered all day were these training
games played by ding Laurent and his
team I got to ask Dean that question
exactly at the press conference
well I don't know which
oh which gave me your prefer
were any training games played online
that you can remember that resemble
games played here at the world
championship
I don't know I don't know
well there you have it unsurprisingly
very little revealed by Grandmaster ding
Loren and his team's radio silence
continued down the hallway when I asked
his main second Grand Master Richard
Rapport about the day's events and he
said he's not allowed to talk to anybody
outside of his team I said to Richard
does that mean no comment and he said to
me I'm not even allowed to say that
what's going to happen in round nine
will team ding be able to recover from
this possible leak of information and
from not being able to convert his
second straight winning position we will
definitely want to see what happens for
chess.com this is Mike Klein inside the
playing Hall in Astana Kazakhstan
thank you so much for that Mike in the
in the championship
that press conference I had a Deja Vu
moment of the 2018 World Championship
Match right after your game you walked
into a press conference and were asked
about that video League having having
been on that stage having have to answer
those questions right after a tensed
game I want to get your take on this
what was going on in ding's mine and how
do you make of how he handled it
yeah watching that yesterday it brought
back a lot of familiar feelings and
memories from 2018 and after the game in
2018 I was immediately met by my one of
my seconds at that match Christian and
he told me something that like there's a
video leak we only have basically like
30 seconds before the press conference
he was like this video leak they're
gonna ask you some questions just say no
comment to everything which is what I
did and I didn't even know what what had
happened what was going on basically I
just said no comment and he was in a
complete panic I was less so in a panic
I didn't feel like it was such a
dramatic moment that's also how I feel
here it's not like it's it's more
dramatic from the side than probably for
for the people involved and I don't
think you'll have a huge impact on the
match but it is still extremely exciting
to to see all this you know this insight
into what the players were looking at
and what they were analyzing how they
were playing training games
um yeah it's it's an interesting thing
but I don't think it'll have a strong
impact on the match
well it could have an impact not just on
dingly Wren but on the man we see on the
screen in front of us yonda palmushi
it's kind of awkward for him and his
Camp because you don't know without
exact confirmation what they were
looking at you don't know is that what
I'm going to expect the next few rounds
are they gonna scrap that and play
something new altogether and let's not
forget these are Fierce competitors they
want to win over the board nobody wants
to score a win because they feel like
leaked preparation happened so I feel
like for Jana palmchi he also will have
to focus on just the things that are
gonna happen on the board today
yes and indeed Robert he does start with
the white pieces game nine a very
critical game Yan leads the match with a
point and our team at the chesscom stats
to cut these odds for Yan to win the
World Championship Match based on a game
9 outcome if Yan wins today with white
he's uh he's almost a 94 favorite to
take the world championship match going
into the last five games with a two
point lead if it ends in a draw it's
almost a 78 favorite Fabi if Yan was to
take this with the white pieces today
would that be a nail in the coffin for
Deng I think it very nearly would be and
it's not only about the score which
would be pretty bad for ding but also
because of the trend like the trend of
the last two games was really in yeon's
favor first getting a win out of a
position which was a little bit dubious
and very safe for Ding and then ding
being completely winning yesterday in
multiple ways it was completely out of
beyond control and he also wasn't able
to convert that and so if we see the
trend continue in eon's favor I think
that we might start to see the Contours
of a a young Victory if there's a draw I
think that that is actually a very good
result for ding for today I think it's
it's good to to stop the bleeding stop
the negative emotions and be able to
focus on the rest of the games in terms
of how I'm going to get back into the
match and and get some winning chances
yeah and we heard ding say yesterday in
the post-game interview I have a bunch
of white pieces remaining so he is
relying on the first move Advantage with
the black pieces he needs to stabilize
and I do think a loss today would be a
backbreaker I think his match would be
over I know there will be games
remaining but he cannot afford to
Lucidity I don't think his emotions will
hold up and I just speaking from the
chest itself he would be down two games
with not many remaining he would not
have very good chances as you see his
eyes staring at me I feel like he's
talking to us he's willing himself back
into this match
yes and Robert The Empty Glass Room
isn't empty anymore as the two
challenges are ready to start a game
nine the most dense moments getting into
a game just before the start of it once
it happens once the first moves are
played it comes down for the players but
of course the big question for thing
with black will be to keep everything
under control it will be an absolute
disaster to go into the next rest day
with a two-point deficit for the Chinese
Superstar now in the match so far thing
has been a little shaky with black
especially the first couple of blacks
that he got starting with the kingspawn
opening uh first question Fabi are we
expecting Yan to start with the King
spawn opening is one E4 going to happen
today
I feel like it's a smart choice for Jan
for a few reasons first of all because
ding was playing the Marshall and it
looked like young was getting chances in
every martial game that they had and in
the one game where young was playing D4
he didn't really get many opening
chances and that was actually one of the
the least bloody games and the police uh
you know full of content games that we
had and ding's last game he played the
French so this is posing a difficult
question to ding do you want to continue
with the French but now I know your
intentions so I can try to you know be
better prepared and press you
theoretically there if you want to go
back to your Marshall or do you want to
deviate again and then you're going to
into territory you might not be familiar
with as much as uh we you know we know
ding is a marshall player so that's his
most safe territory uh does he want to
go for something crazy like a night or
you know we saw we saw some of those
training games were actually in night
Earth's uh does he want to play
something super solid like Berlin but
it's a difficult question for things so
that's why I think Jan should be posing
that question
he likes to be a moving Target in this
match he keeps changing his openings and
what he'll play today is a big question
but I do not think we'll see a repeat of
the French defense
oh yeah that's a hot dig because what's
French a one game opening it got him a
great position out of the out of the
opening the middle game uh the kind of
middle game that Ding enjoys playing but
will he repeat it or will he play
something completely random he has been
the one who's been bringing in all the
opening surprises so far sort of
struggled to equalize by replying with
wanifi well we've got the opening move
and the guest has decided to start with
the King's Pawn will Yan even bother to
put the pawn back or will he just press
the clock here we've seen that happen
before at a world championship match
Robert
yeah I mean it's been funny yesterday
the first sermon on the first one was E4
for ding but he took that back I think
Jan is going to play E4 as Fabiano said
he should stick to what's working for
him it's his tried and true opening and
it has been giving him success
the ding coming out of that game is
knowing that he's trailing the mat
knowing that he missed the big
opportunity we've seen him at the press
conference the drama surrounding it uh
Fabi what do you think is his mindset
coming into this game nine and
handshakes Abby take it away you know I
think the French would be an interesting
choice for Dane because Jan would not
repeat the same third move that he
played last time because it led to no
Advantage but we see e45 now here's the
question are we going to see another
anti-martial or are we going to see
Berlin I think that Berlin would be a
really smart choice by dig
oh just to shut it down just to get a
solid position you want to keep
everything under control with black
Robert do you agree are you expecting a
Berlin here
I think for John it's a great choice and
I think for dingley run he wants
combative games but he doesn't want to
take too much risk he is going to rely
on having the white pieces it's an
important game to stabilize so I think
the Berlin would be a great choice and
there he is going for it uh is Ding and
we'll see what Jan has to play because
uh well what does he want does he want
to give some life to the position or
does he just want to force things into
territory where yeah we're playing for
two results but the likely results is
draw
this is an unpleasant surprise for Yan
but I'm wondering why didn't ding do
this earlier in the match because rather
than struggling in some anti-marshall
lines Why don't you pose this difficult
question to your opponent at the start
and then maybe you even discourage him
from playing E4 in later games if he
can't you know uh break open break down
this defense which is
pretty much unbreakable you know for the
last since uh kramnik used it against
Kasparov now it's been 22 years uh
completely unbreakable defense
I think Jan if he wants to get chances I
don't think he's going to go for the end
game I think D3 it's also more Natural
Choice for his style but then the
question is D3 Bishop C5 is he going to
take on C6 is he going to play some
other lines uh he's thinking now but for
sure he has something planned because
you have to have some plan for the
Berlin it's the most popular defense at
the top level
predicting a Berlin Choice by dingler
and for the first time in the match and
an even more awesome insight there that
how important the timing of preparation
is the opening that you reveal at what
what situation during the match should
ding have gone for the first few games
with black with the Berlin or revealed
his martial plans early on well it did
backfire early on and now he just wants
to stabilize and we see an anti-martial
Choice by Yana pomnushi Robert are you
surprised or is this something that you
were expecting no I think it makes
perfect sense because the end games are
so well studied and they're not really
young to Palm Tree style that's what
Fabi was hinting at that Jan he prefers
to have some chances in the position of
some life and Bobby called this
perfectly we are seeing this bishop C5
move played a more aggressive line than
putting your Bishop on a less active
square and C3 so uh so far it's very
solid start for these two players but I
do think already a slight Advantage not
in the position but in terms of
psychological battle for dingley run he
clearly caught Jan a little bit off
guard there because Jan when he is
familiar territory when he knows what he
wants to play he plays instantly he
paused and I think that he is going to
continue to pause to try to figure out
if he can get an edge here
yeah I think this will be a very
interesting moment after young castles
which he played because now ding has a
choice I think he'll play rather quickly
of D5 is considered the most solid way
for black to try to equalize and and he
does indeed go for D5 although D6 also a
fine move and here I think probably on
will play Knight B to D2 because I don't
think e6d5 really gives white uh much
hope compared to Knight bd2 and this was
actually how uh Timor rajaba of BT cover
Hikaru Nakamura in the candidates the
candidates which qualified both of these
players for this world championship
match and so this is a very very
positional very slow line usually black
takes on e4 at some moment and then
plays A5 or queen E7 or some you know
some slow moves and white is also sort
of trying to maneuver either playing A3
and B4 or A4 and you know rookie one and
queen C2 and all these sort of typical
moves
um but I think ding is pausing here he
might not take on e4 he might play the
move A5 which is uh which is also a
possibility I'm it's a bit sharper
because it allows Bishop takes cease
okay he does take
uh so we're gonna see a very solid game
for for both players
and to me that just looks exactly what
we were expecting a very solid approach
by ding to make sure that things don't
get too messy too chaotic out of the
opening and even though Yan perhaps
wasn't expecting the Berlin to be uh to
be the opening of choice today but he
couldn't have been that surprised right
given the math situation it is an
opening that at the very top level at
all levels is considered one of the most
solid approaches by black to shut down
all play for white so yeah
is definitely prepared to a certain
point about how to handle it even if it
is on a particular day that he's taken
by surprise Berlin he's got to know what
to do
yeah I think this is a good choice for
mjan in general because the thing about
this variation is that you can't really
analyze it so directly because it's so
non-concrete and both sides have a lot
of moves and there is some uh positional
poison there there's a lot of ways that
black can get outplayed uh so usually in
practice although the computer will tell
you that in a million ways black is
equalizing here in practice it's usually
proven very difficult for players to
find the right path and I suspect we'll
see ding play A5 here the idea is simply
to stop B4 and you're not really
concerned too much about Bishop takes C6
followed by Knight takes E5
but it's not the only move very often
because the position is so slow We very
often see these movers like Queen to E7
followed by Knight to B8 or Knight to d8
uh and then trying to get C6 and
maneuver the Knight around in some
fashion like Knight B8 going putting the
Knight on D7 basically because the
Knight of C6 is restricted by The Pawn
on C3 it has no uh future there so it
usually wants to get out of that square
and Hikaru chose an approach involving
A5 followed by Knight to A7 basically
just going back and forth with the
Knight so it's a very subtle type of
position players maneuvering for a long
time
but it's difficult to analyze
yes and indeed as you're mentioning ding
slows down at the moment he is perhaps
considering all these options and you
said that there can be positional poison
in these positions Berlin of course is
famously known for just how solid an
approach it is but Fabi can you just
and then what are these positional
details that black actually needs to
watch out for long term
well long term why we'll probably be
looking for pressure on the queen side
and very often some sort of expansion on
the queen side so white would like to
get the move B for him because it forces
the bishop to an uncomfortable Square
either D6 where it's less active B6
where it's potentially getting harassed
by either A4 Knight C4 so that's why
usually black is trying to prevent that
move B4 and again after A5 white has
different approaches one is to play A4
just to try to fix the queen side and
you know a knight on C4 in at some point
in the future will be an annoying piece
that's the thing of the reason for
White's tiny bit of an advantage here is
because White's Knight on D2 has a lot
more uh prospects than that on C6 than I
don't see four were the Knight going
from D2 to C4 will be attacking black
spawns on the 906 it usually has to go
away from that C6 Square because it
actually doesn't do anything there it's
both vulnerable to Bishop takes C6 and
it's not attacking anything so the other
approach for white is to play at some
point instead of A4 A3 and try to
prepare that B4 slowly because you have
to get the Rook away from A1 and and
it's not going to be immediately that
you can play B4 because of that sort of
stare down of the Rooks on the a-file
but ding is thinking here I'm a bit
surprised because it's like one of the
main lines of the anti Berlin it's
um it's one of the ways that white is
trying to test black in modern chess
and I'm surprised that he I'm sure he
knows something about the position but
still surprised that he is uh doing it
so slowly so A5 we see it's kind of to
be expected in for the modern Theory
and now the question is for yawn
I was gonna say Fabi I think it's
important for everybody because they're
taught that you can remove a knight on
C6 to win a Pawn on E5 but I think
there's just way too much in these lines
it's uh you look at the engine analysis
that Bishop takes C6 Pawn 66 Knight
takes E5 is not what you want to do here
even if at first the engine says it's
all right for white I mean we don't see
it drop at all but take us through it I
mean you've played these positions
before what's it like when you are
spotting Bishop A6 and the Bishops are
going to be very strong yeah this is
just a theoretical position and it's
kind of I think turning into equality so
it's it's not that it's a better
approach for white than let's say A4
it's not that it's a worse approach but
it's a more direct approach and and
Theory kind of figured these lines out
already so that's why white is is
avoiding it I think the Dion play A4
yeah this is this is following the game
where job of Nakamura from the
candidates as well as many many other
games
and
um I think Queen E7 is very natural like
you you basically want to get that
Knight away from C6 but you can't
immediately because E5 was hanging so
you're also dealing with any potential
Bishop takes C6 because now that would
no longer win a pawn and it doubles the
C pawns but that's not as important the
detail as the uh Bishop here especially
that light squared Bishop going to A6
and maybe to D3 so so Bishop C6 is not
on the cards white mate usually plays
like Queen C2 or some such move like
that and then H3 moves a rook from F1
and tries to slowly maneuver you know
Bishop drops back to F1 Knight to C4 and
so on
wow and after A4 we see ding well not a
very big thing but he plays the move
Queen E7 so as you were pointing out a
very logical move and he gets up and
leaves and Fabi we will of course Deep
dive further into this Berlin position
but it's it's so amazing that we have
you here with us because you've sort of
been on this stage right you've played a
world championship match and your
insights into everything that goes into
it is just invaluable the one thing I
want to ask you about at this point is
that uh
Ding and nepo they've played each other
a bunch of times but it just feels like
a completely different Dynamic this time
ding who we've seen struggle a little
bit with confidence he the tension the
moments that with time scrambles with
him sometimes faltering with his nerves
in those critical moments how different
a stage is the world championship match
for a player compared to playing any
other Elite event
yeah you can't really compare it at all
the the feelings you have the pressure
everything that at stake uh for me it
hit me in the first game that's where I
felt it the most and eventually I kind
of uh felt my way into the match
emotionally like I felt more comfortable
and I felt more like I was just playing
chess and not you know fighting for a
world championship which is the I think
the mode you want to be in you just want
to feel like you're playing uh your
normal game for these guys I I don't
know their emotions but we can judge by
the amount of decisive games and all the
crazy stuff that's been going on that
that they are feeling it they're feeling
a lot of emotions and especially ding I
mean he was very upfront about that and
uh I think two is credit and also
um which was greatly insightful for all
the fans watching that he was feeling
very emotional at the start of the match
and it was probably the reason why we
saw that second game totally
uncharacteristic uh lost by his
standards
then it started to feel like he was
getting into it more but we're still
seeing this back and forth and I think
that takes its toll it's like you know
when you play a chess tournament but
especially when you play a really high
stakes match like this it's like those
little bits of trauma and they they kind
of they eat at your soul every time you
make a big mistake every time you miss a
chance every time you lose a game
especially it's like it takes a blow to
Your Ego to your confidence uh likewise
every win feels like you know you're on
top of the world so all those emotions
they take their toll and it's it's
probably best to to avoid you know those
emotional swings for for let's say your
mental health during the match
but yeah I can't imagine what these guys
are feeling right now
yeah it's a very different environment
as you're saying every player who takes
part in the world championship you know
Echoes that sentiment you of course were
the Challenger in 2018 and it does have
a different feel this year right we have
not just no Magnus Carlson but many more
decisive games than we're used to you're
part of the problem Fabi you had 12
draws in your world championship match
but in all seriousness I mean this does
seem like a totally different uh event a
totally different match than the ones we
have seen in previous years and I just I
guess I'm curious what you think is the
Difference Maker between these two
because we're not used to seeing so many
decisive games especially four white
wins in a row so is it just the nerves
are high or is it because this is an
even matchup on paper both sides feel
like they have legitimate chances to be
world champion which young maybe didn't
feel back in 2021 against Magnus
yeah I think these guys are definitely
very evenly matched and I felt that
before the match it was clear from their
ratings it was clear generally for the
from their chests if you've played both
of them you know that they have their
strengths they have their weaknesses but
they are very dangerous and very strong
and pretty evenly matched and in terms
of
I've seen things in this match that like
I'm I'm super impressed by and things
that
um
that it feels like the players you know
are not at their best as well I'm super
impressed by how many winning chances
they create because it's so tough at
this level to create winning chances
every every top player every Grandmaster
will I think Echo that sentiment that
you know you're playing a guy like Anish
for example or you're playing a guy like
Levon and and you have to break them
down in every stage of the game first
you have to get chances from the opening
then you have to outplay them and then
you have to finish them off which is
very often uh one of the most difficult
parts and these guys are doing it game
after game that they're creating chances
from the opening very often choosing
fighting variations
um not always converting them but very
often converting those chances
but I also feel like it is part because
their defense has not been up to par
when they get bad positions usually they
usually they fall apart there's two
exceptions I think one was the first
game where ding got a bad position but
held it and the other exception was
yesterday where Jan got a losing
position but held it but besides that
they haven't really been up to the test
defensively so there's a lot of good and
bad uh in terms of their you know when
they're looking at their own play
thinking I can be confident about some
things but I can also be worried about
some things
ending there going into a bit of a tank
right now he did decide to play the
Berlin and we see him uh taking a pause
at this moment and Fabi while you were
discussing these details I took a look
at the database that I have on this
opening and it seems like the most
popular move right now is actually a
night Retreat the Knight going back to
be it and I'm trying to understand why
is that the top move here or the most
played move at this position and is this
something that uh that you're familiar
with
yeah so I think that
um I I did I I mentioned this retreat
was a possibility in various positions
especially in this one black just wants
to play C6 and basically copy white
because we see ever those structures
symmetrical but the only difference is
the placement's only significant
difference is placement of the knights
on D2 and C6 so if that Knight goes back
to B8 uh because on C6 it wasn't doing
very much then black plays C6 and then
Knight B to D7 then the Knight is
basically you know in the same positions
that white is in I think and I might be
wrong but I think that Nakamura played
Knight to A7 instead of Knight to B8 and
I think Knight to d8 is also a valid
move with the idea of one day getting
the Knight to E6 but I theoretically I
think this is the main move and I think
usually white plays
H3 here although Rook to E1 work to D1 I
think are also possibilities but they
allow Knight to G4 and
um I feel like H3 is the main move and
C6 and Bishop drops back
it's one of those positions that's very
close to level it's very close to
symmetrical but white is a small
development advantage
um so white can look to the future with
a little bit more confidence but to
convert this Advantage into anything you
have to you know you both be super
precise and outplay your opponent for
the next you know 30 40 moves basically
it's it's not easy and I don't know what
I expect here maybe H3
um at least it's it's a very logical
looking movie because you prepare Rook
moves and then Knight G4 will not be an
option anymore and then white snipe can
uh either drop to F1 or Bishop can drop
to F1
and black very often will play C6 soon
in these types of positions
yeah and I feel like if H3 makes perfect
sense stopping the night jump and we see
Jan play Rook to E1 now there's the move
I was going to say because sometimes
Knight G4 is just met by the Rooks
sliding up to the E2 square and it's a
weird way to defend for everybody
watching but this happens in many
different positions in the Italian game
uh for example so Jana's not afraid he's
going forward with your plans Bobby uh
putting up either Bishop back to F1
after the move C6 or the Knight we often
see that knight jump forward after
taking a step back so the big question I
have is whose style is this position
more in because John we typically
consider him a player who likes the
flare of the game he likes aggressive
chess but he has shown a tendency in
recent years after winning the first
candidates and then the second that when
he's ahead he slows things down and has
no problem doing so
yeah I think of Jana as like an
aggressive positional player so he's
he's definitely playing for the
initiative
but he does usually do it in a
positional manner like these kinds of
slow positions I think they play to his
strength and when it comes to Pure
calculation I actually think that Ding
probably is outperforming him somewhat
not because Jan can't calculate very
well but because I think ding usually
and I will say usually because of course
players have their good and bad days but
usually ding will be a bit more
disciplined in his calculations
like for me ding is just basically the
like when you look at an ideal player
who can calculate ding is is let's say
your model
and and Jan has maybe like more goes for
the natural feel of the game but I I
tried to avoid these like sweeping
generalizations about players because of
course they're good at all sorts of
things it's not like they have their one
specialty or anything
uh Bobby you mentioned a really
interesting point one of the big strands
of ding being his ability to calculate
like a complete machine a complete beast
when it comes to calculation and I think
that was one of the more surprising
moments that we had when he missed the
opportunity to just calculate and decide
in game eight to pick up that Rook
finish the game on the spot was that an
uncharacteristic Miss once again because
of the math situation the stage the
tension this belief in Jan's demeanor of
just being so confident on the board
yeah I think it was it was basically
just psychological and it was actually
connected a bit to the previous game
before that where ding
um hesitated a lot at a moment again to
devastating time trouble and lost the
game hugely because of the time travel
and I think that he probably made a vow
to himself I will not get into time
trouble although as we saw he did get
down to four seconds again
and he didn't feel like
some something should have told him this
is a critical moment to calculate this
to a draw or to a win because it's very
straightforward and I think it is
actually a huge Miss although
of course we see that it's a long line
and uh you know a difficult line to
calculate but it's a straightforward
line and when we we think about it it
was basically black hat only moves on
each move so it was something that you
give this as a puzzle
as like a straightforward calculation
puzzle and and not as something where
like you have to spend 20 minutes but
one where I think you can figure out all
the details in five minutes
if it's given to you as a puzzle so the
only difficulty there is having the
discipline uh first of all not to trust
your opponent not to panic and to finish
your calculation with an evaluation
which means that in this case the
valuation either has to be winning or
drawing there are no other possibilities
you don't stop and say this is a slight
Advantage for someone obviously because
you're either up a rook or it's
perpetual check so I think he could have
he could have taken that to the end I
think that this was
mostly a psychological mistake on his
part yeah I completely agree and that's
kind of what I was saying yesterday was
you miss things everyone misses things
but the fact that he only spent three
four minutes on that decision what was
alarming to me because it had game seven
not happened he would have tried to
calculate that to the end he only had
about eight nine moves to make towards
time Patrol and in that series he would
have made all of them so he could have
calculated to the end as you're saying
father he's such a brilliant calculator
such a brilliant player but something
has felt off I think something really
hurt him after that game seven loss and
you know he's not immune to the comments
that people make about him freezing and
people like athletes any professional
sees that or hears about or thinks about
it but I think he needs to put that all
aside and he has a good start in this
game he has spent a little bit of more
time than John has but we're already at
move 11. Black's position looks very
stable and Jan also is thinking so
that's I think good news for dingly Bren
as he just wants to stabilize here with
the black piece
yeah I I want to dwell a little bit on
the point of like why these guys players
of this level make mistakes and I think
it's it's not because it's beyond their
ability like 99 of the time they they
could figure this out on a good day on a
good moment
um pretty much everything they could
figure out in chess like there's there's
a few things that are Beyond human uh
understanding you know things that a
human just can't figure out but almost
all the mistakes that these guys will
make that even Magnus will make are just
because of moments of weakness not
because it's beyond their uh
capabilities but just because they had a
moment of weakness and I think that
yesterday was an example of that and
like one uh little finesse about the
variation yesterday the The Rook that he
could have taken it it culminated
basically in this King march to E5
but when I was analyzing it I realized
that he actually had two paths to
victory at that moment uh after Bishop
to D3 and Knight to D6 he could have
gone forward with the King you guys were
exploring that variation where the King
goes forward and then backwards and only
moves and wide wins but the king could
have also gone backwards so he actually
had a choice if he had uh gotten to that
position he would have realized that
white actually has an abundance of
winning pass well not an abundance but
two of them which is is more than enough
so yeah that moment yesterday is a very
critical one for this match for sure
and I just want to take this point a
little forward what you and Robert were
mentioning about the psychological
aspect of game seven and how that had
its revelations in game eight I also
feel we speak about things vulnerability
how can it has been he's been a little
shaky on confidence but it also showed a
lot of strength from ding to even
recover from what happened in game seven
it's so easy to collapse from that
moment in a world championship match
where you've just Frozen where you have
this complete meltdown on the board but
he comes back the next day right with
the white pieces he does he plays out
this opening that does create a mess on
the board he gets his chances he
actually played a really strong game it
was flawlessly played but the only thing
was that he was not able to convert it
in those critical moments and I think
it's easy to miss out because of the
result of the game just what a comeback
he actually showed right after that
terrible game seven moment that he
experienced and that's the thing we talk
about he's already equalized the match
twice uh so far he needs to win one more
game to equalize it for the third time
it of course
is a complete Beast himself we've seen
how he almost in his demeanor has grown
over the board he asserts this
domination when he comes into the match
and there's so much at play right now
between these two players and uh
probably one more time because this is
your first day and I know that you will
be with us throughout the match with
your experience of the world
championship against a Magnus I also
know that you've been covering uh the
match on your c-square podcast I've been
loving those by the way uh if I had to
ask you for three conclusions that you
have drawn about this match so far
reaching up to game nine what would they
be
yeah I think two of them uh I already
mentioned which are the ability of them
to create chances winning chances it's a
very good sign for both of them
especially leading up to the final
moments of this match and when ding is
trailing it's a very good sign for him
especially
and the lack of taking defensive chances
seems to be a theme for me so those were
two
um I don't know the thirds the third
thing in the match
I'm I've been surprised by the variants
and openings for sure
we saw in previous matches that for
example Magnus sticks to his Marshall or
against me he stick he stuck to his
sweatshirt called rosalimo complex uh I
stuck to petroth and Queen's Gambit
declined against Magnus and my strategy
in that match was I prepare a bunch of
openings and then I will prepare
deviations within the openings so I'll
have room to maneuver but I won't have
to learn entire opening complexes
the strategy for these guys although he
Freon it seems like he's uh kind of
sticking to his guns and playing E4
mostly games but from from ding it's
basically just deviating every game
playing something new every game when
was the last time we saw this he's
played the Berlin the Marshall and the
French three completely different
openings that's a lot of stuff that you
have to uh understand in detail and uh
commit to memory as well a lot of
variations a lot of possible types of
positions that's definitely I think been
a theme at least from ding's point of
view
yeah I I just want to say uh one thing
about a comment you made earlier uh
Tanya is that Ding actually has had the
advantage for a large percentage of the
time in game seven and game eight the
result is only half a point out of two
games but he was the side for Choice he
actually I think played the better chess
by and large in those games but he froze
that's been the storyline but just the
result doesn't tell the full story and
on your point Fabi about preparation
about the types of openings we've seen
as a fan and a commentator I love it I
think it's very exciting but I think it
actually begs the question how do you
think ding chose his second in rigid
report how has that influence his
decision to play all sorts of different
openings because we'd know how Richard
plays he's a wild card you don't know
what you're gonna get from him in any
given game and so do you think that's
Richard's influence on dingly Ren and do
you praise it or do you think that there
are some regrets at this point
yeah I I think that that's a very
interesting question and I've I've
worked with Richard a tiny tiny bit a
few years ago uh so I I don't know
exactly how he prepares so much but we
do have some insight from his games and
his opening choices and he's a player
with a lot of interesting ideas one of
the
um I think narratives which is incorrect
is that he's basically playing random
stuff without preparation which is
completely untrue like when when you're
familiar with his opening choices and
and you see his moves you can tell that
of course he does analyze very seriously
he just usually does it in a path where
he feels his opponent won't be as well
prepared so he's trying to take his
opponent out of prep it's similar to in
some ways how Magnus is trying to
surprise opponents early on but still
using proper computer analysis and uh
and deep analysis to to to choose his
openings
and we see here ding is well prepared
like okay 986 not a very natural move to
me I mean usually I would think the
Knight goes to D7 uh
and we saw young was already a bit
surprised by C6 so ding has checked this
in detail he knows this line very well
which is a good sign but for me begs the
question why didn't he play the Berlin
earlier if
if I like know the Berlin well like why
in a world championship match why
wouldn't I play it earlier it would have
saved him a lot of headache I think in
the anti-martial lines
it's a good question life makes sense
backwards in hindsight of course there
are all these questions that you look at
and you've been mentioning this move
Knight A6 you are expecting a Central
Square for the night is the Knight
actually headed to the center regardless
of where we see it right now is Knight
C7 bringing it to the E6 square or what
ding is looking at and perhaps from
Knight C7 someday also hinting at a
potential B5
I I think certainly the other night uh
we'll probably go to C7 I don't think it
will go to C5 because I think the bishop
C5 looks excellent so you probably don't
want to to shake that up so Knight on C7
yeah could easily prepare B5 that uh
that could be anti-positional but I
don't see in this type of position
especially why not and always good to
gain space as long as your opponent
can't attack that A5 Pawn which would
suddenly be under a little bit of the
eye of the Rook on A1
I don't know if let's say in this
position I would necessarily want to
play a next move
but uh like okay for me I would start to
calculate critical moves here like
Knight to H4 Knight to F5 that would
that would be the first thing now
Knight H4 certainly looks very logical
and Knight F5 I think probably taken E4
is uh it's not working out very well for
whites take take E4 and you're not
attacking that E5 Pawn so so this
probably worked out but Knight H4 is a
very interesting move
and sometimes a typical idea is after 94
to play Knight G4 but here white would
have Knight H to F5 I think probably
winning the game
so
White's idea when Knight H4 is clear you
put the net on F5 and that's a very
annoying piece kicking the queen away
and uh
just installing a night where it can't
easily be chased away
but on the other hand maybe bishop to E6
is not a big deal for black you trade
the Bishops nine to five Queen drops
back to f8
slowly you try to get that neither
kicked away with uh it's not easy but
you know slowly you try to get maybe
King H7 Knight G8 G6 in the long run
the night is unpleasant but it's also
not like immediately attacking anything
so this might equalize very nicely for
black
I feel like it's the type of position
that you look at and you're like white
has to be better you have a knight on F5
your pieces are coordinated in natural
ways but there isn't a step forward from
here that's the big issue is even if a
knight plants of an F5 then what that's
the essential question there is no Rook
lift to make use of black has a rook on
the default maybe we'll see a second
Rook come over here and with these
Bishops probably going to be traded at
some point unless white steps backwards
there are vulnerable squares in the
position like D3 so I don't think that
this would be the end of the world for
dingley Ren and if we look at the
current position after Knight A6 I mean
Knight G3 is super logical here and it's
something it's just been played by Yanda
palmishi but dingley run doesn't have to
bring his Knight back just yet he can
also decide to bring his Bishop out
first maybe off for a trade I am looking
at this E5 Pawn hanging here there must
be tactics in the air uh but perhaps
that's too big of a pawn to give up on
this spot so yeah you have to be careful
that E5 Pawn is a bit loose only the
queen is defense it I don't see the
tactics after Bishop B6 and I takes E5
the only tactic I could potentially see
is Bishop to D6 but I think after white
takes on E6 white will have to deal with
uh Mission V6 Bishop takes e66 probably
take on E6 to get back why we'll have to
deal with the double G pawns I guess
Knight we'll move to F3 but white is
also have a pawn so uh I think white
doesn't care too much that the king size
Pawn structure is a bit spoiled and
Knight comes into D4 Pawn to E5 white
seems to also have an initiative so I
think Knight C7 is kind of
Queen to C7 wow whoa
wow it wasn't a move that was on our
radar how's that just sidestep this
threat that you were pointing out with
Knight H4 Knight F5 getting your queen
out of the way but the question that I
want to ask is then what's the night on
E6 doing Fabi well here it has to go to
C5 at this point I mean what else the
bishop will drop back and like goes to
C5 but I we C7 obviously it's
preparation but I would never consider
this move
I guess maybe Knight to H4 he wants to
play King to H7 then Bishop to f8 and G6
and then kind of cover all the F5 ideas
uh I don't know if King H7
because Bish Buffet I was wondering if
there's Knight to G6 and maybe getting
the bishop pair uh but I don't know if
this is a big deal for black even if you
do get the bishop error
and you can also Play Bishop D6 here I
guess
so
yeah maybe the Knight on G6 doesn't
really accomplish a whole lot it looks
great though right it's a knight on G6
you have to be attacking you have to be
doing well but I think that's a good
realization and phobic I mean when we
look at positions sometimes we see
something in our head we visualize it
and we're like no no I don't want to
allow it but then when you get to make
the moves on the board it makes chess a
lot easier because then we're like oh
that Knight on G6 it's not attacking me
anything I can move my king out the way
next and then your knight will simply
have to retreat
yeah after King like white has to act
right now to make use of the night King
H7 like you can maybe play Knight F5
here but I don't see the big deal if
Bishop F5 EF5 King H7 that goes back and
E4 maybe is is very annoying for white
and now we see like blacks all the black
pieces are coming into their ideal
squares Knight to C5 Bishop on D6 very
active Knight on H4 is obviously uh
completely cut off okay white can
exactly exchange but uh we'll have to
deal with Bishop H2 a potential pack
rank checkmates as well so
so this probably doesn't work out at all
for white
Queen C7 yeah it's clear like ding has
just prepared this opening in a lot of
detail uh you never play this over the
board without without knowing that it's
playable
and after Queen C7 we see Yan he is not
at the bot he's at his resting area
we've seen that happen quite a bit in
this match the players just having a
think waiting calming themselves down
after a move uh has been played uh Fabi
in your match against Magnus what was
that like did you guys have a specific
area where you could just withdraw cut
yourself off for a bit and focus on
what's going on
yeah we did we did have separate rest
areas
uh or actually were we in the same rest
area I think we we might have been
sharing one and Magnus had his own
little little refrigerator as well
he had like a refrigerator uh which was
dedicated to his drinks whatever it
might be
and the thing is I don't like to spend
too much time in the rest area just for
one specific reason it was basically I I
had a traumatic experience I was playing
Boris gelfond in 2013 and the towel
Memorial and I caught him in preparation
and I was just like sitting in the rest
area he's thinking for 40 minutes I'm
just sitting there at some point I'm
like almost falling asleep I'm looking
at the screen and my eyes are closing
he eventually plays a move
and I know that's not a very good move
and I get to the board and like within
three moves I just lose the game and I
start playing instantly I have all the
time in the world and I just like lose
the game like a complete idiot and since
then I have told myself yeah don't spend
any time in rest areas it's not good for
you
you know you should be at the board so I
I try not to to be in the rest area too
much but some players really do spend a
lot of time in their for example Magnus
very often
um yeah a lot of guys like to like to
enjoy the rest area
sharing a rest area that just sounds
quite a
not exactly a rest area but where
tension might even develop more when
you've got to be with your opponent in
the same place a bit here of course the
players do have their own rusting area
and right now we are on move 15 Queen C7
has been played by ding it looks like
things are under control right now Jan
chilling in his rest area thinking about
how he wants to respond uh try to create
his chances with the white pieces and
while Yan has a thing he will take his
time we will take this time to go into a
short break and we'll see you on the
other side
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
of the world championship match he plays
with the white pieces he's still in the
rest resting area not back to the board
but we can clearly see he's deep and top
hot and while he is we've got some great
news for our viewers our official
partners of the chess.com broadcast of
the federal Championship World Quant
they are a global firm that builds
complex mathematical models to identify
market inefficiencies and now World
Quant brain is bringing together its
International one championship and the
chess Community to hunt down the next
generation of One Finance Specialists
because nobody knows how to analyze a
position better than a chess player
right if you think you have what it
takes register for the international
Quan Championship head over to
go.chess.com iqc or use command iqc in
chat for more details
and we will be deep diving into the
action that we're seeing in a game nine
of the match Queen C7 finally
comes back to the board
are you expecting Fabi for him to Blitz
out has he had a complete thought over
in that resting area or do you think
he's gonna take his time a little more
trying to decide whether to go for the
night jump to F5 I think he needs to
take his time here because the
straightforward approaches like what we
were examining with Knight H4 Knight G6
those may just lead to very dull
equality so if he wants to try to out
think Ding and his preparation because
obviously ding is still prepared and
knows his position better than yondo's
so he needs to find something which ding
hasn't analyzed which means that it's
definitely possible because we're
already deep into the line so maybe ding
is not explore this position in so much
detail he might be surprised by move
let's say like Queen E2 or move that
isn't the first line of the engine here
but Yan will still need to have some
sort of idea because it's a subtle
position to we said that before if white
wants to prove an advantage he's going
to have to uh do prove it in a very
subtle way it's not going to immediately
jump out at you I suspect Queen E2 the
thing is white would love to get Knight
H4 Queen F3 in one go because then you
have threats like Bishop takes H6
but the queen on C2 is for the moment
not really contributing to the position
yeah if if black made those here I think
this is already super dangerous for
black like you're you're on the verge of
getting crushed because look at all of
White's pieces Knight G3 Knight H4
Bishop C1 Bishop C4 all contributing
contributing to the attack
uh so black of course cannot waste time
but I don't know if maybe Queen E2 F3 is
also too slow of an approach
one of the questions I'm having here is
what pieces do the sides want traded
we've only seen one Pawn off the board
for each player and so for example
Bishop E3 is that a step to just trading
off pieces maybe lead to equality or at
some point can black start thinking
about more than just trying to make a
draw these kind of positions are very
tender as you said there's a lot of
subtlety in them so what do you think
Bobby would move like Bishop E3 is that
the type of trade that should keep the
position stable or at what point does
Black start thinking I've done my job of
be getting equal position and I can try
to play for a victory
I think if Bishop E3 black is probably
not too concerned black bull I think
happily trade those Bishops and one of
the reasons why is because the bishop
and the Knight the Knight ris6 and the
bishop on C5 were both sharing one
square that they wanted to go to and I
think we would have likely seen if the
bishop sworn traded Black's Vision might
drop back to f8 so rather than that
white simply help black get rid of the
piece which was a little bit in the way
and then the Knight comes to C5
and uh black is ready for Bishop to E6
obviously the more trades we see the
less Dynamic potential White will have
to prove an advantage the other thing is
I don't like to work on E3 unless it's
like Knight H4 Rook F3 coming I don't
really see what it's doing there but I
don't really believe in this whole Rook
F3 business either
so yeah I wouldn't be too concerned by
black here but it is an approach at
least you are getting the Knight to F5 I
don't know if maybe King to H7 again
comes to mind or simply Bishop to E6
comes to mind
uh Bishop takes probably white will play
Knight takes
and Knight H to F5 I guess is logical
and black can probably safely play King
to H7 followed by G6 the thing about
this maneuver is it could be a strong
Knight but it could also just be a huge
waste of time for white so you might not
want to to embark on this maneuver
unless you're sure of the Knight on F5
is not going to get kicked away that's
why I don't like Bishop to E3 the other
thing about hp3 is that it weakens the
F4 Square for white
uh because the bishop no longer covers
that square so Black's Knight eventually
came comes out square as you were
highlighting in that position
yeah Bishop 3 is not on my radar as as a
critical move
yeah
very interesting moment here and we see
that Jan as you mentioned he should be
taking his time and that's exactly what
he's doing uh we haven't seen Yan slow
down as much in an opening phase to me
it appears as a ding is definitely happy
with the opening outcome for those of
you who are just joining us it started
with the Berlin Yan choosing the
anti-berlin with D3 and this is the
current uh position as we can see Robert
you're highlighting the opening so no
Asics no Spanish no martial but we had a
very solid approach it is critical for
dingler and to keep this game under
control Yan does lead the match with one
point and we can see in the current
position that we've got up that Yan is
thinking about the most direct option of
bringing the Knight into the game via F5
the one thing that stands out to me is
that there's just a single Pawn that has
been traded so far so it's definitely a
position where there are so many
possibilities and the rich board it
feels like a calm before a storm an
attack good Brew on the king's side how
much of an opening success do you feel
this has been Fabi taking into account
Yan's long think at this moment
yeah I think overall although the
opening is not finished so we can't
judge completely I think overall this
has been a very good opening for ding he
knows the position well uh and it's
going to be a headache for Jan in terms
of having the white pieces and not being
maybe able to know what to do against
the Berlin in future games and that's
why I think he should have started it
sooner because you want to give your
opponent that headache for the rest of
the match not when he's already had you
know his fair share of wins and chances
and good positions with white actually
while Jana's thinking I wanted to dive
into an earlier moment because one of
the uh sort of training games that
people are speculating on started after
D3 Bishop C5
and here Bishop takes C6 it's one of my
favorite moves to play
D takes C6
my B to D2
Bishop to E6
White Castle's short I played like this
many times myself Bishop to D6 Knight to
B3
A5
Queenie one
A4 Knight A5 and queen to B8 and this
was one of those training games which of
course we don't know for sure if the
players were uh were playing them but
I was interested in this position
because I've played this line of white
it's a super interesting line and I
wonder if um that's why I had a feeling
that maybe ding was like possibly wanted
to choose the Berlin because if they're
analyzing this line I can't imagine that
thing wants to play E4 in this match
with the white pieces so the only
explanation for why they're playing
training games in this position maybe
they just want to play training games
but the other explanation is that
they're actually interested in this from
the Black Point of View because it's a
topical position so uh and it doesn't
look like a topical position it looks
like some random mess but they were
actually playing Knight G5 here and it's
some sort of theory which is is quite
relevant in fact yeah you play this
against lamlay in the Champions chest or
the chest with Masters and of course
this hasn't played the highest levels
and dingley red himself in many
positions he does bring that Queen to A7
in the Italian game so we have seen
these type of ideas from him uh well I
guess it's more of the it starts in the
Spanish it turns into an italian-like
position but this is definitely in in
dingley Ren's wheelhouse but Fabi a big
question that I'm having as we get to
the game position dingley run suddenly
is up almost 20 minutes and I know I was
kind of asking a leading question was
like can black start playing for more
but I feel like how could you not think
about that first you want to equalize
you want to make a draw if it's
available to you and then get white
pieces in the next game but if y'all
continues to burn clock and then starts
thinking too ambitiously as you said
players with the white pieces they want
to make the most of the first move
Advantage they don't want to just allow
a simple draw I feel like ding is way
more comfortable here and this could
give him confidence so for Jan what do
you see his future being in this
position do you think at some point
he'll just trade off pieces and make
that draw or does he really want to
fight on
yeah I can speak to experience here that
very often I I play these positions in
let's say rapid games with the white
pieces and God now played because you
want to be ambitious and once it becomes
an equal position and you still feel
like I'm I'm playing with the white
pieces I need to you know press my
opponent and that's when it starts to
get dangerous so as you mentioned if
he's getting too ambitious in an equal
position
this is a position which could go both
ways I mean it's it's very much a matter
of subtle differences so we saw some
lines where white trades the dark Square
Bishops and black knight gets to C5 and
this is already a potential positional
Advantage for black because we can think
of because of the Central Pawn structure
the the light uh the widespread Bishop
is maybe a bit of a worse piece under
Bishop on C8 and we're looking forward
to the future in some end games where
you know the E4 Pawn is more easily
attacked by a Black's Bishop than by
whites and if black gets control of that
D3 Square because at the moment he has
more control over the D file then he
could put some pressure on White on that
D file so there's definitely things for
both sides to look forward to
potentially and I'm sure ding is super
comfortable now I mean he knows a
position he has more time uh everything
opening wise is going his way but
objectively still the position is is
pretty much equal
and Bobby were mentioning that the
opening phase isn't completely over and
we see our eval bar say that black is
equal right now ding has done everything
right so far but are there still a few
critical moves to be made by ding to
make sure that he gets the kind of
middle game that he's looking at or is
it is it the kind of position where
you've got the margin to take different
approaches different plans
I think in this position probably there
is a wide choice for each player on each
move although if white plays
aggressively with Knight H4
and we did not see that move we saw the
bishop drop back to A2
and I don't fully
understand this move
um
I'm guessing that he's kind of waiting
for Bishop to f8 so he can develop his
Bishop to E3 and then after Knight C5 he
wants to contest the D file
because you don't want to deal with
potential Knight D3 stuff although it's
not a big threat at the moment but
what's the big deal here uh
I guess black can't easily Play Bishop
to E6 because Bishop takes C5
oh maybe that's his idea so Bishop E6
Bishop C5 and now with the bishop on C4
you could take on C4 with the division
182 after Bishop by two Bishop f8
take on f8 again and then there's B3
trapping the bishop maybe that's why he
wants this bishop on A2
uh otherwise the bishop doesn't seem
like a better piece than on C4 but that
could be an explanation for the move
that's a super deep rationale and Fabi
we rely on you to come up with reasons
for a bishop retreating to A2 uh but I I
think your initial sense if I'm reading
you correctly I've known you for a long
time you're kind of like I wasn't
expecting that move it seems kind of
ambiguous it doesn't actually threaten
anything
um is yawn really out of his comfort
zone I feel like black is perfectly
solid here
um and Bishop A2 a retreating move after
a long think it feels like it's just
kind of aimless in a way yeah I I think
for sure he's out of his comfort zone
because whenever your opponent is
playing quickly and you know they have
computer analysis on their side you
don't like it and you want to avoid that
at all costs so you basically you take
the first opportunity to make a move
which you kind of know is a little bit
inferior but you just don't want to be
playing against a computer and that's
pretty much what Bishop A2 seems to be
because obviously I think it's starting
to think and it's very unlikely that
he's analyzed this move and if we go
back into that line where after Rook 8d1
um or Rook eats D1 I'm not 100 sure
which is more logical I think black can
can maybe trade and then play B5 I'm not
sure this is a bit of a double-edged
approach
but it doesn't look immediately bad
because you're you're balancing the
structure as you mentioned maybe black
will someday want to be ambitious
uh
still white does have B4 here which
um will probably be met by Knight to A4
so actually that doesn't look very good
for white
and although apparently it's also
completely fine for white so
yeah it might be one of those positions
where the balance is hard to disrupt
both sides have a lot of freedom of of
decent moves but I like this for black
it's an Unbound structure and you know
you have a potential past a pawn maybe
one day if things go well they start to
go really well and that Bishop on C8 can
go to B7 and now it starts to put
pressure on the E4 Pawn so
I wonder if this will be the direction
that both uh Yan and ding will be
looking at
wow the analysis board that you've just
got up in front of us and all these
lines that you're discussing with the
bishop getting trapped on A2 the op the
queen side opening up it really looks
like the kind of position that has so
much more poison than what meets the eye
at first glance and Robert you mentioned
something really interesting about Yan
perhaps being out of his comfort zone
because For the first time in a long
time right Jan makes a move Bishop A2
and doesn't immediately leave his chat
he waited he was sitting there until
ding got back and only now when ding is
having a sink which is an implication
that perhaps this isn't a top move or
the move that wasn't dings preparation
does Ian decide uh to take to that
resting area one more time Bishop edu
played and once again there are
innocuous looking moves you could try to
trade the bishop to E6 move that Queen
to E7 create that square on C7 or fall
back with your own Bishop uh to f8 we've
seen
so much drama in this world championship
match and we've seen psychology at play
we've seen amazing opening preparation
Fabi as you've been pointing out we've
seen missed opportunities tactical
blowout and wow ding keeping up with the
clock this time and he strikes on the
queen side this is a move that we
mentioned a while back and Fabi it's
happened B5 on the board I love it
I didn't expect it to happen so quickly
because I thought black had prepared a
bit more first because this doesn't
create a threat with the Knight on C5 it
creates a threat on that takes A4 so
white doesn't have to immediately react
to this you don't have to take you
um I think basically there's a sort of
standoff between the bishop on C5 and
the bishop on C1 white is waiting for
that Bishop to go back to f8 so that the
bishop would go to E3 black is waiting
with the bishop to go back so that white
can't move that Bishop so comfortably to
E3
and yeah B5 I'm surprised he played it
so quickly I mean it would is Bishop A2
still some sort of like preparation from
thing like does ding know the move or is
he just super confident and knows his
position is good so why why stress it
let's continue to put pressure on the
opponent uh again I'm looking at Knight
H4 here
it looks super logical as as always to
put the Knight on H4 I'm also looking at
Queen to E2 at some moment because now
it has like a dual purpose maybe attacks
at put on B5 but
then I'm thinking okay B takes A4 or
something something I have to consider
as well so
Queen to E2 it really makes a lot of
sense to me this move
because if B takes A4 sorry sorry no no
I was about to say I'm glad to show it
on the board B takes A4 it looks really
ugly but what's the plan here
I think Bishop to C4 so black doesn't
want to to be saddled with those A and C
pawns so black might try A3 to get rid
of that and I don't know if B3 is an
option here it might very well be it's
like typical you try to take on A3 with
the bishop so you don't have the um
the pawns that are getting separated you
want to keep your you know your Pawn
Islands intact so let's let's call them
that and if Queen to E7 tried to defend
that pawn then maybe now Knight to H4 it
maybe now it's time Bobby do you like
the idea of Knight H4 I'm not sure you
know I know for a fact is that what you
want to have on the board
with Queen D7 I like it
I without creating seven I'm always
unsure about this move but I I keep
saying that H4 so probably it seems like
I have some sort of special attachment
to this move but I just want to attack
that Queen
it looks good though it looks good for
white because this Pawn is likely going
to be picked up at some point and the
split Pawn structure here is not what
you want so I don't think ding really
wants to take on A4 and nobody wants to
compromise their structure on the queen
side like that but Queen E2 a nice
multi-purpose move probably a good
reaction to this B5 Choice and then
Knight H4 does look much more attempting
hmm yeah well I'm loving it right this
is an opening that we don't expect to
fire up so quickly with this last move
by ding it's game on he's he's willing
to create something on the board take
his chances with the black pieces not
playing the Super safe options uh that
we've been discussing maneuvering the
pieces he feels he's ready to strike on
the queen side he does it and now it's a
standoff there you're mentioning the
line with giving up the A4 Pawn a
temporary sacrifice but Nepal is also
perhaps considering just changing the
pawn structure by taking on B5 and then
maybe putting pressure on that B5 Pawn a
takes P5 C takes B5 Queen E2 will attack
that pawn on B5 and whatever is the case
the fact that Ding has gotten nepo to
think early on in the game I think
that's a great sign for for team Ding
and dingler and fans right now ding
playing confidently in this one uh and
Fabi is there an option for Yan to
consider changing the pawn structure by
actually capturing on B5 you were
talking about the positional drawbacks
of a potential break like the one that
we're seeing right now by ding what are
these potential drawbacks
yeah all things being equal I I feel
some sort of repulsion towards the move
a takes P5
and it's mostly because I feel like
Black's a pawn will come to A4 after ab5
cb5 and we'll kind of fix White's pawns
and it's it feels like black gains a lot
of space the only situation where I feel
like that's positionally motivated is if
white can get a knight to D5 but those
Knights are so far away from D5 I don't
see that happening and I don't see a
reason to trade off the a pawn for the C
Pawn sometimes we say you know Central
poems are more valuable than than uh
Hans on on the a h files but it's not
always the case and here I feel like the
change in structure helps black for for
another reason uh I do feel like
Bishop's B7 becomes an option and and
you put some pressure on the E4 Pawn so
I I don't see on plan a takes B5
is very logical
now I wonder how
yeah I wonder how thing reacts because
if B takes A4 maybe isn't an ideal
approach but it might actually be
because what I'm thinking is after B
takes A4 Bishop to C4
that black doesn't play A3 and the
reason why is black maybe takes the time
to drop the bishop back somewhere
and I'm not 100 sure where but let's say
Bishop's f8 and if Rook takes A4 now
black gets Knight C5 with tempo
let's say to A1
and black I don't know if A4 is possible
because of B4 or if it's desirable maybe
B4 is really annoying so but ideally if
black could get this A4 then it would be
a very good thing because although the A
and C pawns are isolated that a pawn is
sort of restricting White's pause it
and if black could get an extra move
here like Rook to B8 I think black would
be doing very well but yeah this B4 here
is annoying so it's definitely a
difficult moment for black like you have
to make a decision here you either
protect B5
or you or you take on A4 I don't see
other logical moves uh playing B4 is by
the way a enormous positional mistake I
feel
um because it's like the bishop comes to
C4 and and just feels very ugly
to to do this you allow an outpost on
that C4 Square
so definitely a critical decision for
ding at this point
critical
mom in this game one thing's for sure
after B5 this is going to be a close
game and it has also been a very close
match between world number two yeah and
well number three ding Lauren so many
Dynamics at play in this one and one of
the things that we've often heard the
Chess World speak about the pundits the
best players in the world this slight
advantage that that Jana Palmer she has
in this match going into his fight for
the world championship has been his
world championship match experience he
played in Dubai in the 2021 match
against Magnus Carlsen our very own
Daniel naroditsky spoke to Jan about
that experience
I mean every unsuccessful game is a
lesson and of course
uh the main the main thing I I took away
from this match was my experience and
experience was quite quite sad but uh
maybe it was that's why it was quite
useful yeah I mean even like in in the
middle of the match I would say even
until I started let's say like
blundering everything in one move uh I
would say that
I came to sort of a conclusion that okay
it's pretty much different uh comparing
to what I carefully you know to what I
have expected so now I'm like in in
awake and can model
let's say uh the match how it goes how
it might go so for example uh my general
idea all right so between candidates you
should like win like three or four games
to win match you should do in one game
and loss zero yes I mean it's also quite
quite a childish approach I think yeah
so speaking of the upcoming match it's
um I mean surely I think it's I wouldn't
say it's like my only Advantage
comparing to Dean but uh it's one of
like very important things that uh
already okay I have like uh more or less
a bitter experience but uh nevertheless
that's an experience I'm not sure if
he's like pretty much used to you know
this type of Chess of course he's
playing some matches like here and there
but they're like four games six games
it's it's not quite the same it's not
the same level of excitement involvement
and preparation so probably probably
this will favor me
yeah and Matt Carlson please 2021 world
championship match in Dubai and we
in which Bayan after game six he
mentioned that it wasn't a pleasant
experience but definitely things that he
took away which is why we find him today
at this stage that he is in this match
against thing lyrin and Fabi I want to
ask you what we witnessed in that 21
match with the game six and what
happened after the aftermath of game six
the collapse that we witnessed by Yan
how big a role does that play in
understanding what it takes to deal with
these difficult situations in a world
championship
I think it's a very individual thing
because a match like that can destroy
you
or it can teach you it can cause trauma
it can you know
you could have them in the back of your
mind always that you know I I lost in
such a dramatic Fashion on the biggest
stage in the trust world uh and you
always have in the back of your mind I
don't want that to happen again
I do feel like Jan has a lot of mental
fortitude and he probably took more
lessons away from that than the trauma
that that it gave him which for sure you
know he
he does have some unpleasant memories
and at the time I'm sure it was uh the
most unpleasant emotions you can imagine
playing chess you know and in front of
millions of people you are uh you're
losing game after game but we saw from
his comeback in the candidates which was
a remarkable
um
I mean just remarkable tournament for
him like in terms of his level of play
and his uh let's say General stability
compared like that's what really
separated him from other players that he
was the only player I think who showed
stability from start to finish and I
can't think of anyone else who
um you know players have their good and
good and bad moments but he only had
good moments and I was I didn't expect
to see that that level of yam in that
tournament but when when he's at his at
his best he's really uh you know one of
the best
um not only in the world but one of the
best ever
so
thing as well uh you know when he's at
his best he can basically play like a
complete machine
and get the role of experience it's it's
a difficult one you know I can save from
my first candidates that I didn't know
anything and my preparation was childish
but somehow I became very close to
winning that candidates with no
experience and then my last candidates
with all the experience in the world uh
I I basically
um played like a child at some point in
that in that tournament so you never
know what the role of experience will
bring sometimes it might be good
sometimes you might not have learned
your lesson from the past tournaments
yeah that makes a lot of sense Fabi I
think there's nothing that can replicate
experience as you're mentioning and
normally I'm the one who's gonna dive
into the conversation but I have this
feeling that I wouldn't dive into the
chest right now if that's okay I have
one variation it's a pawn sacrifice so I
I'm hoping that we can analyze it and
I'm thinking is considering it as well
what if he gives up this Pawn is that
out of the question for him to drop the
bishop back to f8 and give up a Pawn on
B5 just for the compensation of this
week D3 Square the bishop heading to A6
is this worth the pawn
I I do like this about this idea a lot
actually and I'm even seeing some other
tactics because
it's clear that Bishop Basics just
friends doing the queen so white has to
deal with that urgently and I can see no
other way than the queen to E2
I don't see how else you're going to
deal with that threat
and Bishop to A6
there's also Knight to D3 Bishop to C4
I'm a bit I'm wondering about this
position because there is like this
Knight to B3 tactic but I'm not sure it
works
um probably because simply Rook to A4
I'm also not sure if Bishop A6 uh Bishop
Basics 9a1 Bishop C4 back is is very
good for black
so yeah there's probably tactically
isn't working
um
although you always have A4 I wonder
maybe bishop takes H6 at some point
comes into play in this type of position
it might actually be the issue at some
point like I said Bishop C4 maybe bishop
takes H6
and uh and you end up getting two pawns
for the exchange which is it's probably
a bit too much for black to handle
so yeah there's a lot of like sharp
tactics here I wonder
like if you if you play Bishop of Fate
you have to calculate take take take
Knight C5 Queen to E2
and whatever this brings I I don't know
what this is Knight to D3 is also very
tempting here Rook D1 Bishop A6 now
super tempting option you have very very
interesting idea
I love it I mean I I hardly love it
because I suggested it but in all
seriousness I'm looking at this position
and Black's pieces are just firing away
in all cylinders I feel like black has
better coordination better activity but
a pawn is a pawn so you don't make the
most of it it could really backfire
but here I'm like this is very close to
just being really bad for white I mean
you have C4 as maybe a bailout maybe
that's what you should do because I'm
thinking if you play Queen C2 it's night
before just winning on the spot
maybe not but I I was I was worried how
is White's uh surviving this position
um
probably just queen queen B3 but I was
thinking like I have a for you probably
have Queen takes F7
or do you have Bishop C4
Bishop C4 yeah Bishop C4 is probably
super strong
yeah that seems to just uh finish it off
wow what a weird position because the
problem for black at the end here is
once the queen is captured this Knight
takes this bishop here and somehow these
pieces survive like it looked like they
would be in trouble but black has a
piece and a queen for two Rooks too much
material
so let's go back after Bishop to f8
because let's see what happens if white
doesn't take that pawn
does White have any other sensible
options here
yeah but Knight H4 Knight C4 Knight C5
you have to deal both with Knight D3 and
and Knight takes A4 and B takes A4 so
this is a this doesn't look like white
has time to
to get some kind of queen F3 in maybe
white can take on B5 taken and try to
get Queen F3 in
but I'm not believing it so much
Knight's D3 or something
Bishop H6 91 rookie one okay it's it's
potentially interesting
it's funny it's only interesting for
commentators and for fans but I think if
you're playing white you want none of
this position you definitely don't want
to allow this kind of activity for
dingler in and even just statically just
looking just visually looking at these
lines with the Knight jumping into D3 it
could get bad for white super quickly in
this moment that we have and ding not
taking the decision to take on A4 Robert
he's definitely thinking about your idea
of just offering this Pawn sacrifice
we've been thinking about that Knight on
A6 where it's headed it could very well
become the star piece in Black's
position I've been washing his eyes and
he is definitely looking at the side of
the board I mean he must no matter what
decision he makes about the B5 Pawn but
to me it just looks like energetic play
and that's what's been missing in some
key moments from ding's perspective and
I think that you know when he's in top
form his Fabiano said he is one of the
absolute best calculators not just of
the present day but of all time and just
looking at this position it's not easy
to see how white deals with the various
threats you may want to just develop
your Bishop I think maybe some people
will be looking at that but then you're
inviting some pressure down the B line
that B2 Pawn will be hanging or Robert
here Bishop to A6 is is forcing Bishop
takes F7 or queen A5 with the peace
sacrifice yeah that's because otherwise
the queen is trapped and I don't know if
this piece it's
it's Rook A5 and then also E5 is hanging
so probably white is is no worse here
because I mean Knight to D3 I guess
black is not really risking much but uh
but white is going to get four pawns but
potentially for
Bishop I was that was a 97. I mean I
guess I could just yeah I was thinking
like 95 take take and I I guess that
this is a position which is very likely
to end in some sort of equality
yeah but yeah do you really want to sack
a piece with white I can't imagine yeah
I'm going for that sort of thing not
easy to see this from so far away either
you have to calculate so many other
variations along the way that now this
doesn't look fun to work through
yeah definitely I I don't think that
young would take the pawn in case of
Bishop's f8 that's my feeling that he
would most likely try to play around a
bishop to E3 Knights of C5
maybe take on E5 and then follow it up
with some sort of
move but it's not easy to see them move
both E4 is hanging and and Knight D3 is
on the cards so
on the other hand how are you evaluating
just trading on C5 and getting that B4
in using some tactics of Bishop F7 in
the air
so Bishop takes C5 Bishop takes C5 B4
and black drops the bishop back but
where does the bishop go back to E6 is
very logical
keep an eye on F2
how you can take on B5 right yeah I'm
damned to pick up that one in the spirit
of yasa
yeah and E5 is hanging that's super
important so Bishop Basics was met by
Queen takes E5 and yeah maybe white can
can safely grab uh the B5 pod in that
case
so Bishop C5 it's it's a position which
is uh it's a move which is very
physically undesirable but concretely it
might work out okay maybe bishop to D6
here in this case
so so that after Queen takes B5 black
will be able to
um you know uh have the E5 Pawn
protected and maybe they're still
hanging North Abby after Bishop A6
how is E5 hanging or A5 yeah I was
thinking more like Queen Tech C3 here if
it's possible
um B takes A5 yeah you're are you
winning this Pawn because we can try to
chase that Queen so first of all yeah
any taking on A5 is made by Bishop F7
but can we chase that Queen away with
Bishop to D7 or something just showing
off the various tactics this gets very
complicated so no wonder ding is
investing so much time but hey he's down
a point in the match and he doesn't have
to win this game he has plenty of games
remaining but you know he's thinking can
I get some chances to even up the score
not here this would uh be bad we just
were going through some various lines
here but I mean it's upon sacrifice but
I don't like the look of B takes A4 I'm
gonna be honest that looks like a very
ugly Pawn structure so to me Bishop f8
it seems like much more in the spirit of
an energetic play versus maybe a future
passive defense
yeah Robert completely love this line
that we've been looking at and analyzing
and I'm I'm gonna make a prediction here
I think ding will offer this Bond
sacrifice I think he will make the move
Bishop to f8 and we will have fireworks
well he is navigating all these
variations currently looking at this
line Bishop f8 so tricky with that
Knight jumping in and just to close that
thought I do like the idea of yan
considering of trading that dark Squad
Bishop for the night Jan currently in
his resting area undoubtedly also
thinking about these positions where
black might get the initiative while
ding makes a decision we will go into a
shot break and be right back
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chest tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists it sounds very exciting you
put your skills in practice in a case
competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up World Quant is
seeking new talent and new energy and
it's looking at the world of Chess to
help because nobody knows how to analyze
a position better than a chess player
right no Quan experience no problem
so
do you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
okay
welcome back everyone we are inside the
glass the glass room off the Saint Regis
Hotel where currently the two
challengeshi and dingler and are etching
their name into history this is game
nine welcome everyone and for those of
you who are just joining us I'm your
host International Master Tanya sachdev
alongside me Grandmaster Robert has and
of course former World Championship
challenge at Super Grandmaster Fabiano
caruana bringing you all the analysis
the insights the Deep dives into the
minds of these two incredible Fighters
currently dingleren is in a think tank
in a very critical moment of the game we
see action on sides divide the board
into half it looks like janapamnushi is
eyeing the king side while dingler in
creating play on The Queen side Fabi
when we went into the brick we were
looking at options at different moves
capturing on A4 the bishop Retreat
fighting for initiative
thing shows a different one and I see
the eval bar it was not accurate is this
trouble for dink
I don't like his move I don't know how
much it gives white initiative but I
thought that b takes A4 or Bish Buffet
the idea to sacrifice the pawn that we
mentioned was just a bit more Dynamic
and you know putting pressure on white
either calculate something we were
mentioning some lines where white gives
up
automatic move like white has no other
ideas the whole point of Queen E2 was to
try to get that Queen to F3 quickly so
Knight to H4 all of my queen F3 is the
idea and now dig starts thinking again
it feels like again it's not a very
practical approach he's he's giving you
on easy moves and then he's taking
difficult decisions for himself and now
he's starting to think again and the
time is equalized we've mentioned time
Advantage now it's pretty much not there
anymore
and white Saxony was pretty simple I
mean it's going to be Queen to F3 right
uh I guess Bishop's f8 can be met by I
don't know if you take a B5 first or or
maybe Queen F3 first but you play Queen
F3 with the idea of taking on H6 with
the bishop exploiting the fact that
black if he takes back will drop the
Knight on F6
so I don't know okay Bishop fate still
feels very logical to me here but it
might not the thing is what else do you
do at this point
what other because if you put the bishop
on E7 you always get that Bishop attack
from Knight F5 so
which other move is logical besides
Bishop to f8
yeah I think Bishop f8 is the move to
play but it just feels like White's
pressure is mounting and black is a bit
slow I understand the impulse to defend
your Pawn dingler invested a lot of time
at that moment but Rook B8 that was a
mistake I mean you see the evaluation go
from about level to immediately being
better for the white pieces and there
are many reasons why but it's because
black is now saddled with passive
defense whereas the line we're looking
at instead of Rook to B it was Bishop f8
yes white gains a pawn in the position
but you see Black's pieces start flying
in we were talking about Knight D3 ideas
Bishop A6 Maven trap the queen Rook can
come to B8 semi-open file there's a pawn
at the end of it this would have been
energetic active play for dingley Ren
instead he made this move Rook to B8
can't really blame him for it but I just
feel like he's you know he's trying to
withstand the pressure without coming
with pressure of his own and then 90 H4
happens and he's in that deep think once
again just to show fabi's point that
after Bishop f8 Queen F3 let's say you
bring this Knight in yes my Knight's
finally activated Bishop takes H6 is
available because if you take back on H6
your knight lost its Defender this would
be out of the question because Black's
king would be In Harm's Way
I feel like it's still after Bishop text
H6 a critical position because black can
grab some Pawns of his own normally you
really don't want to
to lose that H6 Pawn because that Bishop
G5 comes with a really dangerous looking
attack
uh this this looks terrible yeah Bishop
G5 comes I don't know if like something
to D3 Maybe
Rook or Knight to D3 after Bishop takes
H6 is
is a I would never go for this with
black but maybe
it's playable
on the other hand like you just worry
that you get a checkmated right even if
white sacrifices material you just get
checked made it because all those I mean
four pieces around Black's King the
bishop 182 also participating that's a
lot of attacking pieces
looks bad I mean the Evo bar doesn't
hate it so much maybe there's a way to
defend sometimes you have to take with
the b-pawn and then put your knight on
B3 your best defense is just stopping
that long range piece and actually the
evaluation Bar says that black has
sufficient counter play this is not a
lost position it just looks really
dangerous I think from a human
perspective it's really hard to play
much more fun to play with the white
pieces I think maybe the point is that
Bishop G5 there's a disruptive move Rook
to D3
I'm not sure that's the reason why but
otherwise I don't see how you deal with
the bishop G5 idea and here if Rook to
E3 now black takes and white has to
misplace a piece the queen uh if Queen
takes E3 maybe Knight to H7 is suddenly
you know not not so clear anymore like
that Knight was pinned to The Rook on d8
but with the Rook on suddenly black has
some time to to coordinate some defense
so on the other hand I would be too
scared to go for this I would look for
an alternative
yeah I'm thinking King to H7 after
Knight to H4 is also a logical move
okay so you're saying start with King H7
yeah but I'm still not sure if Queen F3
is good and I'm also a bit worried about
Knight to H5 but I'm not super worried
about Knight H5
your point is that with the trade that
F7 oh okay so don't trade you're in big
trouble I think Queen to E7 might be
okay after Knight to H5
might be
it's it's still a dangerous position
because white has like Queen to F3 here
and uh
certainly
I mean certainly has its own dangers for
black just because there's so many
pieces on the K on the king side and the
Knight on A6 is not participating in the
in the defense it's it's more white
pieces that are attacking
looks terrible I'm gonna be honest I'm
looking in this position I've had
positions like this from the black side
you just feel like white is increasing
the pressure you know attacking this
nice at the very least I can double your
pawns on the next move so even if I
don't Checkmate you or win the game I
will have a much better end game and
actually F7 is hanging as soon as I was
trying to finish my point like let's say
you make some defensive move you have to
trade Queens because your King's in wide
open but trading Queen simply loses this
Pawn down here on F7 so this is just not
looking very pleasant yeah this is bad I
after Queen to F3 I guess black is at
this point obligated to take on H5 most
likely and then Queen takes H5
and I was thinking Queen F6 first but
then I saw Knight to F3 is just like
attacking everything so Queen F6 doesn't
even like work out at all uh because E5
and F7 and Knight G5 are all threats now
so
so black would have to dig deep to um I
think it's 1986 like it's it's a
double-edged sword you know it could
become very good piece on C5 but for the
moment it's out of the game you you kind
of
have an urgent positional problem to to
solve which is get that item to the game
get it to C5
wow all these lines that you guys have
been pointing at it looks like it could
be trouble for thing he needs to be
super careful and it all comes down to
this move Rook B8 right everything
looked absolutely fine before he made
this move and now suddenly the attack on
the king side looking a lot more
dangerous it always does right and if
you divide the board into two halves and
one player is playing for activity on
the queen side and the others going for
the king it just looks extremely scary
especially when you've got two knights
the Queen the bishop joining into it uh
ding Robert is he feeling the pressure
right now he definitely is I mean he was
up about 20 minutes a couple moves ago
but his last few moves they've been
cautious but overly so Rook to B8 it's
we get it you're protecting a pawn that
was under attack but fabi's first
instinct was the take on A4 realizing
that I can't just play defensive chess
this bishop is in the night Square uh
sometimes we refer to squares as
turnstiles as pieces that can take their
turn jumping into them this the C5
square is taken by the black Bishop but
the Knight needs to be there and playing
Bishop of Fate Queen F3 you just don't
have the time because H6 is hanging and
the Knight on F6 is loose I do not like
this position at all for dingley Wren it
seems very difficult to play I don't
care what the eval Bar says
I completely agree with you uh Robert
and to Echo that thought take a look at
the clock situation dingler in in a big
Think Tank he's the one for the first
time in game nine who now falls behind
on the clock to Jana pamushi it is a
narrative that we've seen in the world
championship it is something that has
come to Haunting in those critical
moments well the moments are just
getting started uh take a look at what
ding had to say about his struggles
dealing with time pressure in the world
championship
of course the best way is to play as
quickly and as good as possible but
you know the position after the opening
very very unclear and there are many so
many options for me so I have to figure
out which was the best way to continue
and it cost me a lot of time
and I think the time
spent during the first half the game was
needed
because I guess I pray some good good
moves or maybe not the best but I
at least I was not worse
it's just because I didn't cover the
advantage when I have the chance
only thing slowing down having a big
thing as it looks like Jana Pam Nishi
has managed to create initiative on the
king's side and as I was saying it ding
does make the move Bishop Retreat coming
all the way back to f8 how critical was
it Robert according to you to not burn
the clock too much at this particular
moment it's essential we've seen what
happens when ding is in time trouble he
gets flustered and this game is Just
heating up it's going to get sharper and
Jan's moves are easy Fabiano's plan is
about to be seen on the board where the
queen comes up to F3 there's a threaded
Bishop takes H6 and blacks decisions
every single one will be difficult for
the foreseeable future so I think that
dingley Ren he's doing okay on the clock
right now but there's no increment and
with one hour and 11 minutes to make 22
moves that is a ton because this king is
not a happy camper
yeah I think that the time situation is
going to be in his head because he knows
that once he gets into time trouble it's
a time kind of time trouble that can be
disastrous as we saw from from like game
seven
and so about the position I actually was
having a thought because if white starts
with queen F3
Knight to C5 variation that we were
examining
and
now we said that if Bishop H6 there was
some kind of btx A4 and it wasn't super
clear and if white takes on B5
immediately instead of Bishop H6
black has this intermedium of knights D3
I think
and if you can trade off the bishop and
C1 White's attack pretty much evaporates
instantly so I'm wondering if maybe why
it's most accurate is to take on B5
first
instead of Queen F3
so you get them
yep
you get rid of all those B takes A4 and
Knight takes A4 ideas cb5 only move
which makes sense Queen to F3 now and
now Knight C5 Bishop page six is a whole
different story you can't recapture the
pawn so you kind of just lose Pawn with
black but you do open up the sixth ring
so black maybe can use another piece to
defend that's the downside of having the
C6 Pawn removed yeah that's what I was
thinking but after Rook B6 there's
Bishop to E3 and you kind of have
another difficult moment do you want to
play Bishop to C5 you're you're you're
taking
a lot of time with that one piece now
but what other move do you have I mean
do you want to put your Rook on C6 it
looks very odd there
and yeah maybe bishop C5 maybe it's not
so bad or black but
it's it's double edged I'm kind of
considering Bishop takes H6 already but
I don't believe it works
um because gh6 Knight G2 F5 it comes
with the thread of Checkmate but
probably King to H7 covers everything
but yeah these are the sorts of lines
that might be going through the player's
heads
and Jan didn't even think by the way he
just he moved he went Queen F3 he's not
taking he's not allowing dink to defend
that King side he's going for the attack
plays such an important role in this
match he's off throughout the match Jan
strategy has been really clear in the
opening phase even if he doesn't go far
well the most direct line he just makes
sure that everything is under control
and leaves ding to take the most
critical decision when he has an
advantage on the plot and we've seen
ding struggle with those Fabi as you
were mentioning and once again now that
Yan feels that shift in the momentum he
did slow down earlier on in the game
making that move Bishop A2 Yan is doing
Yan things now he's just back he makes
the move quickly puts the pressure on
it's easier for him to make these
attacking moves Queen to F3 on the board
and ding move by move every single move
taking his time he's really starting to
burn the clock Fabi if you had to make a
prediction will clock be a big factor
for ding in this one
I feel like yes they are likely going to
get into time trouble or at least sting
will likely again to time travel yawn
seems to be speeding up so much and he's
doing his typical uh thing which is a
psychological tactic uh but it works for
him because he he quickly kind of feels
what the right move more or less should
be and then I think a lot of people a
lot of top players will feel what the
right move should be or at least one of
like the one of the Right Moves Like
Queen F3 but then they want to calculate
and be precise and hesitate and he can
kind of put that out of his head
psycholog that's just a psychological
thing he's he doesn't mind giving up a
little bit of control uh the upside beam
that he puts a lot of pressure on his
opponent I mean it's unpleasant to face
when your your opponent is just thinking
and you don't have time you're you never
have time to think on his clock it's
always on your own and you see your
clock ticking down you have to calculate
variations and you're feeling the
pressure
so that's it's unpleasant on the other
hand it is a double-edged thing of
course because
you can't get as deep in your
calculations when you're playing as
quickly right so if there comes a moment
when the natural move is not so good it
could be that yawn makes an imprecise
move
but in this case this is the right
decision he's putting a lot of pressure
on ding
I have a question for you though because
Dane came well prepared he was up on
time how demoralizing it is it when you
play what seems like very good opening
uh repertoire and then you're the one
down the clock and struggling to find
equality because your king is in trouble
like this
yeah I think it really does come down to
after the opening there are usually some
critical moments and The Rook to be
eight move that was a critical moment
you have to feel when those moments are
that you you can take your time on those
moments you just need to feel where it
is you take your time and you choose the
right decision and it makes all of your
uh decisions after that much easier so
it actually saves you time if you take
the time then and he did take the time
but he made the wrong decision I'm quite
surprised in fact I Rook V8 because I
don't know if BB takes A4 was the best
move I don't know if Bishop I think it
was the best move but it really feels
like Rook to be it is giving your
opponent the initiative and it's not
like Knight H4 is a particularly
surprising move so I don't know
what he felt maybe he saw this position
after Knight C5 and felt like something
on D3 was was going to work out for
black
but on the other hand I saw no downside
to Bishop's f8
instead of her to be the move that that
you mentioned the pawn sacrifice if
white doesn't take the pawn there is
actually no downside to it so you
basically have to just consider okay if
my opponent takes the pawn am I worse if
not let's go for it why not
very well might come down to that move
17 decision and ding went into the tank
but decided to move the Rook a move
later going for Robert's idea of
centralizing the Knight right falls back
with the bishop but chess is all about
Tempo it's all about timing and it could
be a move too late to find the Harmony
in his pieces to get that Knight to the
defense to create is his own time to
play and with that last move Jana
pamishi has a big threat on the board he
wants to grab the 8-6 pawn we've been
looking at Alternatives where Dane just
ignores the bishop 86 capture and
instead creates his own initiative with
the knight jump to C5 but is there a way
in this position that Ding can still
keep it under control on the king side
and make sure that eight six Pawn still
stays alive or is it now time time for
ding to just go all out to throw all his
cards and fight for the initiative
I think it is the time yeah I was
supposed to say Bobby I'm gonna pass to
you but I just don't see even a move to
start defending the king side
I can only think of King to H7 but the
thing is that might just help white play
Knight to F5 with similar threats or
maybe
I don't know which Knight to F5
Knight H7 feels like the
but again your threading Knight takes H6
and of course black can kind of play
stuff like Knight to G8 but at that
point it's clear you've accepted you
have a bad position
and at least I'm not losing tactically
so let's let's try to hold on but not
what you really want to go for and
besides that I think Dave seven also
I guess Knight F5 was probably the right
move because Knight to H5 I feel like
black can take and played G6 in time so
King H7 I don't like I think yeah he
should go for it he should play an ic5
Bishop H6 B takes A4 it's a critical
line you just calculate it uh and hope
that it works out
and here I I think at least Yan would
suddenly have a difficult decision
because this is a very complex position
and you have a lot of options I mean
you have Bishop G5 you have like Rook to
E3 or something to sub Rook D3 but but
then you're taking a lot of risk as well
because you you might just lose your
entire Queen side
and you count on the attack uh other
moves which come to mind I'm not sure
Bishop to C4 but I don't really feel
like it's the right move
let's try this Rook E3 let's see let's
see what happens
nothing good
Rook takes B2 and black just wins is
that is it that simple
this is sometimes that simple yeah I
guess I was hoping that some Bishop G5
here or Knight F5 and black and white
might like uh you know Brute Force his
way to an attack but would probably just
gh6 and it doesn't work out at all
you know it's uh it might be one of
those positions so it makes me very sad
it looks like you should be checkmating
but you just cold-blooded take the piece
and say that's it no attack for you
yeah it seems although it's still like
you would you would still calculate
Knight takes H6 here Bishop H6 Queen F6
it's not like
um it's immediately self-evident that
that white loses this
Bishop takes you three Knights F5
uh
I I don't know baby Bishop B3 is just
Knight to F5 uh oh sorry this bishop
takes F5 yeah of course so there's
there's simply no ideas here for white
how about this one
that that is an idea
[Laughter]
okay but uh King to H7 is that important
okay that's just disgusting like it
looks like you actually are attacking
the black king this Pawn on F7 is pinned
so you can't take this Knight that's
illegal but King H7 defends the
checkmating square oh but think about it
yeah but think about it from far away it
actually looks like it white is about to
Checkmate you so you have to see King H7
well in advance
yeah it's it's not easy like with with
the Avail bar of course everything
becomes clear instantly but for these
guys calculating over the board
especially for ding because he knows
that he's he's taking responsible
decisions you know if you get checkmated
that's that's not gonna be good for your
match so he's gonna have to take some
tough decisions here
yeah ending is down to almost he's
touching the 1R mark on the clock and it
comes down to that decision that he took
with the Rook move after which it seems
like every move has been a difficult
move to make for ding one wrong decision
in chess it just means that every
decision that you follow up with it it's
gonna get that much harder a big attack
Brewing on the king side here and I did
see ding reach out for that pawn he did
a little twirling there we see him
shifting around with the pose he's put
the pawn back and I want to get your
take on this Fabi because we
you and I we've been commentating
together we've talked so much about body
language and different players different
commentators have their own take on it
and what it means I know that as a
player it is important for me it is
something that that does affect how you
view the position what your opponent is
doing has there been a shift in it uh
Fabi in your experience especially for a
world championship match a completely
different stage that we can only imagine
but never truly understand you having
been there and done that how critical is
are these shifts in the body language uh
and especially when you're playing
against a player like yeah
yeah I think you're not noticing your
opponent's body language so much
especially when it's your move to think
because you're just concentrated on your
own position but let's say if if your
opponent is thinking and you're sitting
there at the board and let's say
something dramatic has happened you're
winning you you might feel that your
opponent or you have a very good
position you might feel like your
opponent is starting to despair or uh or
be uncomfortable like it's it's very
clear in this
from watching ding that he's not super
comfortable uh you know he's heading
hands I try not to read too much in body
language but it's very clear that you
know he's not seen immediately what uh
what the answer is to this position
while in a in a position where he he's
very comfortable you know we might see a
completely different posture and
and let's say amount of thinking time
especially like from his last two moves
I guess how much has he spent on his
last two moves you know 30 minutes at
least
um
that's not a very encouraging sign
for let's say his comfort level in the
position I I don't feel like
I've been in that position where you
you're tanking on two moves it's just
because you don't
feel like you have the right path you
you start here you think this move is
how I should play Then you change you
change your mind again and again and you
change your evaluation again and again
and you end up getting everything
muddled up
that's where I feel his
um thought process is as well he's he's
uncertain should I sacked upon H6 should
I play King H7 uh should I play Knight
H7 at various moves come to mind but
nothing clear-cut
and he's been in a 12 minute Think Tank
already every move as you're pointing
out if the last couple of moves Rook be
it bishop f8 and now this one he's
definitely spent a lot of time he is now
below that one R Mark a ding has to use
his time judiciously there are a lot of
critical moments that are coming up in
the game and one might feel that an R
that's a lot of time we've seen these
minutes disappear move by move and until
you're left with just a couple of
minutes to make a few moves to reach
that 40 move Mark to reach time control
and that's when the big mistakes happen
uh Robert Queen F3 on the board it's
also a difficult position to actually
answer you leave the clock aside the
position itself is so dangerous
currently it could all collapse in just
a few moves they need to find a way
forward and what are you expecting at
this moment from ding will he play the
move Knight C5 or will he grab on A4
what do you think is going on in his
mind right now I expect him to think for
a while longer and while he does so I
just want to give a quick shout out to
Yana palm trees move 16 Bishop A2 when
it was played the three of us but
especially me I was kind of like what
what does that do what is the point of
it Fabi you Illustrated why he did not
want to see pieces traded off and he
created difficult decisions for his
opponent and we see maybe the most
difficult position uh that we could have
expected from this opening for dingley
Ren there is the threat of Bishop takes
Pawn over here removing the guard of the
Knight and F6 the bishop on A2 is
sniping long range piece towards the
black king and you see it on dingley
wren's a face the way he is spending his
time here he doesn't know what to do
because most variations look very good
for white you may steal a king-site pawn
if you move your knight on F6 away the
other night from G3 hops up to H5 that
doesn't look Pleasant either so there
are many options here for dingly red but
they don't feel like opportunities they
feel like ways to try to you know Turtle
up get your shell and survive but none
of them look particularly fun yonda Palm
she right now he's the one in charge
he's the one dictating the action and he
may very well win this game if dingley
Wren does not find a solution and find
it soon because he cannot afford to get
in time travel
yeah I think we mentioned earlier on
that this variation although it's equal
does have some positional poison and
we're starting to see that you can get
under pressure even though it's a
position where the engine will tell you
early on you know just equality quality
equality with any move and then at some
point you start to get some difficult
decisions and and we're starting to see
that Bishop to A2 was a very clever move
especially because it took ding out of
his preparation which is a good sign and
yeah I like what Jan has done a lot so
far to get some chances some chances to
put pressure on ding from an opening
where you know ding had equalized and we
were already saying it was an opening
success for for him
but now it no longer really looks like
an opening success he takes on A4
we didn't even mention this move
I think just transposition right Bobby
so Bishop takes H6 Knight to C5 or does
he want to take on B2 first because
that's the other option that he has at
his disposal then the question is does
Bishop G5
come with more power because there's no
Rook to D3
that's actually yeah what I suspect that
you would need you need the Rook D3
resource or you can't really deal with
Bishop to G5 so easily because Bishop F6
is disastrous if you allow it and if you
play Bishop to E7 the Knight I guess g
to F5 at this point because other night
might you know someday come to G6 and G
to F5
and
it's actually Knight H5 I just realized
is also an option because you can't take
allowing Queen take Queen takes F7
um
so a lot of really dangerous tactics
that black has to deal with maybe Knight
C5 is really necessary after Bishop H6
and then we we've talked about this
Bobby and it doesn't look Pleasant here
anyway
yeah so let's let's think about what
white can do because we actually didn't
find the method for white to deal with
this bishop G5 Rook D3 seemed like it
kind of works out for black
and Rook to E3 was simply losing so we
can't do that so this is not an obvious
moment for me at least I don't see how
wide is proceeding so clearly here
Knight G6 by the way we've got moves so
we will be we've got this position this
exact position on the
six was played Knight C5 not even
spending a moment to consider Rook B2
and the dangers after Bishop G5
tinglerize realizes that Fabi as you
mentioned that for the move Bishop G5
black needs the resource of jumping in
with that Rook on d8 to D3 get out of
that pin use the temper to attack the
queen and this is where we're trying to
see how white can continue with the
attack one of the moves that comes to my
mind is move forward with the Knight
Knight G6 and perhaps after Rook D3 just
come back with your Bishop no more
Bishop on offer say that I'm gonna
continue with my attack alright H5
coming in I love that idea Robert of
just giving me it on h8 that's the dream
that would be amazing if black allows it
uh and Bishop E3 looked very logical
somehow this position is super difficult
to assess because we see the engine
saying white is much better you make the
most natural looking move and it says
nope you're actually not that much
better after all but this kind of Knight
G6 jump you have to consider it uh but
with Rook D3 maybe there's another
response here that white can play it
could be rookie three I am kind of
wondering after Knight G6 like the movie
which comes to mind for me is Rook takes
B2
I know it's greedy I know I'm ignoring
all of your stuff but what exactly is
your idea with my G6
great question I was ready after I need
4K too
yes so if I go on idh5 now you'll just
capture everything sacrifice your Rook I
need to and perhaps pick up the g69
I think so Knight H5 Queen H5 Vortex A2
probably wins for black
so do you take on f8
let's try that Robert let's back up and
see what happens so if there's no Knight
H5 uh let's try and trade on f8 Knight
f8 what do you recap you can't recapture
with the King because of Queen F6 I
think yeah
so Rook takes update is forced this
simply looks dead lost for black
it and it is
so Rook takes a fade completely forced
and how are we proceeding here
a question at some point there might be
a queen E3 heading to G5 I need to time
this well can I take on G7 first
is that right King takes Queen E3
I'm at 96 there's Knight to F5 which is
very dangerous but if I play Queen to E7
here
just showing that very quickly that this
oh wait that's the best
I thought this was the engine I thought
the engine would just you know go in
White's favor but saying this is the
best somehow King G8 and after wait sir
but then Queen G3 now yeah so
okay so you have to go to h8 at night to
H7 okay but spying this in advance
without the help of the evaluation bar
is just nuts you're allowing the queen
in with check and after Knight H7 the
point is that if Bishop takes E6 Pawn
takes E6 the queen stops Checkmate on G7
the Knight protects the Rook over here
but I mean we talk about inhuman
variations Bobby this feels like if you
find this you just deserve the world
championship title
super tough and also because white
didn't have to play Queen E3 that was
just one Sub sub variation in in a sea
of variations
and yeah I that's if you even spot
Bishop G7 Queen E3 what did Black have
like some other ways there because there
was also
uh like Bishop G7 King G7 Queen E3 it
did feel like black probably has another
defense although I was thinking Queen E7
but then I think Queen G5 followed by
Knight H5 is actually probably just
crushing
King yeah and then Knight H5 and you
threatened Queen G7 and
um
apparently not even the best potential
way but it looked very strong I mean
it's still great maybe you throw in
Queen H4 check for some reason is that
oh well actually I don't see the
difference like Queen H4 check the
knights still can't move if you go to G7
then I go up to H5 I see all that uh but
I guess it's somehow Queen H4 is
stronger I don't well because after
Knight H5 Rook to G8 I think might be
potentially because the end game might
be rather
difficult but okay Queen to H4 might
still be crushing here so
so
strange moment because after Knight H5 I
was sort of threading in Queen G7
Checkmate it's 96 it has to be right I
mean what else can it be
what a strange move like you're giving
up a piece after Bishop takes E6 you
have to take with the pawn over here and
it's the now you protect the Knight it's
a miracle defense just to survive
yeah well this is this is definitely not
what black is looking forward to this
whole you don't like these you don't
like these Pawns well here I'm thinking
okay at least I have a piece to
compensate for my troubles but but in
general yeah in general I'm not too
happy about this whole line for black
wow yeah this is an insane position I
just want to put this in that getting
these lines in this attack out of a
Berlin honestly only happens in the 2023
world championship match between Ding
and Yan we've seen everything in this
match so far and now we're seeing a
Berlin and Auntie Berlin just exploding
into something with so much poison and
Fabi you call this out a while back you
call this out at the very start that
even though it's a slow start the
position does have a lot of Venom in it
and we're seeing that being played out
now we were discussing the option of
Knight G6 but I did see the eval bar
seems to say that there is something
stronger in the position there is
something that keeps White's Advantage
as we can see Yan is definitely thinking
about all these options things Parts is
clear right he wants to play Rook D3
he's the next move Rook B2 is an idea
that Ian always needs to watch out for
what is what are the alternatives to
continue the attack right now we've
looked at Knight G6 we've looked at
Bishop G5 is there a third move possible
in this position that perhaps Jan is
considering can I just note something
very quickly before I let you take it
away Fabi that white isn't down any
material you stole a king Side Pawn and
then black stole a queen side pod but
black structure isn't great so if
somehow white isn't just like dropping
all the pawns on the queen side you
should also have a structural Advantage
so maybe it's not about winning and
checkmating on the spot because then
black will get that counter play I I
think Bishop G5 looks logical but my
question was going to be because of all
that what if I just drop my queen back
to E2 isn't white just strategically
better as well
I think that's very likely the case that
white is not going to the best path for
white is not to attack but to go for
something like this I was even thinking
like Rook a to B1
instead of Bishop G5
yeah I just want to defend my pawn and
then
um computer is not thrilled about this
but I thought okay you defend the pawn
and then you move the bishop back
and
yeah Rook D3 Bishop to E3
so maybe maybe your way is the best
Bishop G5 Rook D3 and queen to E2
and then black has to deal with that
threat of Bishop takes F6
I was like
briefly thinking about Bishop to A6 here
but I don't know if it's the right
way to play
at the bishop F6 World takes G3
ah you sneaky sneaky but of course
oh is Queen to H5 winning oh yeah that
squares that's gross crushing
because now with Rook Rook D3 Knight G6
oh wow finally the idea appears on the
board and this time there's no running
away from Queen AJ
yeah this this is over
so yeah probably Bishop base6 is
completely uh completely wrong
does that mean Knight to H7 is the right
move it could be could be Knight H7 is
the right move
because I'm threatening to remove the
guard and Rook has to doesn't have straw
pack but I guess we drop it back to d8
feels just so bad for black like maybe
you're I mean we see the eval from the
side and saying that black is doing okay
but with knights coming to F5 and the G6
and these pawns being weak
is it out of the question let's say I
even get to this position is this just
still better for white without anything
I think so and I was even thinking well
you have that idea but first play Bishop
to C4 and just preserve that idea of
Bishop C5 but with the idea of winning
the pawn and A4
and it looks like a lousy position for
black because you're you're probably
dropping one of those a Pawns uh and why
do we have a pawn and Black's King side
is very compromised so there's not much
really to look forward to for black in
this position
but it takes a lot of uh self control to
to not try to you know Checkmate your
opponent right away you know what it
takes Bobby it takes the eval bar just
laughing in your face a bunch of times
where like process of elimination at
some point takes over and you're like
okay I'm not gonna check with you so
then I started thinking about the
Strategic elements rather than tactical
ones I'm like white has to be better if
you don't start dropping your queen side
yeah I think that's exactly the case
that's such a good point that you make
Robert that it's so easy to get carried
away with all the pieces that we see on
the king side and start looking for
these direct variations trying to get to
black skin and just forget that actually
there's a material balance and
strategically White's the one who's got
the upper hand you've picked up the H
Bond there is a double the a pawn if you
can just defend your B2 Pawn you might
not Checkmate the king but you just keep
all your strategic trumps alive we know
Yan right Yan is such an aggressive
players player he's definitely first
looking at all these tactical ideas
before he decides as well that it might
be time to just consolidate his position
and say that I'm better uh Fabi do you
think that's what's going on in Yan's
mind as well first trying to work out
all these tactical blows simply because
how critical this moment is if he's able
to make something of it the match can be
essentially over if Yan wins with the
white pieces
yeah this is a this is a pretty critical
situation for Ding and
Jan's best bet would be to be practical
now not to start to calculate all the
crazy stuff that we were looking at just
to play Bishop G5 Rook D3 Queen E2 count
on a Time Advantage Plus a better
position I was like looking at another
fun variation there which is unlikely to
happen but
Bishop G5 Rook D3 Queen E2 black has
this tempting move Rook takes G3
and I don't know if the exchange
sacrifice is good but it's kind of
tempting for black but I think Bishop
takes F6 is very strong here
yeah this looks like the point Yep this
looks very interesting for black
possibly and Bishop takes F6 Rook to D3
black could make the argument that you
know I traded off my bad Knight out of
six but then I think there's a very
strong move Bishops to C4 here
and The Rook has to go back to D7 and
now I want to play Queen H5
and G takes F6 I want to play Rook E3
and I'm just I I think I'm just
checkmating or wait is there even Queen
g695 but okay Rook E3 looks good enough
I mean this is just
this is a classic Checkmate Rook lift
Rook G3 Knight F5 everything coming
yeah so yeah a lot of danger for black
yes and definitely ding is feeling the
heat well chat looking at this analysis
if you didn't realize that look at ding
Jana's been in a 12 minute think tank in
the position ding hasn't moved from his
chair and often you see the players just
get up and go into the resting area
everything definitely feeling uh the
heat in this position as you're pointing
out how difficult it is and how quickly
things could get completely out of hand
beyond control right now uh Fabi you
know Yan
the best hair you've played with him a
bunch of times do you think that Yan
will go for a more direct approach moves
like Knight G6 and then all these
tactical ideas or do you think he will
be able to step back and reevaluate all
these points that you've been mentioning
and take that strategic approach of just
consolidating
I don't know how much this is a
stylistic thing
in because a lot of people I think
pretty much every player would be
tempted to make some aggressive attempt
work I would probably be a bit
disappointed that it doesn't seem to be
leading anywhere very clear-cut
and
yeah then it looks like he's about to
make a move did he make Knight to G6 so
Ayana answered your question for us yes
it's a line that we were looking at we
decided that Bishop G5 was the move that
gave Jan the best chances but he goes
for Knight G6 the eval bars doesn't
completely approve of it but there's
still pressure on the board there are
still ideas we were looking at Knight f8
Knight G6 a very critical moment now for
ding uh Robert what do you make of this
decision by Jan was this a stylistic
choice
I think it's just a good choice so I see
that uh the Knight comes into G6 the
pawn remains pinned so everybody
thinking that John blunder no he's not
giving away a free Knight can't take
that piece and he's going forward and
you can't blame him for this because the
B2 Pawn losing that is not the end of
the world even if you just play Knight
takes f8 there and say I don't care
about that Queen Side Pawn you still
have double isolated a pawns I still
have an attack so the Evo bar has barely
budge which means objectively it's a
good move I think practically it's a
good move so he had multiple options
that left him with an advantage he chose
the one that you know he calculated to
be best and the evil Bar says you know
what John you're right
yeah I love it I love it I know that you
guys were discussing about the Strategic
approach and the position which perhaps
was the best one but as as a player as a
commentator I love that Jan has chosen
this direct line well at least it
Promises to the fans that this is gonna
be fireworks and chat if you love Yan's
style and if you're inspired by Yan then
we've got some big news for you because
tomorrow do not miss your chance to play
in The Blitz Arena posted by the
chess.com Jana palmnushy fan club
compete against fellow fans of the video
World Championship challenger but the
chance to win a diamond membership join
the yarn fan club and you can enter the
arena use the command Yan in chat for
details and we'll see you on the arena
tomorrow a lot of excitement going on
and the game is heating up dingler and
is feeling the pressure this is a big
moment for him Jan going with the direct
night jump on G6 we will find out on the
other side of this break how ding
handles it
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
resignation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
wait wait he just took money you panic I
told you I didn't like the position my
goodness the position is getting very
very bad for black
dingley Wren knows firsthand what the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame 10 seconds one more
move remains whoa he made him move four
seconds on the clock and there's a draw
agreed but what a match we have
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
fashion is arising in the fish tank at
the Saint Regis Hotel we see dingler and
they're completely focused a big move
has been played by Jana pamishi
continuing the pressure on the king side
Knight to G6 now before we delve deeper
into the tactic that exists here I have
to discuss the question that's on
everyone's mind chair situation you know
that has been a conversation around the
world championship match the process of
the players deciding which chair they
want to play on Bobby what was your
experience with that back in 2018
against Magnus
well they were kind of just giving us a
chair and then Magnus was complaining
about the chair
and then they started to give us options
for cheers
but I don't think they gave us different
chairs if I'm remembering correctly we
had the same exact chair
so they're they're so this is an
evolution of chairs they're solely
branching out soon they'll give you like
a full office set that you can choose
from
I love it it's not only the format of
the world championship that's evolving
but also the world chair Championship I
was in Dubai and uh I was there while
they were testing out the different
chairs and it really does feel like an
office setup because they've got these
14 15 different chairs the players sit
they try them out one by one adjust them
see where they're most comfortable and
eventually very different styles in the
ones that they chose uh for the match as
well Robert what's your take on this do
you have a preference do you prefer
dinkster or yans the position I know
which one you prefer I'm not invited to
a seat at the table so you know I don't
think I should choose the chairs uh but
I know dingley Ren I think at the
candidates wasn't he the only player to
choose a unique uh chair there so he has
his preferences I think all players do
some like a little bit more back support
Fabi I'm looking at you and uh we see
that Jan speaking of comfortable chairs
look at him he is analyzing from the
comfort of his rest area he's having a
little drink he's enjoying the flowers
on the table that are near him and right
now I think it's a pretty critical
moment so he is relaxing at least it
appears that way but he really is
calculating because the last move played
by dingly Rand was a pawn grab on the
queen side one that I you know we had in
mind but we didn't really dive into in
this particular position because it
looks so scary for the black king and
the eval bar it says yeah Black's doing
fine but I am guessing I just see the
move I'm seeing it unfold live in front
of everybody I'm guessing there's like
one way that black survives and if you
don't find it you're just lost because
at first glance I'm saying what if I
just take this bishop on f8 give me the
dark squares you are going to have some
serious problems here and I'm already
seeing some funny pins for instance if
you go Knight takes f8 just to put a
quick line on the board and I played
Bishop C1 and Bishop A3 there could be
an issue on this diagonal
yeah I think we did delve into one of
the variations which was after work
takes up Faith is very critical Bishop
takes G7 Bishop C1 is also a critical
move although it feels a bit like you're
going backwards and and you might want
to like go more for the attack but
there's like two two ideas you mentioned
we we analyzed Bishop takes G7 a little
bit
King G7 Queen E3 and then it seemed like
Knight to E6 was the way for black to
hold on here
right and maybe even more so than hold
on Knight F5 King to AJ maybe black is
starting to get better
because white might not have enough
attacking potential but this is very
difficult to see but what if white
starts with between the E3 so the bishop
takes G7
because now if Knight to E6
white can start with Bishop takes E6
maybe I'm not sure if it's the best move
um but black will be forced to play F
take C6 to avoid this bishop takes C6
Bishop G7 stuff
and this is a questionable structure for
black I mean after Bishop to G5 you know
I've seen I've seen more aesthetically
pleasing Pawn structures
and by the way instead of Bishop 255
there's also like an immediate Queen to
C1 so you get the bishop back to E3 I
don't know if that's brilliant no that's
probably
I love that because the bishop on G5
you're not threatening to take the
Knight the bishop 183 protects F2 which
is a weak spot in the position so Queen
C1 lovely uh it's not really I guess
it's kind of Intermezzo but you're
really just clearing space for the
bishop while you attack The Rook I have
a question for you guys this line that
you're looking at it looks great for
white but the first thing that came to
my mind is that after Knight of it real
Cafe Bobby you're suggesting Queen E3
what happens if black just captures on
H6 are you going for the pawn on the
king side or the Knight on the other
side
that's a good question I think we should
probably go for the night because I
don't I have a feeling Queen to H6
I was hoping you'd say the night because
I want to know what you want to do after
Queen B6 because I'm really happy to
trade off the Queens if I can well white
will have no choice in that case but
Queen C5 Queen B6 Queen takes B6 Rook B6
Bishop C4 white can claim that your Pawn
structure is bad and and I will
recapture A4 so it's equal material but
you have a weak a pawn
um I guess it's hard to say if this
pause weak or an asset long term but uh
you have a weak King side structure F5
Square potentially a big weakness
for example if Bishop to A6 here which
is very logical
uh White can try to exploit that I don't
know if take on the A4 or A6 first but
let's say take on A6
take take and then the Knight will at
some point after rookie 4 coming to F5
and white will still be better I mean
just because of the pawn structure so
so why that will have a pleasant choice
you either you know you can start to
calculate Queen H6 and all that mess or
you can just content yourself with a
slightly better end game hmm yeah that
actually looks like a very ugly Bond
structure that is four different Pond
islands and we saw the eval bar approve
of what you're saying Fabi that the end
game does keep why with all the trumps
uh and queen 86 is a different direction
is that also dangerous for black it
would be upper piece but there is fire
on the king side
oh definitely dangerous for black
because I think we saw there were some
ideas like Queen to E7 is met by Queen
G5
the King goes somewhere and then Knight
to H5 we were already we were saying
like first queen to H4 some subtlety uh
avoiding Knight to E6 and now Knight to
H5 followed by Rook to E3 or queen G5 or
whatever I mean you have like million
ideas
and so probably black can't play Queen
E7 black will have to find another move
I'm wondering what that move is it could
could it be Queen d8 is that like too
funny
um
apparently it's it's too much the idea
was to keep the queen defended in case
of Knight H5 stuff but I guess
I guess the Rook will come into E3
anyway and just like Checkmate you
so
so yeah blackhead this is tough for
black
um
no like immediately obvious way path to
I have like this feeling yeah Knight H7
allows Knight to H5 and the Knight to E6
you
but then Rook to E3 I feel like it's
going to be Checkmate every single time
right without fail this Rook just lifts
up the board and delivers a very quick
checkmate
so I is it Knight to E8 I'm not not at
all certain but at least I I covered the
G7 square and prepare Queen D6
oh is this the one you did it I I mean
this is just such a ridiculous move to
see in advance like if you were
defending a position and you're trying
to visualize how can my king survive
Knight E8 does defend G7 that's the good
news but this Rook as soon as it gets to
G3 you're checkmated so after Rook E3
you're gonna have to find a defense here
and suddenly it says black is even
better I think queen queen D6 is
covering everything like oh nice that
was the idea of probably the main idea
behind Knight to E8 and I think maybe
the computer's suggesting that white
should but this is a nice thing for
white because you always have a safety
net instead of rookie three you have
Queen G5 Queen H4 Queen G5 and black can
never play Knight to G7 because then you
get checkmated with knight uh F5 or H5
most likely the most uh so black has to
go back and forth so white has a safety
net
and then can also in case there's a win
find that Black is Black is operating
with only moves and can only play for a
draw there's no joy in this from ding's
point of view
but he still went for it I mean he's a
he's an amazing calculator
if there is a draw he'll probably find
him
wow what are the chances of Us ending up
here with this repetition that you're
pointing out after this blowout middle
game for it to go Queen G6 Queen n6
Robert I would be a little disappointed
to see the game and that way I would
love to see this go on for longer and if
that has to happen what are the
alternatives for Jan here how can you
keep up the pressure thing has
confidently just grabbed the B2 pawn and
is saying show me the money here Knight
of Fate Queen E3 is one plan any other
ideas come to your mind a knight of Fate
seems automatic and then the follow-up
is the hard part I mean we see the
evaluation bar say that's good decision
how could it not be you're taking a
bishop for your knight you're moving one
of the key Defenders of the black king
and now it's about coming up with the
follow-up Bishop E3 doesn't look that
appealing to me because black will
immediately play Knight to B3 shutting
out the bishop and if you take it well
thank you very much for past Pawn this
is just great for black uh maybe
eventually winning so I can't get away
with Bishop to E3 right now but like
Bishop's also not under attack so Fabi
showed us this idea earlier it was a
great illustration of how you can take
your time Bishop C4 first why not you
can't take my Bishop I get your knight
then I can do whatever I want with my
Bishop next but Black's Pawn structure
is hideous on the queen side and on the
king side your king is in grave danger
so I feel like this bishop C4 move this
quiet move is actually a step in the
right direction
I I really like this move too and this
is like this is the patience Factor you
have to
sort of avoid that temptation to because
it feels like you might be winning on
the spot in Queen E3 Bishop G7 if these
are like direct winning times maybe I
just checked my opponent personally I
would be so tempted by those things I
don't know if I would be able to play a
move like Bishop C4 I would just be like
I would spend all my time trying to
check my opponent but uh some people
would be able to make that practical
choice
I can think of let's say a guy like
Wesley might for example you know take
that practical Choice like first five
minutes you calculate I don't see a
Checkmate okay let's just play something
which keeps the advantage like Bishop C4
and
that's the most unpleasant move for your
opponent because then the onus on it is
on him to calculate it it's not
it's not no longer on you right like
right now white ass calculate but you
play Bishop C4 now you put all the
pressure on your opponent
and ding just left his chair so he made
the move immediately went back to his
rest area a black is up upon if we just
take stock of the position black has six
pawns white has five the big issue for
black is this king is going to be in
danger and it's probably not going to
get out of it anytime soon but as we've
been highlighting showing by our own
mistakes and this is what happens when
these top players calculate uh Fabi
being one of the very best of all time
you know this is what happens sometimes
you see something that looks appealing
but then you recognize it isn't it helps
when you have the evaluation bar off the
side that changes things all together
but Bishop C4 is not an easy move to
play because all of our instincts is to
take to go after the king play Queen E3
but it turns out once we tried those
wasn't working out just the way we
wanted so Bishop C4 came to mind at long
last better late than never but also
aided by the evaluation in a trial and
error method that the players do not
have
this is another big moment are both
players taking their time on every
single move simply because this is such
a critical Junction and every move will
decide the difference between a draw or
a potential win for one of the two
players Jana pomnishi currently putting
on the pressure here the trades have
happened now the big question once again
and to me it always sounds like a
stylistic approach we saw it happen
previously about whether to consolidate
the position with this bishop C4 move
keeping everything's under under check
or going through these direct lines
Queen E3 which if navigated well for the
next couple of move could very well end
in a Perpetual as we saw in the analysis
this is this continues to be a very neck
to neck battle take a look at the piece
by piece between dingler and and Yan
napomnishi and we've seen the players in
this Championship with the black pieces
saying the black pieces did
who won the first game in game two with
black and then we saw several wins with
white and currently in driving seat with
the white piece is Yan Robert what are
the chances of another white win in this
one well Jan just moved and ding is back
from the chair so the question of
whether white will win it's not about
this moment although actually if we dive
into the moment Bishop G5 he does
retreat the piece and it's not approved
of by the engines a very human move a
very a move that makes perfect sense and
you know as we see here it you got a
question mark it's a inaccuracy it's not
the best move played uh the made the
position worse but not worse you know
not saying that his position is worse
overall but you just go back a turn you
see that white had the advantage after
Bishop G5 apparently the advantage is
gone and it should be a level game it
doesn't look level to me though I mean
black is in trouble here you probably
have to make a backwards I think Jan's
winning chances are still great
so I'm just because the move is super
logical I'm wondering okay Knight to H7
is like very very logical response and I
assume that he wants to play Bishop C1
here because Bishop D3 allows Knight B3
stuff and all sorts of things you
probably don't want and just doesn't
look very good for white to be honest
and so Bishop C1 it was your idea and
okay I want to play A3 I just want to do
it can I play A3
you can but when I
yeah take take Rook B1 and I was
counting on some Bishop A6
apparently doesn't work at all
but the idea was Rook B2 Knight D3 and I
was I don't know I was
C4 maybe that's maybe C4 is really
stuffy
okay we're B8 and yeah I guess it
probably doesn't work out very well for
black
into A3 yeah that looks Queen to B6 and
Rook to E2 is the final attack of that
pawn it's it's really Tempo by Tempo
like if black can defend that bottom B2
then you know we have full compensation
right so I guess okay A3 is a bit too
getting a bit too ahead of myself there
but Knight H7 feels right and then the
questions after Bishop C1 which move for
black
sorry Robert just I'm wondering is 987
because I saw in our featured chat that
thing perhaps needs to find the only
move here how important is it for him to
find 987 right now well 987 I think
that's not the hard move to find
whatever in this position after Bishop
C1 keeps the relative balance that's the
difficulty because if you make a very
natural move oh my rook's under attack
let me go back here white brings the
bishop to A3 and you're losing material
on the spot there's nothing you can do
you can protect the Knight that's good
for you I can play Rook to B1 and you're
going to lose something in one of these
directions and that's a big problem for
black so if you move your backwards you
lose this uh I mean exchange at the very
least on the diagonal so
A3 was fabi's Choice what else is there
I'm thinking Rook to C2 is possible
it's difficult to put the Rook there
but if Bishop tb1 there's Rook C1 Knight
B3 okay that's easy to find but then I
was thinking of Bishop to A3
there's another exchange sack at first I
didn't believe in it but now I'm
starting to like warm up to it which is
Knight to B3
sorry Knight B3 and Knight
take Bishop of Fate Knight to f8 I guess
and probably not King of fate and Bishop
I mean those pawns are defended they're
and they're strong
oh it's on the board by the way
Bishop C1
oh not Rook C2 okay Rook B5 he quickly
went Rook B5 and actually just look at
the Evo bar that was a huge mistake
Brook C2 is not easy to play because
your Rook looks like it's about to get
trapped down there and it involves an
exchange sacrifice but Rook B5 played
quickly and the engine does not approve
yeah okay Rook C2 is definitely not a
move which comes to mind immediately
because it feels like The Rook is
getting lost there but somehow he was
staying alive and it actually looked
like black was uh I mean we saw the
valve bar after the natural Bishop to A3
and Knight B3 it was actually going in
Black's favor so it was kind of a fun
little chance maybe for black
while here here he's just getting under
pressure
and he immediately pleased to move
Bishop A3 the one that we were looking
at well the Knight is defended for the
time being how dangerous is the plan of
continuing with the attack Knight H5
Queen G3 putting pressure on G7 is that
something that Ding immediately needs to
start taking care of in this position
I think the action is really with this
Knight and the Rook on f8 because Knight
to H5 I can usually play G6 and I don't
think that I think white has given up on
the direct attack now it's just uh okay
black is open Pawn but has the very
concrete issue of what to do with the
Knight on C5 and I'm thinking I'm still
thinking about stacking it I'm still
thinking about Knight B3 here
it just feels logical Bishop takes f8
Knight takes f8 but probably Rook 81
simply at this point like the point with
the Rook on C2 was white couldn't move
that Rook away because Rook takes A2 is
an option now you
now white is not forced to correct the
black a pawns by playing Bishop takes B3
and so this exchange sacrifice looks
much less attractive
if white was forced to play Bishop B3
then it would be a very attractive
exchange sacrifice but here
doesn't really seem to work out I'm
going to show that again father to
illustrate your point that fabi's saying
that in this position after Knight B3
there is no Rook a to D1 like we were
just looking at a different line because
the bishop on A2 needs defense so when
The Rook is on B5 the white Rook can
slide over successfully you don't need
to defend the bishop but with the Rook
on C2 aiming at this bishop that would
force that pawn correction and not just
a correction uh this looks like
Devastation for white because that is a
past Pawn that can be easily defended it
looks too dangerous to allow so I think
dingley Ren you know he went Rook to B5
I can't blame him for missing Rook to C2
that's a very unnatural looking move uh
but he played Rook B5 quickly and will
he pay the full price that is really the
question at this point
yeah the thing is that he's taking these
quick decisions and it forces him to
take a long decision right after so he's
not really saving time with this I mean
you can take your 10 minutes after
Bishop to A3 when it's already difficult
or you could take your 10 minutes before
Bishop A3 when uh or at least five
minutes like I mean to do it in how long
did he take uh 30 seconds something like
that yeah
this is a little bit feels like a
panicky moment like trying to avoid time
trouble but he's not going to avoid it
he's actually going to more likely put
himself under risk of time trouble
because now he's going to tank again
because you can make one kind of
I would call it like a rapid chess move
like okay you play some sort of natural
looking move Rook B5 and then in Rapid
chesses it's just how you play because
you have little time but
uh not really the way to approach
Physicians when you have 45 minutes or
or so or you know 42 minutes like he has
he's going to be tanking here because
it's not an obvious decision anymore
and it's not difficult right to find
that balance on the moves that you
should be taking your time in and
perhaps ding just felt that Rook C2
looks like an unnatural move you get
your own Rook kind of trap and just left
it without looking at the details trying
to keep that time situation under
control but it does turn out to be a
critical moment he makes another very
natural move simply sidestepping the pin
you've been talking about how critical
this night position on f8 is Fabi is
there a way to take advantage of that or
now do you shift your focus uh perhaps
by getting the Avon Rook into the game
get that Rook to D1 you start going
you know the king side and the two
Bishops on the extreme end but also
eyeing Black's King so it definitely
still looks like there are a lot of
dangers to be parried uh on the black
king what are you looking at are you
looking at Rook D1 here Knight H5 jumps
or a third option
well okay so the first move which comes
to my book which you quickly discard is
C4 because then black plays works at B4
and although you win material it's not
the kind of material I think you want to
win well this certainly this is just
like probably dead lost for what so you
don't want to kill your Bishop on A2
and then the second move you probably
consider is Bishop to C4 and I would
guess the answer here is Bishop to E6
uh because okay you're losing that rook
and Bishop B5 cb5 at least you have like
the very nice massive pawns which is not
really moving but it still looks nice
but on the other hand after Rook HD one
here
uh since it's not moving and black not
having a clear follow-up it might still
be better for white
big difference right Bobby the pond
could have been on B3 undoubled and now
it's farther back it can't make any
progress
yeah and especially because white has
the dark sweat Bishop which is so good
at controlling that E4 Square the A3
Square uh that's a very important piece
in terms of stopping the black's Pawns
so Bishop C4 is like the second move I
think you calculated and then after that
if you're not satisfied with Bishop C4
then you look at like Knight to H5 which
somehow I don't like Knight H5 any very
much because it allows Knight to B3 and
I don't want to allow Knight to B3
uh and it's my Bishop 182 gets
completely stuffed out
and then maybe you look at Rook D1
but still light to B3 I'm not sure if I
want to allow that so
Bishop C4 is kind of yeah I mean I'm not
really seeing here what why it's so good
for white but
I imagine there is a reason
yeah but you point out this move Bishop
C4 and it's so tempting to go for it
because immediately you end up with this
materially imbalanced position and you
still have your ideas of centralizing
The Rook building the pressure on the
king side and once again is this going
to be a question of approach of
different approaches different styles of
players Robert is that going to be the
big call out here whether Bishop C4
going for this material a material upper
hand with white or just continuing the
pressure on the king side is that what
it's going to be about yeah Jana has two
good choices but they are very very
different one involves him going up
material if he plays Bishop C4 and takes
his Rook on B5 the other as we're just
looking at is in the event of Rook D1
Knight B3 is by no means forced but in a
position like that this bishop may see
the D6 Square his Queen can jump forward
as well maybe he's trying to go for some
kind of pressure against the king side
but also the black pawns can't go
anywhere black is up a pawn but they're
over here they are splunted by this
bishop pair so uh I would be very
difficult for me not to take this Rook
on B5 it is available you can just take
an exchange and you don't seem to be
paying a huge price for it but I also
think that black has good chances to
hold there because the Rooks their full
might isn't felt just yet and you have
to watch out for these pawns and just to
show that one more time that if you get
these Pawn structures it can be very
very dangerous in the long term
especially if the pawn gets up to B4
okay so Jana's having he's in a four
minute thing tank currently but once
again we are expecting long things at
this moment because this will
game nine a very crucial match for both
Yan and ding ding has to has to stop the
bleeding in this one he needs to keep
things under control Yan does lead the
match by a point we've been talking so
much about his match experience and just
how in these kind of positions Jan seems
to get even stronger when he feels he
has to initiate it when he's up on the
clock he tries to play on all aspects of
the game his demeanor his understanding
of the game his ability to pose
practical problems to Ding and that's
the kind of yarn that we've been seeing
so far with his last couple of moves a
big moment for janapamnushi in this one
will he go for Bishop C4 or will he
continue to Simply build pressure with a
more developing approach getting more
pieces into the attack Jana vanishi has
had quite a match along with dingler in
and it's been quite a journey for Yan as
well in the second world championship
that he does play for the big Crown take
a look at Yan's path to fighting for the
word championship
story of Jan napomnushi's return to the
fide world championship and the mounting
pressure that perhaps follows him in
Kazakhstan began two years ago
it was then at the 2021 fide World
Championship the Palm Yoshi faced Magnus
Carlson who was in search of his fifth
straight title in his prestigious event
o gave Magnus plenty to handle through
game six which proved to be the longest
game in event history ultimately taken
by Carlson and that is Magnus Carlson
taking three and a half two and a half
lead
after that nepo never recovered and
failed to win a game for the rest of the
match Magnus had his fifth World Chess
Championship and a promise she left
Dubai with a bitter taste of Unfinished
Business
his loss to Magnus behind him neponishi
entered the 2022 candidates tournament
last summer in Madrid with a renewed
sense of purpose
the rumors bouncing about Magnus not
wanting to defend nepo managed a steady
and at times dominant performance we
have a massive victory for young upon
Richie what did you say Almira Catch Me
If You Can with four wins under his belt
from the first half napomnia should
cruise through the second half with
another win over farusha and a string of
useful draws to secure the bid as
Challenger
undefeated in Madrid napomnushi had
earned his return trip to the world
championship without truly knowing who
he would face or prepare for who do you
want to play in the World Chess
Championship literally I don't care yet
the question of who his opponent would
be was answered later that summer when
Magnus decided to step down as world
champion the door was now open for an
upanishi to capture the most coveted
title In classical chess
the candidates in a foreshadow of things
to come nepomishi squared off twice with
dingley Ren drawing as white and winning
in a dominant 32 move fashion as black
nepomishi has given ding little to
prepare off of nopo has played sparingly
over the board since Madrid dropping
just one game at the sink build cup and
playing in only one other major
tournament
fresh rested and with World Championship
experience from his clash with Magnus
two years ago napomnishi is considered
by many to be poised to become the first
fide world champion not named Carlson in
over a decade only time will tell
is playing for the world championship
title for the second time in his life
after playing against Magnus he returns
to fight for the crown against England
and a game nine is so critical Jan leads
the match with one point at four and a
half currently the first player to get
to seven and a half takes the match away
well of course if he wins that would be
a huge blow to to team ding a second
loss a two-point deficit tough to come
back from but also on stake is that Ian
for the first time will cross the 2800
rating Mark if he does win game nine
Fabi how important are these milestones
and what does it mean for a top level
Elite Grand Master uh to cross the 2800
coveted mark
yeah I remember for myself it was a very
big goal in 2014 and I was close in 2013
um but I think I
I plateaued a 27.96 and then 2014 I
managed to hit it and it was a really
big goal when I managed to do so I I
remember the tournament I pretty much
even remember the game where I where I
hit 2800 and I remember talking about it
with my father beforehand
um about how like it'll be really
important to hit this Mark in hindsight
it does feel a bit like the importance
of this at least personally was a bit
overstated
um because it's not so much about the
ratings more about the tournament
results as we see
um Beyond
maybe come world champion even not
needing to become a 2800 right if he
draws the rest of his games he he'll be
27 99 or 27.98 and that'll be enough for
for world champion uh title as well so
yeah it's it's one of those numbers
that's like
of course the difference between 27.99
and 2800 is in reality not nothing but
um it feels much nicer
around the sink field cuff with your
amazing seven game streak was it then
that you crossed the 2800 mark
no I I crossed it in Dortmund
um I I scored like five and a half out
of seven in dortmundo earlier that year
and then I my first tournament being
2800 was the Olympiad in 2014 which was
held in Tromso
and
there I played Magnus with white I lost
to Magnus but then I I hit 28
um 35 in singfield cup of that year so
yeah that like that was a big push for
me hitting that 2800 for the first time
that's amazing because
Fabi we've
had Champions so far Magnus Carlsen is
the 16th world champion in Astana we'll
have our 17th world champion and to just
bring into context how big a deal 2800
is I'm looking it up and we've had only
14 players so far who have crossed that
2800 barrier I mean you're one of them
incredible stuff and yeah could be the
15th player to cross the 2800 barrier on
the live ratings if he wins today's game
but of course there's still a lot of
chats to be played in this one a lot of
work to be done in this one rookie it
and that's a big Think Tank he's been
thinking for about 12 minutes uh Yan in
this position
again doubts about whether to play the
move Bishop C4 or to continue with the
initiative is that what Ian is weighing
in on right now yeah it definitely is I
mean Jan has decisions to make he can
take material but then that gives black
some chance as well or is he just gonna
sit on the position so to speak by
bringing his Rook towards the center
with the move Rook D1 as we were talking
about earlier so it's not that clear
some people say give me that Rook I
would take that Rook if if y'all were
playing a Blitz game I'm pretty positive
he would go and take that Rook but then
he's realizing that it does give ding
some winning chances despite the fact
that white would initially be better if
you make an inaccuracy down the line
there just to put that on the board
again that with these past pawns over
here if you just allow a couple moves
black is pushing forward on the queen
side and that is scary news for Yan so
he's really looking at this position so
before getting to it he needs to assess
it properly he needs to recognize that
he is in fact better and then find a way
to challenge black at this moment so
that he does not see these pawns storm
up the queen side
yeah I think Bishop C4 is the first move
that comes to mind and maybe like eighty
percent of your initial calculation is
tied to this move
and the thing with Rook id1 is if if I
see the answer to Knight B3 then I might
be very tempted to play Rook 81 but I
need to see what I want to do after
Knight to B3 and that is not obvious to
me because it's I don't think it's a
Concrete thing I don't think the white
has like some very good concrete
approach here I think it's something
very uh subtle I don't know if it's
Knight to H5 G6 and something here I was
thinking maybe this could be it uh
although it's thinking about the
position it nothing very clear-cut came
to mind or if it's something like Bishop
to B1 D3
I feel like Bishop B1 is unlikely to
lead to an advantage I mean I would try
Knight H5 here if I was like let's say
and and it's not the move G6 probably
and uh
and I guess it just doesn't
this idea of Knight H5 if it's a Blitz
game we just definitely go for it I mean
I would definitely go for it whether it
works or not you want to start putting
the pressure and to imagine that after
G6 Black's doing completely fine despite
keeping those dark squares as weaknesses
uh is definitely a very tempting option
and as we can see G6 in fact might not
be the right move here Fabi well you
know what that suggests to me that
um if G6 isn't the right move is Rook to
E6 the right move to get that rook and
stop Bishop D6 stuff and get the Rook to
G6
it's like the D flower now you're yeah
allowing yourself to get background
checkmated if you're not careful so that
that would be my speaker
some Queen D3 stuff is probably super
dangerous
yeah very direct because The Bishop's
also loose on C8 so you're having
problems in both directions but you
actually I think solved it probably by
saying it and that's why I love about
commentary is I gotta talk through ideas
the sixth rank play C5 and then you can
bring this Rook over and shut both
Bishops out of play
see Rook to B6 say yeah that's the right
work to get over to the king side and if
Queen to G3
do you play you play G6 at this point
right and uh and it's not clear how
White's attack continues
yeah you did that's you you solved it
for me you said all the right things and
then all I had to do was make a single
move thank you Bobby you made me look
good I said all the I said all the right
things and made all the wrong moves
what did John just do
okay so Bishop B6 is the thing is like
black can play Knight to B3 to sack The
Rook in another way but white doesn't
take it I think white players Rook HD1
in that case
and uh this is a much better version
because the bishop is not on A2 it's on
C4 this is like a magic trick we jumped
over the night
and here here this looks really bad for
black just visually so I think black
needs to get rid of that Bishop on C4
and the way to do it is Bishop to E6
it forces Bishop B5 I think
or logically forced is it cb5 in here
Rook 81 is a move which comes to mind
but that's not it's not necessarily the
best move but it kind I don't see other
very logical moves it feels like Rook 81
is uh by far the most logical one
yeah we paused this position a couple
times now and it really is that
difficult to find the continuation Rook
ad1 looks very natural to me if since
that move the bar went down a little bit
Queen E3 maybe just attacking the Knight
and asking it to move backwards or to
choose forwards but I don't know why I
would invite the Knight into here but
maybe it just clears the diagonal for
the bishop to allow me to go after this
Pawn
and this is super super difficult to
play Queen E3 because why wouldn't you
start with Rook D1 what's this what's
the downside what
what does black gain like which move do
you make here do you play Knight to F6
and Knight fd7 and you've consolidated
suspect that might be the reason
okay wow that's kind of crazy stuff
but it's very subtle it's not obvious
that
[Music]
um
like a lot of people would play Rook HD
One automatically just because how can
it be a bad move like there's no way
that Rook 81 uh just intuitively you
feel like okay this has to be a good
move Bobby you're gonna love this uh
thanks to our producers for shouting
this out check this out you wanna know
what the the this continuation goes
Bishop E6 apparently you're not gonna
believe this the best move is
Bishop takes E6 and after Knight takes
E6 Queen D1 is a variation just going
after this Pawn that and Bishop D6 is
available if the Rook decides this
doesn't feel very natural to me at all
but now that I've been told it I can
justify it in various ways
yeah I I don't I don't see myself even
if you told me this is the right way and
Bishop takes C6 I can take with the Rook
too
like do you want to just take on C5 and
take on A4 there doesn't feel likewise
is significantly better in that position
so after Rook E6 what is the big deal
I'm just you know repeating what I was
told I don't see this right here
I mean Jan's going to pick up the
exchange Bishop V6 on the board it's
hard to imagine just letting go of the
B5 Bishop to play this Moon Bishop C4
and then to trade it off with the bishop
I would be shocked what are the chances
of Jan going for this uh line Abby like
like zero I think
I mean you just played Bishop A2 to C4
now you're playing Bishop C4 to E6
you can take a rook uh yeah exactly as
simple as that it got the Rook
I I don't see this happening at all I
actually thought you were gonna say like
the best move was Bishop to F1 to keep
the option of taking the Rook on cards
but but I also feels like a rather
strange move uh I think Bishop takes B5
it's just sort of the movie play I mean
if he plays Bishop B6 I will
I will bow to yam that that will be
that will be an amazing moment for sure
he's thinking right so if he's gonna
take on B5 why is he not doing it
instantly because that was the point of
bringing the bishop here to begin with
so I could see a Universe where he moves
his Bishop away it doesn't really make
sense to me like I I I can't see him not
taking this Rook on B5 is essentially
what I'm saying
is he thinking about Queen to E2 is that
possible
um because if take take then I get A4
directly or I'm most likely going to win
this Pawn
oh my goodness and the eval bar approves
of it so Queenie 2 is actually a decent
move oh I was I was I I didn't have a
feeling that white could play for an
advantage in this way but
yeah it could be an option like this
this to me feels much more natural than
Bishop takes E6 I would much rather do
this than take 26.
wow
I I it's so hard to attack a rook and
not take it but this goes back to our
earlier point you don't need to be so
concernediction so if you trade Bishops
here your knight on C5 is under attack
if that moves it's a one move threat
against The Rook The Rook simply can
slide out the way Bishop comes to D6 at
some point A4 is hanging don't forget
about this Knight it's gonna say hello
on F5 and then maybe go into some of
these critical squares so I just think
that Queen E2 is
just beyond me I had my beyond the scope
of my imagination but Bobby good find by
you and if yon plays it oh my goodness I
think that'd be surprising for ding
I like the move for sure yeah it's
it's a move which once you see it you
start to appreciate it a bit more and a
little bit more because it feels like
with the Knight on B3
I don't think black should put the
Knight there but if black does and the
Knight is just trapped I mean it has no
influence it doesn't control any
important squares and why is playing
Knight F5 and id6 all sorts of ideas
uh so
I don't like Knight to B3 at all but it
you pose a difficult question to that
Knight on C5 where does it go does it go
back to E6
uh does it go to D7 there's definitely a
lot of options for black maybe D7 is in
fact the best Square to go to
I'm already seeing a future for this
night first F5 then D6 all sorts of
forks things of that nature I can take
on A4 as well it's not out of the
question just to get back to material
equality and Black's pawns still remain
in worse shape so I I kind of like
Queenie too whoa
whoa when he's done
no we thought we
thought was it really goes for them
oh my God yeah it's a beast
represent he's
just to prove me wrong he plays it
that is shocking I I think we just have
to do an instant replay we don't need an
analysis but we're not going to analyze
but Bishop C4 to attack a rook and no he
enticed a bishop trade after all that
and simply took on E6 he does give
himself access the F5 square that is of
critical importance that's great news
and if he plays Queen D1 after this uh
that's just ridiculous stuff from Jana
pomachi oh my gosh yeah I think Queen D1
would be even more unbelievable to see
happen a retreating queen move from a
spot that's so active and this was one
of the options that we thought will
never happen Robert you said that you
know if it wasn't for the production
team telling you that this was the best
move it would never be something that
would come into your mind right Bishop
he said it just doesn't make any sense
from a human perspective and I want to
understand now go a little deeper into
it why is this the best option you trade
your very strong Bishop you retreat with
the queen from all human angles that
make zero sense in my head guys and any
one of you can take it away why is this
so strong well I so I'm thinking
that black has two logical moves and
it's not clear which one is better and
Knight takes E6 is the first which comes
to mind because it feels like at night
is a bit vulnerable there so I would
like to get it out of the way but then
Knight to F5 comes to mind as White's
response and I'm wondering about that
position Robert you mentioned Queen to
D1
but just from like visual point of view
it doesn't matter if I feel like a bit
more of a natural way to get to that D6
Square
yeah I was just shocked by what they
were telling me Knight F5 looks like the
human response I think that's more
likely what Yan will play but then maybe
C5 and black is in time because Queen D1
now work to B3 and and I both uh get
that Bishop locked out of the game and
save my A4 pawn attack bc3 things start
to come together for black maybe that's
why you play Queen D1 first
and then if Rook to B3 there's Bishop to
D6
and C5 obviously just drops the A4 Pawn
and here you get the E5 Pawn it's still
a complex position by all means but it
does start to feel like if you get that
E Pawn that it's a really important one
there's one more time what are the
chances of Queen D1 actually happening I
think if you get to this moment then
Queen D1 could could definitely come to
mind because Knight F5 C5 you might feel
like you hit an impasse and uh
Queen D1 it's a backwards retreating
move but it has a very clear idea right
you just want to take the pawn you
combine that with Bishop D6
very once you see it again it's
um it's a move that has to come to mind
and then it feels very logical and then
the question is blackplay Knight to C5
back
uh just to keep that A4 Pawn as black
encourage you to take that on let's say
Rook d8 or something but isn't there
it's a knight C5 I was thinking C4 but
you're gonna go with your Rook B4 stuff
oh yeah I'm happy for that I trust me I
want you to play C4 and just sack my
Rook for the queen side Pawns
but but maybe white has something very
dangerous like Knight to F5 here for
example
Rook to d8 allows Queen G4 potentially
you know it's all sorts of
why does play on both sides because
black
so you can definitely combine play on
two flanks
Robert I'm gonna be on the 3C Queen D1
this queen retreating move it is just
super high class stuff and I see that
Ding has gone into an almost four minute
thing on this recaptcha which at least
from our analysis to both you and Fabi
96 felt like the natural decision
thinking
so is he just calculating the outcomes
after Knight takes E6 or is it even an
option to perhaps recapture with the
Rook fe6 looks extremely ugly to me yeah
no chance he's playing Pawn takes E6 I
mean you probably said zero percent
chance and then it happened but just you
can't play like this and you see the
eval bar reacting uh White can probably
even just take on A5 and take on A4
which is what you'd do anyway if Rook
takes E6 white can just say give me back
my pawn and this is a weakness I can
remember up to B1 to A1 to D1 I have
options here the Knight is coming into
F5 this looks really Pleasant for white
you're playing for two results if ding
defends perfectly he draws if he makes a
mistake he's going to be in some pretty
serious trouble uh but maybe it's not
even necessary to recapture this Pawn on
A4 so soon uh the Knight coming to B3 as
Fabi mentioned is not a very big threat
so why not just play Knight F5 hop
forward instead of liquidating just yet
big moment for ding he does need to
recapture with the right piece he is
currently having a thing yeah playing
some Flawless chess today the match the
game is heating up and we're gonna go
into a shot break while ding takes a
decision which piece to recapture with
this right here is how I use chestable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
justinville came around when I got on
adjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're going to be folders now
so I can categorize by white black and
all tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to
show you like how many adjustable books
you got I'm like all of them how are you
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
chelseable it actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 and bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just worth
on chessable just being honest with you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
putting on an impressive defense in game
nine of the world championship match
he's just made his move number 30 which
means that there's still a bunch of
moves to be made before time control the
clock will account had enhance that he
knows this is a critical moment and guys
I love how we go on a break and
immediately we've got a bunch of moves
that happen a very different position
from where we left it Robert should we
just back up backtrack and see how we
got here
for sure because at this moment after
Jan brings his Bishop to C4 to attack
The Rook we started praising his
decision making to take this bishop but
now I'm going to take it back because
once this trade happened and black was
able to play C5 after this queen E2
Retreat Rook to B3 the queen jumps up to
C4 protecting the C3 Pawn attacking the
pawn on A4 putting more pressure on C5
though that is well defended for the
time being black played Queen to C6 and
I don't really see the issue in Black's
position anymore you have a very active
Rook tying down this bishop C3 is
threatened the queen on C6 defends this
A4 Pawn so Fabi I mean is there anything
here left for Yana palmchi to start
playing for an advantage once more or is
Bishop C1 backtracking is that a sign
that things have not gone according to
plan
well the suspicious 6 was a surprising
choice but it's especially surprising
in combination with Queen E2 C4 ideas
because if you wanted that then why
didn't he play the move that we also
mentioned Queen to E2 instead of Bishop
takes E6 it most likely gains a Tempo on
the lines in the game I'm very likely an
important tempo for example Bishop C4
Queen c496 isn't white just up like
actually two Tempe in this case and I
can choose between neither five or queen
takes A4 here
so that's a bit of a strange moment for
me because okay Bishop B6 made some
sense in conjunction in conjunction with
Queen D1 but not with Queen E2
um feels like maybe he let his advantage
or part of his Advantage slip I still
feel like he has a more pleasant
position after Bishop to C1 in the live
game
because
well A4 is likely to fall and then the
question is can black respond with Rook
take C3 after Rook takes A4
Queen C3 Queen takes A4
and
the answer is maybe yes it depends on
the position because E5 might also fall
in those variations
I I think like Knight to F6 comes to
mind here is a very natural move just
developing the knights again
okay four Rook C3 Queen C3 Queen A4
and if Queen takes C5 probably there's
an id4
maybe other moves as well but
um
yeah 94 at least looks very I mean it
feels like this might just head for a
draw because we're seeing a massive
simplification of pieces
so then the question becomes after
Knight F6 does white have a way to
protect the C3 Pawn
because if you can get A4 without
allowing
Brooks okay he does play 906. and I'm I
was thinking like maybe bishop D2 to
play Rook takes A4
but
then Rook B2 is kind of disruptive so
it's not so easy for white as well
it feels like it's one of these
positions where if white tries to play
on for a win too long it could really
backfire then black could have the upper
hand let's not forget black is up a pawn
for the time being uh the knights now
are nicely centralized here E4 is put
under pressure so I feel like for Yan he
has a full point lead in the match at
this point making a draw is not the
worst thing in the world he didn't have
a decisive Advantage he was much better
it's not like he's gonna be kicking
himself too much perhaps to just make a
draw and get out of here enter a rest
day still a point ahead
I don't think so but he will feel like
he had an advantage throughout this game
so I think he's still an ambitious mode
especially because if he could play
rooftex A4 without a lion Rook C3 why
does white is definitely better and not
even a little bit maybe even
significantly better because black can
never play Rook A8 there's always 97 so
it's it starts to get difficult to
defend your your pieces
so the question is will he find a way to
make Rotex A4 work will Rookie 3 come to
mind for example
but if Rook E3 feels wrong somehow just
feels very wrong
um because the work is blocking the
bishop and allowing maybe some back rank
stuff in the future
like 97
yes sorry I was just gonna ask you
because you're you're looking at these
lines with Rook A4 and these
simplification is it because you don't
like the queen trade here for white to
pick up that Bond Also let's just point
out it's it's the obvious but I'm gonna
say that currently black has an extra
Pawn in this position so the A4 Pawn
needs to be picked up at some point
you're pointing out these lines of
keeping the Queens on the board uh and I
want to ask you what would be the
objective evaluation of a queen trade in
this position I do see that after Queen
A4 let's say it's captured you recapture
with your Rook the C3 pawns hanging that
could perhaps give white the option to
also plant his Bishop on B2 on the
diagonal and go for the E5 Pawn how are
you looking at these end games for white
actually I was thinking after Queen A4
Queen A4 Rook A4 maybe Rook to A8 is a
very interesting move
because that a pawn could be a big asset
and if Bishop to D2 here I started to
get attracted by uh the move C4
because it if what takes it then the a
pawn starts to run and if not it's
difficult to say what white is doing
like disabled is very dangerous without
being easily blockaded
and if white plays another move for
example Rook to A1 instead of Rook takes
C4 then it drops the E4 Pawn so C4 was
was attracting my attention
um
okay this will be an interesting end
game
wow okay so Queen F4 a queen trade
possible and is that the is that thing's
best option to actually trade Queens
with the Rook on B3 hanging the pawn on
if I'm hanging I don't I'm struggling to
find another move you've got to go for
the end game here with black yeah
there's no choice
yeah I think you definitely have to what
I mean you can play Queen B6 I guess
okay you can blade it's not like losing
on the spot but it just doesn't make any
sense
so the question is now does he play Rook
C3 or does he play Rook A8 it's two two
moves which come to mind I think thing
will sit down we already see himself
getting comfortable uh you know he he
realizes this is a point of calculation
it's a clear branch in terms of what you
could play leading to different
positions Rook C3 Bishop B2
or Rook A8 and uh whatever white chooses
there which is unclear you know I think
that if the rookie I'm so scared of your
past a pawn that I might give you this
check anyway and then bring my knight to
C6 like I just looked at the variation
you demonstrated for us Fabi I'm like no
way not me I'm not letting you promote
that pawn so I think wrapping the Knight
around attacking A5 and E5 at the same
time maybe that's the Saving Grace
needed uh for yonda palmchi and I say
Saving Grace not because he's losing
right now but because the trajectory of
the game would start going in Black's
favor after that variation you showed
with C4 I really like Black's Chances
with the outside pass Pawn
yeah I think you're definitely right the
97 C6 is
one of the most critical ways for white
and probably the safest way for white
because if you get rid of that a pawn
you're unlikely to be to be losing this
so you want to get that safety net first
and then I O C6 also attacks E5 so it's
very multi-purpose piece there
Queen A4 recapturing of the A4 Pawn with
the queen kind of uh hinting at a draw
for by Yan is that Yan saying that I
tried with the white pieces I did the
marks I could and now I'm okay with this
game ending peacefully
I'm still feeling his ambition a little
bit in this end game I still feel like
he's going to want to try because
there's potential
in fact there's potential for both sides
if things go wrong because black does
have the ape on but on the other hand
black has a lot of weaknesses
and you know
the structure is the more long-term
Factor so like
is the one who might have some you know
immediate Chances with that iPhone but
in the long term you could if what
consolidates let's say if I could get
let's say Bishop D2 F3 Rook to e Rook e
to A1 then structurally black is
suffering a lot
foreign 's face by the way he looked
displeased he's sitting at the board
even though he's already made his move
typically he goes to his rest area I
actually think he's quite unhappy with
the developments of this game and he
should be he did have the advantage he
knew it ding knew it we all were talking
about it it was not easy to you know
make the most of it to make progress but
you could tell that he wanted more from
this game and he had a nice position a
very young the Palm she liked position
but dingley ran credit to him he has
been a sturdy defender in this game one
of the big story lines of this world
championship of course has been the
trading off of Victories but also the
collapse the lack of defensive tenacity
that we do typically see from these
players in high level events but dingley
Ren I mean he's been digging deep after
game seven debacle then yesterday he
doesn't win a position that he would win
in most occasions and we do see pawns
are coming off the board right now after
Brook takes C3 and I think that Jan he's
resigned to the draw so to speak and
he's not thrilled about it
yeah and I think Bishop to B2 is a good
move because if Rook takes A5 I think
black could easily play for an Avenger
with Knight to D4
and you don't want to allow the knights
D4 it's it's too strong of a piece so
he's he's grabbing the E5 Pawn
and ding has something clear in mind
here is it Rook to B4 is that the answer
and it very well very well may be he
says yes you asked ding answer is Rook
before on the board so he's saying take
my A5
centrally for Pawn
makes a lot of sense and we're just
seeing a bunch of Liquidation in this uh
position so does that mean that it is
heading towards a draw and perhaps very
soon
yeah it seems to be the case because I
don't think white wants to play Rook
before black can take with either Pawn
in fact but I would maybe suggest CB4 is
the most natural way
and now he takes only five I got scared
I thought he took on B4 and that
actually happened no that would be very
scary for what that was me showing that
there's no way he was taking on B4 you
just can't afford to give these kind of
past pawns and as Bobby said you're
taking either direction because now
there are two unopposed passers that are
quite Advanced that is just a
non-starter
you know I think dink is happy with this
I mean he looks he looks pleased I think
he was very worried that he was gonna
risk losing this game and
Jan probably felt like he was close to
getting a serious advantage and now it
just looks like
this is heading to a draw without
um many chances left for either side I
mean take take there's only three pawns
left and you know white can even trade
off another pair of knights with Knight
to D6 so a lot of pieces are going to be
coming off the board very likely
it does look like The Rook trade is
inevitable as well right with the bishop
hanging The Rook on E1 you've got to
trade on e4 I would say is there an
alternative that Yan is thinking about
well he goes for it rookie for Knight E4
equal number of Pawns but there is a c
passer there is the C5 Pawn I don't see
that becoming a danger Fabi is there a
way to take care of it immediately is
there a shutdown in this position I mean
I think 96 does kind of shut it down
because take you force the trade or goes
to C8 Bishop goes to E5 and to C3 and uh
I mean the pawn is blockaded and it's
not moving anytime soon and this just
feels like a like pretty much a dead
draw to me
you know if the Knight tries to go like
Knight of fourth running king of uh 2092
then white can usually cover with King
F1 pretty easily
and so on so
yeah this is
he plays Rook A4 also a logical move
I guess
asking tonight where do you want to go
and the Knight can go to D2 or does it
want to oh wait 92 allows Bishop G7 okay
maybe we have to be careful
I know but not very careful no it
doesn't because there's 97 Rook G4 and
Rook T1 so he you actually don't want
that at all for what oh that's nice
that's a nice counter tactic Robert it
looks it looks so good but as Fabi gives
us the end of version check the Kink
can't escape because the Knight covers a
square once the king is back boom
discover a check and you lose your Rook
or your knight or everything the game is
over so uh we're getting a little Fancy
with the tactics but Knight D2 something
about it feels just weird like even if
you bring your Rook over to G4 just
going for the attack and if you play G6
I may try to check with you at some
point in the near future so it can be
very very careful if you are a ding the
ren before it was a funny thing here so
Rook H4 I think I think F6 is probably
working very well for black
and I was I was also thinking that maybe
Knight G7 is playable but I'm not I
think 97 probably Knight H6 wins so it's
a 997 let's not get too clever here that
is funny that Bobby's Point what if I oh
if I take with the bishop yeah there's
rookie one rookie one Knight F1 I think
actually white is risking here because
there's 923 905 but I think Bishop C3 in
the end sort of holds on
it's a miracle for white that it holds
on but uh okay yeah we're getting into
the fantasy lines though
it's always fun people love seeing how
your brain works Fabiano just let them
enjoy it
I would agree 100 with Robert hands
speaking of fantasy line one more
perhaps that I'd like to point out is
that if you decide to retreat your
knight to F6 then maybe the sacrifice
with G7 works here as well because after
Knight G7 you can't recapture with your
knight the F6 Knight is hanging in G7
you have six nine is still pinned and
Rook G4 check it looks like the tactics
work out for white in this case as well
well night now and if you just come back
to the live position as we have it
Knight F6 Knight G7 looks super strong
for White Knight D2 feels like an
unnatural move uh it might be the best
one in the position but Knight D2 will
you really make it from a human
perspective just watching your knight
kind of trap itself on the other side of
the board A Lone Ranger there but apart
from these two moves is there a third
defense in this position for ding
well you can you can always play an id4
but you don't really want to because
then you then you um basically condemn
yourself to defending three against two
with knights it's a draw but
there are more fun things to do with
your life than defend this end game
I think at least maybe some people enjoy
it
uh but here yeah G6 or something and
it's very likely to be a draw anyway
I think four against three gets very
tricky but three against two is probably
not very tricky at all and just to
finish off Bobby's Point here that any
nitrate rook and three pawns against
rook and two pawns all on the same side
of Boris will be a draw uh night end
games are most resembly King and games
they can be a bit Troublesome but the
Rooks are not going off the board
anytime soon even if they do it still
should be addressed I just want to point
that out it's a bit of a high level uh
consideration but this would be a draw
despite the material deficit
yeah here here the for ding is just do
you want to be like you know an id4 is
just kind of a draw but
do you really want to do it I mean I I
would try to avoid that because I I
would have a feeling that it's sort of
an equal position calculate Knight to D2
for a bit feels like the let's say
principled way of holding this game
yeah and also this line with Knight D4
right you just can't keep the Bishops on
the board you can't try to trade that
Knight and win that pawn uh with
starting with Knight D4 simply because
black would have the option to take the
bishop on E5 so you would have to go for
this end game but it is a bit of a
torture it's the kind of position that
probably yeah she will play for the next
couple of hours trying to grind down and
right now we see ding well even if he
knows that that end game with the trades
on D4 could and will perhaps end in a
draw it's not something that he wants to
do if not that Knight D2 feels like the
only move Knight G5 too much on the edge
of the board that Knight can be pushed
even further Back The Rook can pile up
on G4 Knight T2 is the move that thing
is looking at the good news is that he's
got enough time to navigate through
these
Robert what do you predict will he find
this idea or will he just go for the
simplified version with Knight D4 and
say yes I'm a pawn down I'm willing to
suffer because I know at the end of the
day that is a draw
I'm too scared to play Knight D2 like
I'm worried about my king safety with
that Rook going over to G4 but the more
we talk about it I don't really like the
Knight getting banished back to H7 in
some variations either so with all that
in mind Knight D4 does make sense I know
it's a draw I know it should be a draw
but then I have that work that not fun
at all work that Fabi uh referred to so
you have three options that you and the
problem is you know all of them are
going to keep the relative the same
evaluation there all should be a draw
it's a theoretically drawn position now
it's about choosing one I feel like I'm
a bit of a chicken right now and I would
go Knight to G5 but I think Knight D2 is
probably a sensible reply as well
yeah I think Knight G5 but it might come
down to this H4 F6 because after Knight
um might Forza G5 H4 I don't know Knight
H7 still has Bishop G7 uh business which
I don't want to allow I think
at least I'm rather worried to allow it
maybe the C Pawn ends up being very
powerful compensation but
uh because maybe there's like Knight to
F6 here Rook G7 king f8 and the C Pawn
starts to get kept powerful maybe maybe
but I I wouldn't play like this for sure
so
I was thinking Knight G5 H4 maybe F6 is
The Prudent way of holding this game
because if the bishop who is Knight to
F7 I guess we're in relative safety
and
if take on G5 it's very concrete fe5
why needs to play G6 most likely
uh
probably we can attack that pawn in some
manner like Knight to f8 or something
A7 here no no this is a blunder Rook to
A7
uh so not nighttime effect and not
Knight F4 for that reason as well so
this is a little bit
of an iffy Direction maybe maybe not to
D4 is where you put the Knight
if you're playing with fire there right
even Knight E7 check your King has to go
to one of the squares you can't take it
because of back rank mate but the king
just doesn't feel that safe in these
lines King h8 is just game over after
Rook A3 Maybe
I don't know if 92 F4 is
but yeah it's probably just game over so
King f8 is completely forced
and then yeah this kind of position
where you're surviving here but if that
Rook lands on A7 you could find your
king in some difficulty it is a draw
Still most of these lines will be uh
balanced for the most part but yeah it's
just not an easy situation if you allow
this Pawn to G6 I think you'd prefer to
avoid it if you can
yeah let's just play Knight D2 let's see
if I mean okay I I understand the
hesitation with this move but uh you
still have to find some sort of idea
with white right
yeah but don't rely on me to find it
because I feel like I see the evaluation
I know you've already told me it should
be a draw but I'm just looking at this
Rook G4 stuff
yeah G6
and Rook to H4 F6 looks pretty at the
very least safe for black I mean if not
just better
so sort of like drop this here first
okay can I
can I play Knight to P1
I was also thinking maybe
you know
oh now you're invading
yeah yeah this is this is getting
dangerous
[Laughter]
is 94 completely stupid here just
hitting that bishop and if you capture
the Knight then I can take the Knight on
F5 and you don't have Bishop F6 after
Knight E4
wow if this works Pitch Four and Knight
D4 yeah I'm still surviving after Rook
H4 Knight D4 I think wait we're getting
four and id4 I don't think you want that
end game
oh yeah just treat everything that is
that one Pleasant
Peter doesn't mind wow
yeah I guess it's a draw King G7 G6
um
nobody wants any of this end game no I
don't I don't believe that Ding would
voluntarily go for this it just looks so
lost for black even if the valbar says
it's not
you might think it's a draw but not one
which looks super Pleasant so okay he
does have a choice
it looks like he's reaching for the E6
night yeah
wow that's the other option we were
looking at so he decides to just
simplify the position at the cost of a
pawn uh you need a lot of confidence in
believing that that position you can
hold down upon but Fabi as you mentioned
three versus two is an easy hold for
black are you expecting Yan to push this
to try and grind this down
oh yeah for sure he'll play it out
uh with without Knights I don't think
that you really played out but with
knights yeah you probably should play
this one out and if it's for so I once
had this without Rooks and four against
three and four against three without
works I think is probably losing for the
for the side that's the pawn down
without Rooks three against two without
Rooks I think is is a draw without
significant problems so that's a good
thing for black that he he can trade
Rooks he played G6 I think we'll see 93
very quickly
or night's age or maybe but
E3 feels like the most logical
and then black can kind of quickly play
King G7 put them out on F6 and just wait
around for white too
to just say okay
show me the show me the money show me
how you're going to make progress here
which is probably uh probably that
there's no way to do so
but we're gonna be sitting here a while
covering this end game
music to our ears for sure you know
covering a rook in three versus Rook
into end game and Yan well he quickly
pays 93 but you're right if I'm young to
Palms here or if I'm his coach I would
say if you're a position like this you
have to play it it's likely going to be
a draw but you're not risking anything
and you're the only one who can win so
why not right like Bobby if you had a
position like this would you play it out
oh yeah for sure with the Knights uh
even without nights I'd play it out for
a little bit or against two I wouldn't I
wouldn't waste too much of my time
because without nights it's really
really kind of dead but with knights for
sure I'm playing this as much as I can
and I'll play it slowly I'll you know
try to play G3 H4 King G2 and
uh very slowly make a little bit of
progress
but fully with the knowledge that you
know 99 times out of 100 this is a draw
well maybe you're sure of the result but
the thing is it's also a psychological
battle right you're also saying sure
this antenna draw which show me how
you're gonna do it and you've got to
still be slightly precise with black
draws fine as long as it happens on my
terms is what yanapamnashi is saying
with the white pieces so trying to grind
this down would be also a great math
strategy going further into the match
they will be playing game 10 tomorrow
right and Fabi how much of a role does
stamina and energy start playing at this
point in the match because one thing is
yes just action the over the boat but
also it's so emotionally draining for
the players this environment that
they're playing in what's at stake here
for them so even if this ends in a draw
yeah she's saying it's going to end in a
draw on my terms you still have to
defend for a long time I will Tire you
down how much of an aspect is stamina
right now for this match
I think that in general stamina will
play a huge role
but I think that the energy draining
moments are the ones where you have to
make tough decisions or where you're
worried that you'll lose here you don't
really have to make any tough decisions
because as we saw for example they were
just like not thinking King G7 fast 93
fast it's a non-concrete position where
they know that basically every move has
the same evaluation so they don't have
to make difficult decisions and also
they're both fully in the knowledge as a
draw so it's a pretty
stress-free situation uh
you know maybe a little bit later on
then we'll have to think a little bit
about one or two moves he might make one
or two semi-differal decisions in this
game
but uh for the remainder of this game
but overall of course this is one of the
easier sorts of defensive tasks you you
have a theoretical draw and you don't
have too much to calculate
and if even the bringing the Knight to
F5 and trading Knights here ruining your
Pawn structure we saw that still is
objectively drawn a theoretical draw
then that means ding should have this
half point in the bag and uh he'll be
happy about it I think Jan will be
decide who is going to be frustrated
based on the advantage he had wasn't
nearly as big as the advanced ding had
yesterday but it's still he had pressure
on dingly red it seemed like ding might
get into time trouble but just when we
started the sense that y'all might be
playing for victory it seemed like he
couldn't quite find his footing and
daily red on the other hand he was able
to stabilize and played some good
defense so I think ultimately a draw in
this game would be a very very good
result for dingley wren
and also just seeing how ding has
managed that games haven't collapsed I
keep coming back to it because as
players we know just the kind of effect
that that sort of an end can have on
your mind it's not about the result of
the game it's not about the about how a
ding lost but it's more about the way it
happened just the complete inability to
move and then we saw him with the white
pieces create his chances even though it
ended in a draw he was the one who was
in driving seat and then today holding a
really difficult position with black
keeping things under control it could
have gone anyway and Yan tried to make
his best try to create his chances but
think Super impressive with his
defensive resource today very very cool
stuff there by a dingler and so far in
this world championship match Rook
before I saw a feature chat and our
viewers believe that a draw might be
agreed in just a couple of moves it's
very possible because tomorrow being
arrested both players would be just
happy to call it a day go into the next
one and say sure you fight it out they
will take the white pieces and we'll
take it on from there a big question
here well the well we can see both the
players have left their chairs they've
gone out for a bit of a break a bit of a
breather here uh Robert what's your
prediction are we gonna see a long Rook
pawn and then grind with the Knights on
the board or just a few moves and a draw
for on the board
I don't think it will go on that long
but if ding the red can't find a way to
trade off knights in the near future
then maybe Jan will think I have some
outside chances to win but when you look
at this they both know it should be a
draw ding he's been confident in his
decision making he gave away the pawn
knowing that he will split the point
with proper play so I think that yeah
this game will not last that long but
commentators curses happen and as soon
as I say that it means we'll be here for
another three hours
wow and
now right now
championship match we were with James
earlier in the month for the Champions
chess store and Mike caught up with
James about his thoughts on all the
action that we've been witnessing in the
world championship take a look
thanks guys and uh well you all know who
I'm here with feed a master James Canty
the Jedi he's in town to be a
commentator for the lucky stars event
with aronian and kramnik and Bibi Sarah
and all of those Stars uh but the lucky
stars event that's a Madonna song any
truth to the rumor that you sing this at
karaoke oh yeah actually you know what I
don't know the words uh Mike
unfortunately so I can't do that okay
well you're a little young now you were
in Astana for the big game seven were
you yelling at your screen like Gotham
chess was oh absolutely in fact uh I was
happy to see the fridge I was like oh I
actually grew up in the fridge and I was
like if he wins with the French it's
going to be a wave of French players and
I'm probably gonna hop on that wave as
well because I did like the French for a
while then he lost and I was like that
is why I don't play the French but at
the same time of course it was really a
heartbreaking to say the least right
with especially him doing so well in
that game even almost having a winning
chance at some point but of course the
time really got into them and a Time
Time trouble was like for everyone we
all get in time trouble and of course
when it happens you can't uh make
mistakes and that's what happened in the
game okay so real quick be our tour
guide 24 hours in Austin what's a good
thing to get into give us some flavor go
to the mall next door oh my goodness
there's so much stuff to do right
hopefully it was a VR place where you
could like play with virtual reality a
little bit of that it was a lot of food
everything that you can think of was
there right also use Google Translate
because uh I didn't know what I was
doing I was in the grocery store for two
hours Mike but I was taking pictures and
it was translating it for me so Google
translate does have picture and it does
help but definitely goes to the mall
next door and the Expo is outside and
it's also cold outside but at the same
time I love it here Estonia I'm having a
great time next door's Mall also has a
trampoline trampoline chest are you in
um let's go bro let's go right now all
right guys we're having to figure out
how to do this but back to you guys in
the studio
James County currently in estana thank
you so much for that fun interview guys
well James is commentating at a site
rapid event that is going on with some
big big names fighting it out uh so much
fun to see him there having a good time
and he's excited about going for some
trampoline fun I feel like that's a
great word guys to describe how this
match is turning out to be it's a
trampoline of a match would that be
accurate
yeah definitely and uh I have to say I
like the idea of trampoline chess
you know we were when we were
um commentating on the global
Championship we were trying out some
different forms of Chess but we didn't
have the idea of playing trampoline
chess I I think the only problem would
be the logistics we gotta find a
trampoline and then we can make it
happen
ing
now you put a set on the trampoline and
you jump up and the pieces fly
everywhere it would make great
cinematography but I I don't know if you
really want that to happen that's what
magnets are for Robert
oh well that could be one way of doing
it right guys you've got the chess set
on the trampoline itself or you could do
it the chess boxing where you play a few
moves of Chess and then you kind of
compare who jumps higher on the
trampoline that could be a safer
approach to this I'm loving it I'm
loving the trampoline chess concept
Knight to G3 was played
wow that is an offer of the night and if
that happens that's definitely a draw
fg3 you pick up that night I need three
that's game over but we're not expecting
uh Yan to go for that we're not
expecting a capture on G3 it's just such
a funny move because you can move the
Knight anywhere it's not like
it's not like moving to F6 is bad or G5
or D6 or when you put it on G3 it's it
almost feels like a joke
um
like like a little bit of teasing
because there's there's no specific
reason to put it on G3 it doesn't
actually like help your defensive task I
don't think
it prevents Rook D4
that's Android F4 yep
that is a great trick you've got to
watch out no Rook D4 Rook F4 with a fork
coming up but I think every every other
move for white is fine it just keeps the
balance I don't think that there are any
critical moves in this position and it's
kind of still hard to imagine how Jan
plans to create his chances the one
thing I want to ask you is that in this
pursuit to try and trade off Knights the
one idea that black can have is go
Knight F5 and let's say we have that
structural change it's in that let's
just make a random move in this position
and imagine and visualize the White
Knight comes to F5 and this structural
change does this offer
any chances for white uh with the g-pawn
moving to the f-file is this something
that perhaps ding should avoid not bad
no matter how badly he wants to trade
the knights right now
I would avoid this but
probably with no specific reason because
it does feel like the F pawns are just
as good as they would be on any other
files but I would still probably avoid
this
I I don't know if this is his idea
because if it was if it were his idea he
could also play I have played Knight to
D6
I actually have a feeling he just wants
to stop G4 he's just like okay I'm I'm
blockading your g-pawn so your king
can't get in so easily and King h294 is
a bit annoying
and then if white doesn't want to repeat
then you have to play I guess Knight to
D1 or something which doesn't look super
dangerous
so
yeah I think he's just trying to
blockade that jeep on but he could also
go for the nitrate it it does appear to
be a draw which is good to know in
general that you know even if you have
the double Death Punch you still draw
rather easily in The Rook again
yeah oh one question for you Robert in
these positions you know often when you
know that the position is job but your
opponent is still pushing a little bit
right he's got in this case Jan's got
this extra Pawn you would make a move
like Knight G3 or at least I would make
a move like this just to see how
ambitious my opponent really is does he
is he serious about any winning chances
in this position is he serious about
trying to grind this down so just give
him a little bit to try to provoke to
see a reaction is this uh something that
you've experienced as well as a chess
player
oh well I I feel like sometimes you can
get complacent and that's the really
difficult thing and ding is not doing
that right he's clearly making moves
with purpose he's bringing his Knight he
said the actions that you can't take me
will just trade but I've definitely had
situations where I felt it it's
certainly a draw I have no worries here
and the game continues I'm like wait a
second where was that guaranteed draw
that I just thought I had and then the
game continues like I'm worse and then
it continues like okay where did I go
wrong this is a problem and there are
some great technicians oof Anderson the
legendary a Swedish Grandmaster he would
trade off the Queens as early as
possible and then grind you down in an
end game and it's not just him there are
many illustrious Grandmasters of the
past who did just that and I think that
you just can't Overlook anything you
can't take a result for granted and
dingley runs not doing that and I think
this is very instructive that he's not
just making careless moves because as
Fabio's saying white wanted to expand a
bit G4 King to all that stuff and he's
making Jan's life more difficult he is
not just allowing that simple progress
hmm yeah yeah really nice points there I
think we're gonna find out how ambitious
Nepal really is in this position if he
captures the Knight that's a draw for
pineapple he says all right I'm done for
the day going back going into the rest
day we'll come back with the black
pieces but if he lets that Night Live on
if he doesn't recapture on G3 it means
we're in for a long grind in this end
game and then all these points that you
made that Robert that you made Robert
about ding still playing it actively not
just sitting on the draw not just taking
passive decisions but actually actively
stopping nepo's plans to expand on the
king's side those come into play once
again it's hard to suggest a bad move
for white hair but I'm gonna ask you
Fabi is there a way that white can now
start thinking about pushing those pawns
not at the moment but to try to expand
the king side other plans that we're
looking at the only possible plans in
the position for white you got an extra
Pawn on the king side you want to push
it but what's the path how do you how do
you go forward when this yeah I don't
think he'll take on G3 it's just letting
your opponent off the hook too easily
and you just want to press it a bit and
fg3 is the equivalent of a draw for I
think he might play Rook to B3 clear
idea clear threat F takes g3i defend the
Knight on E3
forced the Knight to make a decision
does it want to give a check on you too
because I want to go back to E4 after
which the position didn't change much
but maybe I can try G4
doesn't want to go to F5 trade those
Knights at least I give my opponent that
decision
um I was thinking Rook B3 Knight to E2
King goes to H2 and then white tries to
slowly play G3 King G2 H4 maybe G4
someday and you know
uh try to advance a bit
it's not really about both these guys
know that it's a draw
with pretty much any move as long as you
don't blunder
what do you just want to find a move
which
keeps the game going a bit longer makes
your opponent annoyed that's why he
played Knight G3 I think he's just kind
of annoying him like okay now you have
to find some sort of little calculation
you have to you have to think about the
position a bit
rather than just making automatic
immediate moves and not having to you
know worry about
he plays Rook to B7
which doesn't really have a thread I
don't think
nope you're looking for it where's the
threat eventually he would like to bring
his Knight in and team up in the F7 Pawn
but as we've been talking about Knight
back to F5 is a viable option and I'm
not just gonna allow you to win this
Pawn anyway I can bring my knight back
to E4 where it came from
or just Rook to E6 I don't see what Rook
B7 changed so why not just make a move
that doesn't change the position either
ask your opponent what do you want it
would work to be seven and
I don't really see it like Knight C4 is
never an option because it allows rookie
won a knight F1 with perpetual actually
would in this case wins a piece so you
really don't want to do that
Knight to E3 or D2 and wins a piece
so yeah maybe he'll just play quickly
Rook to E6 I would I would think
or not oh he really goes for The Rook
end again okay goes for it and this is
what
we got right that a nitrate you really
want it but at the cost of what and ding
is saying that he's willing to pay quite
a high cost with a structural change
which could have been dangerous but
shows immense confidence in his endgame
technique and Yan doesn't even take a
moment he just denies the trade on F5
speaking of confidence he knows zen
games right Fabi he says I'm not going
to liquid into a known theoretical draw
I'm going to continue to make ding work
yeah he he's keeping the knights on
it's very logical he wants to play G3
King G2 next and slowly get that the
Knight on G4 is not doing much but
slowly get it back to H2 F3 and
and yeah long term you put pressure on
F7 you want your opponents to play Rook
to E7 at some moment at least give you
the option of trading Rooks which I
think is is a complete draw but
um
at least it's a decision to make up but
okay why not Rook E7 let's just see this
end game a little bit without the Rook
song
it's funny that you bring up this move
Fabi because I was just gonna say that
you know in these kind of end games
we've been talking about the night trade
and how that is a confirmed draw but the
one trade that one might want to avoid
is going into a pure night and game uh
and yes if it was a four versus three
we'd be having a different conversation
but with three versus two it's still
very holdable but it just feels like
this might be a little more difficult to
keep under control rather than the rook
and rook and requests Rook versus rookan
game I would be very scared as black to
go into a pure King and night end game
but you're saying very you're saying
that this just ends in a draw and
there's nothing to worry about uh is it
really that easy to go into this trade
I wouldn't be overly concerned if you
put pawns on E3 and H7 in this position
you just like drop them on the board
magically then I think White's winning
chances are very high
it's it's really not a pleasant end game
but three against two I think that one
Pawn difference changes everything just
too limited there's too little material
left and I even think that f and g
is is a nice like it's no worse than
having h g bonds for black soap
here I wouldn't really be concerned
because what's White's idea if you trade
off one more pair of phones we're
already in territory where you just
don't have enough pieces left to win the
game and otherwise you try to I guess
dominate The Knight on E7 with your king
but
feels unlikely
I think one of the main things is if you
like include e and H ones is that white
could try to create a passport E4 F4
bring the king in and then E5 and create
a pass eform or um
foreign yeah he immediately goes for it
I don't think he's scared by the same
game at all
right
but fabi's saying because if you did
include and I'm just gonna draw random
colors here and uh and E and H Pawn that
changes everything because then white
can make a past pawn and in the process
you have to go E4 and E5 and F4 and G4
and F5 you see the trades happen let's
hit trade here and then we'd see a trade
here when the E Pawn goes forward but
you'd be left with this H3 pawn and
that's the big difference is with more
pawns remaining uh to start with
liquidation doesn't happen as fast but
now if you're going to create a past
Pawn like we can just make some moves
here just to kind of
force it to happen in order to actually
create a past Pawn white is going to
have to like push this Pawn up the board
but black at some point will likely be
able to sacrifice the Knight like even
in a position like this where it's
starting to look a little bit riskier if
you play G5 things look pretty locked up
but this is not what you want if you are
black because the white king will get in
at some point H5 happens and if I can
get give up one Pawn you see the
evolution going all the way up I'm not
trying to show you an example of what
you didn't want to have happen let's
just move this here just something like
this is not what you want because it's
two unopposed passers even though you're
only up one Pawn it's kind of like
you're up to and black is up one but the
two pawns definitely uh win the show
here and that would win the game for
white so there are some nuances here
Bobby that I think we need to take into
account but Jan just he's not having any
part of it
I think you you really don't want to fix
your structures in positions like that
because when you put the pawn F5 you fix
it on a square where it's very weak you
can't easily the more advanced it goes
the harder it is to defend it with your
pieces or with your king so when you
were playing F5 in that position you
were creating a big Target for attack in
the F5 Pawn while let's say King G7 G4
King H7 H4 King G7 I just keep going
back and forth I'd even I do ideally
Like to Move That Knight from E7 at some
point because I feel like it at the
moment it's a bit restricted but if
white plays King G2 and I don't know
Knight to C6
and King to G3
and plays H5 at some moment you know
black will I think happily take
part of H5
take
and most likely this is a draw in a
variety of ways uh I don't think that's
like one move draws here I think it's
most likely that many many moves strong
and it's just because you don't have
many pawns left so if you play
um
I don't know what a normal looking move
is in this position
but
let's say Knight to C6
I mean I feel like you just won't have
enough material left but again you do
have to sweat it out a bit here it's not
like
it's not like you're enjoying this
process it's just that you you know
it'll probably be a draw in the long run
trades are
possible of course is the one end game
that you want to avoid is a pure King
Pawn end game when you're down upon that
would be completely lost but yeah making
his intentions clear he's definitely
being ambitious here even though he does
know that this most likely will end in a
draw he wants ding to sweat it out for a
bit longer we see that the players are
taking it slow they've met time control
and as this end game progresses we will
go into a shot break and be back to see
the end game action for the first time
in the world championship match
[Music]
thank you
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
with all the decisive action that we've
been seeing in the world championship so
far this is the first time that we've
got a full-blown end game grind going on
here as janapamnershi plays with an
extra Pawn in the position that
completely holdable for ding ding
answering impressively he keeps up the
pace he has the confidence that he will
be able to hold this and we've seen a
couple of moves there which have
happened and the a nice move by Yan
putting that Rook on the seventh rank so
taking away that option that Ding
perhaps had with Knight to eight six uh
offering a night trade as the F7 Pawn
that you're pointing at is thunder uh
interesting how Black's Rook is on the
seventh rank hitting that F2 Pawn white
stroke is on the seventh rank hitting
that F7 Pawn what are we expecting ding
to do what ding has done come back with
the Rook offer another trade on E7
yeah I see no reason why not I don't
know why the King on H2 rather than G1
would change anything and after Rook to
E7 it Rook to B5 Rook to E2 is a
repetition and if Rook to B2 stopping
Rook to E2
then Knight to H6 Knight to E3 and
Knight to F5 and we've seen this kind of
dance before right so I don't see why it
really changes much if he wants to play
rookie 7 at this point
it doesn't change anything but I think
we've seen John cleverly stop ding from
making the immediate draw just to go
back where we left it in the break the
threat for black it's not threatening to
win material but it's the running
exchange material that would lead to an
immediate draw say The Rook went to B8
instead then Knight H6 forces the
knights off if you want to keep the
knights on the board you drop this Pawn
enough too now you no longer have a
material advantage if you trade Knights
on H6 this is very easy theoretical
drawn territory where rook in three
versus Rook on two two same side of the
board no Advanced pawns no passers yet
this is just a basic draw for players of
this caliber so that's why yon instead
went Rook to B7 saying if you now try to
play Knight H6 looks like a great idea
but it's terrible because that's their
takes takes Rook takes F7 I get to steal
my pawn and protect the pawn F2 at the
same time that means white is two pawns
ahead that is insurmountable material
lead that would lead to a victory for
white so that is why dangly Wren he's
thinking here he wanted to play Knight
H6 it's likely he will return his Rook
to E7 continue to offer trades and I
don't think that young could really
avoid it for that long because otherwise
we're just going back and forth
yeah I think after rookie seven we
either see the trade or we see the move
Rook to B2 nothing else really makes
sense I think because you either have to
stop rookie two Knight H6 ideas
or you have to trade Rooks uh trading
Knights seems to just be like the the
most drawish option out of everything
and rookie seven Rook to B2 I think then
we can predict Knight to H6 Knight to E3
Knight to F5 and maybe at this moment
the other will find a different Square
for that night at long last maybe he'll
put it on you know D5 or something
um
eventually he just wants to kind of get
maybe now to F4 he wants to get G3 King
G2
so that the F2 Pawn is more more well
defended and his pieces have more
freedom
uh it won't change the evaluation but
it's like you got to look for your small
victories first you you know first you
take your slightly better place King
then you take some Pawn advances
it's probably still going to be a draw
but you take what you can get
Fabi you're talking about small
victories now drawing this game with the
black pieces that's the kind of start
that we had in this game and the math
situation
even though the result might be a draw
is that in some way a small victory for
ding right now given the Mad situation
I think definitely also given the game
situation he was certainly in in quite a
lot of danger earlier on in this game
out of the opening he had equalized but
then a few inaccurate possibly uh
dubious decisions put him in in very
serious danger and
coming out of this with a draw I think
he'll be happy with that
one of the things that he can look
forward to with with a great deal of
confidence is that with the white pieces
he is constantly creating winning
chances game after game he's getting
winning chances and even though
he was unable to convert it in the last
game and it ended in a draw you know
the the most difficult part is first to
get those chances
uh against players of Beyond's level of
dings level you know you're not usually
getting chances so often so even to get
that chance is is already a big
achievement in itself
yeah and sometimes we see both players
getting chances in the game we've seen
we've seen so many twists and turns and
ups and downs in these ones uh and
Robert what what's your take take on
that just how unique this match has been
I'm thinking back in time right I'm
thinking about fabi's match with Magnus
I'm also thinking about the karyakan
match with magnet so the wishy Magnus
match and you might get your chances in
just a couple of games you might get
them in two games in three games maximum
just a handful of times but in this
match in every single game it's been
both players having that opportunity to
strike showing Amazing resource showing
defensive technique also incredible
tactics
it's been so unique thus far
it's a bit of roller coaster and we
nobody could have anticipated a match
where the players would trade victories
and you know young would go up by a
point then ding would equalize and John
would go up by a point again and then
dang would equalize once more and then
the third time young went up by a point
and then a third time uh dingley ran you
know he was able to uh try to stop it
but the third time hasn't happened yet
right he is once again down by a point
and he needs to catch up he does have a
couple victories to his name he uh has
been playing quite decent chess uh in
the last three games even though he lost
game seven that's really such a critical
point in the match but I do want to take
us back to game two in some ways like he
went outside of his usual repertoire and
Jan punished him like janapamshi is
playing great chess in this game Jan was
on the verge of taking a two-point lead
if he posed a few more questions to ding
I really thought that Ding might have uh
had troubles keeping up but for young
the way he's played in general
throughout the candidates and in even
the last World Championship I think that
final result is super misleading because
in the first five games and then even
most of the way into game six young was
every bit Magnus Carlson's equal
throughout that match and then Magnus
decided to uh take control in that end
game it was a long game and finally
Magnus was able to win it with a
material imbalance and then the match
actually was easy enough for him from
there so I just think that Jan he's
proven himself to be a worthy Contender
no matter the opponent and dingler end
is finding himself sitting across the
board from somebody who is really
determined to win that world
championship title who is not going to
back down no matter the type of game
that is played and who continues to lead
he has not trailed for a moment in this
match
yeah this is the match of their lives
for both and dengler and it is the
ultimate dream of every chess player to
become world champion and here they are
the two of them they've been such
Gladiators throughout the match and you
pointed out that Ding has made a
comeback twice in the match already uh
yeah I'm taking the lead I think
striking back yeah I'm taking the lead
then ding Strikes Back Again currently
Yan has that one point lead now the
buttons that we've often seen with these
two players in different events so yeah
when it's going well he almost seems
Unstoppable you know he he's such a
beast and it just feels like he gets
more aggressive more confident and very
difficult to deal with over the board
but for Jan sometimes we've seen that
when things don't go his way when there
is a difficult moment he struggled in
those he struggled to come back from
those meanwhile ding in many events he
has he tends to have a slower start
sometimes even dropping some points but
then
beast at the end of the event getting
closer to the Finish Line do you see
this dynamic as perhaps
having some effect in this world
championship match Fabi if ding is able
to equalize for the third time in this
match will the momentum shift completely
in dings favor
it's hard to say because it's been so
back and forth and we we've heard a lot
of
after every young win that you know now
Janis is going to win this match for
sure and then ding wins and suddenly
ding is a favorite and it doesn't seem
like either player has been able to
fully pull away or fully show their
dominance
uh the last two games has shown a clear
Trend beyond that uh you know it's it's
all starting to go his way but this game
I feel like is is putting the brakes on
that a little bit if you know it's going
to to stop his momentum a bit because he
was very close to creating serious
chances in this game
and it was really looking dangerous you
know we we talk about positions that
aren't like lost or anything but still
you can start to see the Contours of how
it starts to to go sour for for one side
or the other
and in a lot of the games in this match
we've seen that the good day for one
player has coincided with the bad day
for another for example in the second
game Beyond played a perfect game you
can't criticize a single move but ding
played a lot of either question moves
bad moves or just like it looks like he
lost a plot and he just wasn't fully
there and there's a a few games I could
point to where it feels like once I got
stronger as the other side got weaker
in the game yesterday and the game today
it feels more of that kind of typical
top level back and forth even if there's
mistakes it's like Mistakes by both
sides and neither side is running away
with it neither side is playing
perfectly but neither side is playing
terribly it's a lot of back and forth
and also today it felt like one of those
games where
one side gets a chance uh they they
press the chance a little bit but they
don't make the most usually advantage
and then it kind of simplifies into a
drawish position of course we I don't
mean to speak about the game as though
it's a in the past tense it's still
thing is still working hard to to prove
the draw but
but he did turn a very very uh dubious
addition to one which is a direct
objectively drawn
sweating out a little
think tank in this one and we were just
thinking right it's a position that
we've seen before at least the idea of
just simply offering a rook trade on E7
and very often during the course of the
game as the game progresses you're into
the end game you've had your struggle of
the opening of the middle game trading
off well and and also countering super
attacking ideas which you have to be
very precise with at times even offering
an exchange sacrifice as we were seeing
in this game and then you come to this
end game how often is it that you kind
of start double guessing doubting your
own confidence in your ability to hold
this and sort of seeing ghosts in the
position and I'm asking that because
rookie seven is something that Ding has
done before where he's thinking for 12
minutes when he has the option you
actually repeat it in this position
yeah I'm surprised by his long thought
here because I I don't see the position
having changed too much compared to what
was it three moves ago when he played
Rook t7 or two moves ago and
okay so when I was playing Magnus in the
first game I was dead lost but
eventually we got to work in game which
was a draw
but I was feeling a lot of pressure in
that Rook end game and I knew of course
it's a draw but I was really feeling
so Under Pressure because
it was just like I'm losing the whole
game I'm absolutely exhausted and
he's still putting posing some practical
problems to me we both know it's a draw
but
you know you still have to make the
moves
I think that was a bit more complicated
than this end game but you can it can
get in your head and once it gets in
your head it's not so much about the
position on the board it's it's you know
are you panicking is your head working
right
I'm surprised that he's not playing Rook
t7 quickly
you know it's it's not like long thought
here is going to change anything
there's nothing to calculate it's uh
all the secrets in the position can be
pretty much figured out within you know
the first few minutes right
uh no concrete variations to look at
just okay I trade Rooks and I either
consider
uh whether the work trade is good for me
or not and he he doesn't offer the
trader Rooks at the moment
he ran away you know he made his move
and it sprinted elsewhere uh maybe to
get a refreshment maybe just to stretch
those legs but I have a question and
it's not for the two of you so you know
don't get too excited it's for the chat
I'm curious what chat thinks dangly Wren
will play with the white pieces tomorrow
we've seen him uh essay a bunch of
different openings he is not somebody
who's trying to be predictable so come
on get involved let us know what you
think dingley Ren will play I don't
typically ask the chat for
recommendations but I have changed I'm a
changed man I've grown so please let us
know what you think dingly Wren will
choose the white pieces after the rest
day tomorrow
that's a great question Robert and I
know that you said it's not for me and
Fabby but you know what I'm gonna take
it anywhere because we've been seeing
such amazing opening surprises by Ding
and that's been one of the unique
features of this world championship
match that you were mentioning uh Fabi
for you the three big conclusions one of
them just the kind of opening approach
that we've been seeing by the players
and I'm gonna predict at least the first
move it's gonna be one D4 I think Bobby
I'm gonna ask you as well for your
prediction when thing starts with the
white and let's just for now imagine
that this one does end peacefully
needing that one point to equalize what
do you think he'll start with
I think in English reverse facility is
very likely it's a it's a rich area
where you can search for ideas and we
already saw one of those reverse
Sicilians and it worked out very
successfully for ding right uh he came
back from a deficit in the match to win
a very nice game
and the nimsa with A3 E3 it's good for
one game it's not going to happen again
the whole H3 business that he tried and
didn't work out will never happen again
and probably ding will never even play
his entire career again because I don't
think he wants to see that that whole
line
um but they the reverse Sicilian it's
ding's territory Yan is a little bit of
a predictable Target there he he can
kind of predict where he on might go and
it had its Rich positionally so
definitely a place to look for ideas if
they find idea I think that's a natural
place to to strike
but I say this with low confidence I I
wouldn't bet much on it it's just that I
think it's a logical place for him
wow all right so I'm going with 1d4 Fabi
you're going with one C4 Robert do not
assume that you will be led off the hook
on this one you're the one who bought up
this question so I'm gonna ask you to
make an opening prediction for ding with
white yeah I'm not the unreliable lad
that just typed in chat uh but I don't
think we will see a sozen sicilian
because I don't think that even if
dingler and played E4 which I don't
think will happen that Jan would not
play the Sicilian there's no reason why
he would do that it's too risky of an
opening you know especially in the night
orbs why take the risk when he is up in
the match so no we're not gonna see a
bomb Cloud bill I mean come on come on
let's be real here we're gonna say
delayed Bond Cloud uh the gubernator
it's a G4 uh I think people are just
having fun now I asked a serious
question I wanted a serious answer I
have to say that guy's name should be
the grobanator that's what's awesome
later nice well played smooth the album
counter Gambit
is more Yan's choice so if if yon has a
moment of delirium he might decide to
start sacrificing Pawns in the opening
with black but
seems rather unlikely
the ding Gambit of time
oh is this is this uh
David Cronenberg I see crow in the
username wait did Cronenberg direct The
Crow
no no I don't know I was with Brandon
Lee no but the username was Crow tweet
so I I thought cro was just short for
Cronin Bobby took it come on I went too
far yeah you know you're you're like the
fly
[Laughter]
it's a good movie yeah we saw it
together well we not for the first time
we'd both seen it before but we watched
that at the last World Championship yeah
yeah that's right you guys are watching
movies at the last World Championship
oh
we hit all the animals we we saw Pig we
saw the fly we were just
going species after species what was
that nor well we probably shouldn't talk
about that Norwegian movie the the trip
or something like that that was like a
yeah let's not talk about the plot of
that one but yeah that one's a little a
little too adventurous but uh Bigfoot
who is you know producing the show since
I played the B3 special learn that on
chessable well they do seem to like B3
on chessable even though nobody actually
plays it and ding has played King f8
wow yeah adibon would not have been too
happy to hear that comment on one B3 uh
Robert uh but of course some
amazing some amazing uh options here for
ding that our chat is mentioning I doubt
we'll see one G4 one F3 bong Cloud but
then what's to say about this world
championship it feels like whatever you
expect the opposite of that happens it's
been an unpredictable opening Affair so
far and right now we are in this endgame
affair with a dingler in coming back
with the King perhaps once again the
idea of falling back with the Rook
offering a rook trade in this position
did we see any chances here for white to
try to defend F2 the only thing that
comes to mind is you've got to push the
king side pawns Jan's gonna make that
happen if it's a real try for anything
in this end game Fabi what's the way
that the pawns on the king side can
start rolling down the board well the
thing is why it has to deal with a very
direct threat which is F5
that's why he played King death f8 he
wants to pick up the F2 Pawn so if y
plays G3 F5 just wins upon and uh and
white will no longer have any winning
chances
and if white plays came to G1 and The
Rook gives a check and goes back and
that doesn't lead anywhere
if the King goes to G3 I feel like maybe
F5 is still an option but I'm not sure
uh but it also it also just allows
Knight to F5 checks so I'm not sure
maybe King G3 is an option F5 Knight F6
Knight E4 seems to trade the knights off
that's good for black
or at least favorable for for black
compared to what we currently have
so
this is this is one possible Direction
King F3 is also a move here for sure
and looks looks double-edged I don't
know if I would go for this black
because F5 is a rather committal
decision so maybe King G3
I don't see other logical moves because
you have to deal with the F5 thread
yeah you know I'm thinking even if white
plays like let's say white plays Rook to
D7 after King to f8 in the in the live
position
well this kind of invites 94 I was even
thinking like maybe maybe F5 is still
possible
uh but I don't know if if he would ever
go for it
just loses on the spot wow
and I'm wondering why what's the what
what's the killer blow here do you take
the Knight on D6 and is it because the
G6 Pawn is hanging
um that's that's a good question
I didn't see an immediately huge problem
with this
hmm interesting take the night take the
night
and what's the big move here
this is confusing it doesn't look like
it's a winning position but somehow it
you just go oh it's just
hd6 oh HG
oh this is not I was like H4 oh yeah H4
is winning you're absolutely right H4 is
the win
and then the G4 Pawn is going to fall
right even if you defend G6 King G3 is
coming next and you're gonna eventually
lose the G4 Pawn yeah you're if King F7
King G3 and if Rook F2 Rook G6 and you
lose that so we're finding good ways or
at least I'm finding good ways for black
to lose you're finding good ways to
refute my good ways so
uh Rook D7 is also an option King G3 why
does a few things to consider here
hmm
interesting but yeah what you're
pointing out F5 is actually a real
threat here king f8 is not as harmless
as it seems uh at first thought I
thought he just wants to offer another
Rook trade but you've got to be careful
in these end games as well especially
when you're playing the world's best
players and right now yeah is having a
thing will he go for Rook D7 trying to
set up this nasty idea of provoking F5
but it might be a very bad choice or
will he come with the king or we might
see a repetition King falling back to G1
give a check come back to E2 give a
check come back to E2 what are the
chances of the game finishing with a
repetition here
well Jana's no reason to do that so you
know he can play on in a million
different ways uh he doesn't want to end
this day just yet uh but I actually
think that that oversight that we were
talking about with Rook D7 Honda F5 this
is actually very hard to recognize once
you're in the moment and you see the
eval bar off the side think oh White's
winning because of H4 but two separate
pawns are under attack so when you get
to this point in your calculation you
think uh do I take on G4 I go up two
pawns do I take on G6 well if I take on
G6 they take on H3 and then take on F2
next I'm not gonna get away with it so I
feel like it's actually such an easy
thing to overlook if you're playing a
long game a very intense game and you
just missed the H4 and suddenly you're
lost so I think that a dingly run still
has some work to do after this Rook D7
move uh he can just move his Knight away
but with the Rook on the seventh Rank
and F7 in its sights he still needs to
be a bit careful the game is not
completely over just yet
I asked that question Fabi about what
are the chances of giving the repetition
I saw you were smiling was that because
you were gonna say a big zero this time
yes one as well I was gonna say zero but
then I remember the last time I said
zero it happened so now I'm going to
leave it at like one half a percent
chance so so I I have the safety net in
case
no but the thing is as Robert said like
yeah Jan has no reason he can always
make a draw there's no reason to to uh
acquiesce so quickly especially when it
feels like ding is feeling the pressure
a bit right he's been taking his time
uh he might as well
the thing is like when your opponent uh
creates a threat
at least you can now respond to his
threat so it's F5 so he Jan has an
intellectual challenge to to solve which
is at least can I stop F5 intermediate
draw whether that's with King G3 or Rook
D7 uh it's an interesting
piece of calculation for him so there's
no reason for him to to end it at the
moment Bobby what's the most drawn
position you've won against you know
another Super GM
I won like night Pawn against Bishop
against but not against the super
against the GM like 2600 GM but not
against this still you know that's
obviously in classical chess yeah it's
it's super rare In classical chess that
you you win these things at all like I
can't really think of many there's
simplified on games like this almost can
never think of like I I mean rook and
Bishop against Rook is is kind of common
that that people mess that up and and
you get winning chances
and so I
he plays King G3 okay
that makes a lot of sense you had broken
Bishop if I remember correctly twice at
the U.S Championship one game ended in a
draw the other you won right no so what
you're thinking of is is Gareth had it
twice oh
and the first game he had he drew and
then he plays me the next day we get it
I had to work in Bishop and then I beat
him yeah and
I I don't know exactly what happened it
was such a long chaotic game but
somewhere he gets confused in this rook
and Bishop and and the terms turned sour
for him I've had rook and Bishop in a
very crucial game against Peter swedler
in the 2016 candidates and it was two
rounds to go
I was uh tied with
um with Sergey kayaking
and my tie breaks were worse than his
because at the time the time the tie
breaks were not a playoff the tie breaks
War whoever had won most games which is
also coincidentally Whoever has lost the
most games has the better tie breaks and
he had lost the game and I had one two
and and drawn the rest he had won three
and lost one and so I kind of knew that
my tie breaks are bad I need to get
ahead of him in the score
uh because I'm playing him in the last
round as well with blacks so it's very
gonna be very difficult to win that game
and I'm playing Peter speedler we reach
rook and Bishop against Rook
it's a draw of course at the start but
then I'm slowly I'm like getting some
chances and eventually I get a winning
position I get what's known as the field
or position
and I don't win the the end game man
it's obviously very crucial for the
tournament results because I'm
now I need to beat karkin in the last
round with the black pieces I don't
manage to do that at karyakan wins
qualifies for the 2016 World
Championship
and
then I studied that Rook filter position
and a lot of other rook and bishopings
working games for for like a few weeks
straight basically so I would never
forget
and I think I will never forget
but but don't uh
you know don't quote me on that I might
forget something I didn't want to burst
your bubble but I think I also remember
another rook and Bishop end game you had
which one
Olympia 2018 is that right yeah but that
was that was against Judo yeah there's
so many rook and Bishop end games oh I
have a ton I I once beat level and
they're working visual Rook I I've I've
had like a million of them
super hard to defend a rook and Bishop
versus Rook when you're playing
your plaque and you definitely want ing
one side with the extra Bishop defending
it can be such a nightmare a mess those
position up so many times and I just
feel like when you're the one who's got
the extra piece it's also equally hard
to get that meeting net going to get
that position where you're actually
winning by force and very often what we
tend to do is just avoid going into a
pure rook and Bishop versus they're so
difficult to attend to actually defend
and on that topic I want to ask you Fabi
for a world championship preparation
right of course opening is a huge part
of it but what about these end games
what about these kind of typical setups
like a rook Bishop versus Rook or rook
and pawn and games wow okay we've got a
big move so I will wait on that question
because the move that you were pointing
at F5 a structural change hitting that
night with the F2 Pawn is defunded but
just to finish my question Fabi I was
going to ask how important is it in part
of preparation to actually look at those
kind of positions before going into a
world championship match
in terms of we did a lot of General
General chess training and a lot of
training games and so on not a lot of
General endgame work
um I I don't think that's been
like I I have done training in that area
of course but never like specifically
for
for that world championship I don't
think I think a lot of it was working a
lot on openings playing a ton of
training games and I felt like I was in
good form that entire year so all the
training it was working off throughout
the year I was having very good results
and
um always felt kind of sharp in in all
my tournaments
Jan quickly placed King to F3 which we
kind of said this was
and now he's he's frowning he's he's
trying to get him to ding's head a
little bit I guess
well what does date play ding is
wondering if Rook E7 still holds because
he can force the Rooks off and he does
it but you mentioned this earlier and
that's why I was nervous to say it Fabi
is that pushing the pawn to F5 there is
some drawback to that with the fixed
Pawn structure but ding has calculated
in this position it still should hold
well what what he's doing with this last
check is that if black players worked to
E8 now he will be forced to trade the
Rooks but he's very happy to not have
black thing on E7 because then the King
on E7 would go to F6 the king if it's on
E8
if like takes on EA with the King then
Knight to E5 is super annoying because
then you have to play G5 and you don't
really want that oh it might still be
fine but you you really don't want to
make that commitment or you have to play
Knight takes E8 and might also be
completely fine but
okay it's it's a little bit of a problem
to
95 King G7 King F4 King F6
doesn't look tremendously dangerous but
you know I can give a check on D7 and
it's still a bit annoying
uh and check on C5 or something yeah it
it's always going to be very Josh but at
least white was able to provoke this F5
move and this one's already dangerous
right like in this position
you need to calculate this way ahead
that this Pawn isn't getting to H7
quickly enough because after King E7 I
guess F5 is hanging but the point is
that it's hard to deal with all these
threats right like you protect F5
instead H4 like how do you save this
game
I have no idea if you even do save this
game and you certainly don't want to go
for it
here maybe the draw is F4 so that after
H4 King E7 H5 King f8 I'm in time
and if you ever play King F5 then or
King G5 there was probably like some F3
or something yeah just throwing this
Pawn away and this way so reverting the
structure that makes perfect sense but I
guess we're illustrating that it can
actually come down to the wire here I
need to be really really cautious uh
before just trading pieces and assuming
that you have the draw and that's what I
was mentioning earlier with complacency
you can't do that you always have to
calculate if you're dingly Ren and he's
doing that right rookie check he didn't
automatically respond he could bring his
King up if he feels that's safer but
he's not assuming that rookie 8 is a
draw he is calculating to make sure that
that would be the case
and I also want to say Yan's been really
good we're just trying to create some
small questions in this position we've
been talking about what a dead draw this
is right we've been talking about it's
almost a four gone conclusion that this
will end in a draw but he is making ding
think a little bit decide whether this
is the moment that he wants to create
the Rook whether if he moves the king
forward the Knight comes back and we see
some improvement in Jan's position the
king is ahead of the pawns the Knight is
in a good centralized post and black has
made well at least visually certain
weaknesses on the king side that can
come on the fire as you're saying as
you're pointing out Robert the king can
move to F4 to G5 at the right opportune
moment and the most important thing is
that Jan is forcing ding to think it's
not as if ding can make automatic
decision right now this is a big one he
needs to figure out whether going for
this Rook trade and again taking a big
middle push with that pawn on G5 you
move your Pawn once you can't take it
back is just how it goes and well after
that long think ding is ready for it
he's confident he says that I've
calculated this trade on E8 the only
move is 90 at an option also or will he
go for this idea of recapturing with the
King and then pushing the Jeep on
I'd be scared to put a jackpot on G5 for
sure because the more you push them the
more the weaker they get
but on the other hand you are avoiding
any sort of King F4 G5 invasions you
know what I just remembered I don't know
how this came to me but I remember that
there was a game
a nod Carlson
and uh sorry Carlson was white Carlson
and not and it was played like a long
time ago I don't know some Vikings a
tournament long long time ago I think
might might not have been Vikings a but
Carlson was like winning winning winning
and then suddenly it's going to this end
game Rook might three against Knight two
and I re I remember these pawns I think
it's the structure with the fun F5 it's
suddenly like reminded me of this
and and Carlson won that game it was a
draw it was drawn draw and drawn and
then suddenly final mistake happens like
it starts to get a little bit difficult
and then one mistake one objective
mistake turns evaluation drawn to losing
and I don't remember the details of the
game but just like vaguely remembering
this game uh which which Carlson won I
don't know if
um
someone could do the research here and
someone from chat maybe could could
figure out how this game exactly how it
went sour for the knight in two pawns
but but I I suddenly remember this game
and so there's definitely some scenarios
where it goes wrong for the weaker side
for the side of the two pawns I think I
was commentating that I feel that sounds
very familiar so it must have been in
the last five years but I I
can't recall exactly when it was but I
know it was oh it was even one of the
games that was on tour so it wasn't
Viking Zay but not actually in Vikings
day so it was in like Leiden or
something but I can't remember the year
but I know exactly what you're talking
about
yeah I can't remember either but this
year was playing Maybe
I don't remember if it was a long time
ago or if it was like 2019.
that sounds right that's it let's see if
the chat can verify that for us but that
sounds pretty accurate
I'm I'm just like by the way it's on the
board just want to say that 95 G5 you've
been calling out this end game the ct5
played the only way to defend the pawn
this can potentially create weaknesses
on those pawns is there if white was to
go H4 here or sacrificing the pawn only
to regain that F4 square but the more
pawns that do get liquidated the more
pawns that get traded black gets closer
a step closer to that draw right so H4
you gotta hold on to that
yeah h4gh King to F4 it's still a bit
annoying because if King to E7 and white
gets his Knight G6 Knight H4 which also
looks like a draw but black is sort of
paralyzed
uh I guess black can play 94 F3 Knight
D6 and G3 and now black has to
play King to E6 and then King G5 okay
it's you know you're you're definitely
hanging on by a thread at this point but
it's probably still a thread which holds
Knight to F7 King g695 and so on
so
there's danger here H4 is an interesting
option but it it feels a bit like
you don't want to take this uh concrete
approach just yet you still want to wait
a little bit do you want to kind of poke
around a bit more
and you know this alternative is if you
could play F4 right now that would be
very dangerous for black because if I
could spring free and outside pawns it's
just to sort of show what that looks
like if I get in a situation like this
no exactly it is winning for white if
you could get F4 in so the king being on
F3 uh that is what prevents white from
winning this game and so that means
after the move King to E3 okay King f8
was I was just trying to illustrate
let's look at that one a little bit King
to fa because I don't think it's like
obvious how white wins but takes a king
to E7 let's say I think it's just the
move Knight to F3
rather than King G5 even maybe King G5
is also good but Knight F3 King F6
Knight to D4
King to G6 H4
King to F6 and H5 and you have gotten
into Zeus one wow and so this is the
type of way that you could lose these
end games potentially if you're if
you're being careless
so yeah as you said King to E7 would be
necessary after King to E3
wow yeah it's amazing how one little
difference uh can change the evaluation
completely so in this position after G5
King E3 King f8 is we knew it wasn't a
good move we were just trying to make a
quick move King E7 is important and this
king gets the F6 I guess just in time in
many of these positions but even this
looks kind of worrisome to my eyes
yeah for sure
you know what I'm thinking in the in the
live position this move G4 is like
rather dangerous looking I think that
black has to play King to E7 G takes a
five and King to F6
because if you take on a five I think
you lose with King G4
Knight to five King G4 King F6 and now
he still says drop a knight D7 nope it's
sandwich now you go see I know what
you're going to do you are you go around
you go you do the little tour
oh King g69 G5 and you're up two Farms
so wait what's the draft for King G4
because the computer was saying that
there was something no I think it was
just uh I was moving and it didn't react
just yet but since this is somehow
holding for black oh Knight to D6 holds
it
oh
okay yeah yeah it's uh
I mean at that point you're in an easy
process of elimination because other
moves are obviously bad but you know
there's danger we're already in
territory where one move why draw one
move by loose
find these precise defensive resources
we're seeing two ideas for Yan to
continue posing problems one is the one
that you pointed out Robert sidestep
with the King and threaten the move F4
which ding would have to precisely
navigate it can get really dangerous and
after King E3 black also doesn't want to
further Advance his own pawns creating
more weakness on that King side and the
other idea that
Fabi you're pointing out which also
poses a very direct question in the
position is G4 how do you handle uh the
tension on the king's side once again
there Yan with his death stare as we
just saw we see the clock situation
while Jan's got about 55 minutes ding
around 30 minutes uh still about six
moves left to make time control how
difficult will this be in these last few
critical moves for ding to be precise In
This Moment let's say whether G4 working
E3 do you expect ding to handle it
without too much problem
I think that this is already like ding
has probably seen all the lines we
mentioned he sees G4 King E7 he's
already seen it in advance when he
decided to go for this
uh he's seen this F4 King F6 stuff it's
it's it's good territory for him because
it's very concrete direct calculation
and it's one of his very clear strengths
for sure and
I don't know if it was the best approach
but once he's here I still think that
this is so so likely to end peacefully
the other thing is that maybe with white
I would try King D3 King E7 King D4 just
want to go around and keep as many pawns
as possible on the board this is what
would
come to mind to me as an option for sure
you fight against the threat of f4 but
can is it really bad for black instead
of King E7 to go F4 himself to fight it
it's very scary because you kind of make
a weakness and I see it's not a good
idea and I'm guessing that's because you
just simply slide back with the King and
then when you go H4 you're actually
gonna end up losing both your king side
bonds
I have a feeling this move is bad for a
number of reasons one is that the king
can go to D5
and you don't want that King to be there
because then you'll slowly get your
knight will be forced uh to go and then
the king might invade via E4 the other
reason is as you said like maybe King
Tab 3 and H4 and then taking on F4 is is
gonna be very bad for black and then you
just pick up that A4 pawn and I'm even
thinking that maybe white can just like
sack the Knight on F4 play three pawns
against the Knight it's it's borderline
losing uh from what I know about the end
game
I don't know if it's like always losing
but but very often this is like a losing
end game
here the computer says that it's
I have a draw but okay obviously white
doesn't have to go for this but I don't
think that you want to allow this you
know you I would never want to allow uh
Knight against three pawns for sure
all right so looks like King E7 would be
the right way and the only way the ding
has to find to counter the threat of f4
if Yan goes for the idea of posing this
big question with a sidestep from the
King to E3 uh opening up the path of
that F Pawn two big choices for Jana
pamushi go for G4 another direct
question or sidestep with the King and
we see yeah and he's kind of looking
into nothingness right now what do you
think is going on in his mind
that's a good question I think he wants
to play for a win and he's trying to
figure out the variation that challenges
ding the most and no I mean if there's a
thing about chess players they may seem
like they're lounging that they're about
to take a nap but they're always
calculating so Jan isn't just sitting
here looking away this is his
calculation phase right he is really
trying to figure out a variation that
challenges ding the most and he's seeing
do I push the G Pawn do I push the H
Pawn do I move the king and push the F
Pawn do I push no pawns at all I just
March my king in first he just wants to
make dings life difficult because the
last thing chess players want to do is
to hand their opponent a result you
never want to lose the game so you don't
want to blunder but it's very important
to these top players and Fabi you can
speak this more than I can of course
that when you have an advantage it's not
even necessarily about winning the game
because it's not a winning Advantage but
you want to press and press and press
make your opponent suffer make them
prove that they can defend and get that
desired result rather than just handing
it to them
yeah this this is one of those positions
where given enough time you can
basically figure out every detail of the
position every possible draw every trap
every way
that you could win if your opponent
messes up
and with the amount of time he has which
is over 50 minutes
he could figure this position out
several times over so that's why he's in
a relaxed calculation mode he's he's
calculating of course but he's not doing
it in a way that he would calculate if
he had five minutes on his clock which
is that he would be concentrating on the
board intently he's sort of you know he
understands the position as a draw but
he's still trying to figure out all the
details and he doesn't have to be super
super laser focused at the moment now
he's sort of like getting into the uh
you know now I'll start to look at the
position again it's also a bit of acting
of course
it's like if there's a win here I'll
find it and I don't even have to stress
out doing it
but um yeah I've felt this mode a lot
myself it's like
and we've we've reached a position where
I just have to calculate it out so
I'll I'll make my poses you know think
this way think that way and and
eventually try to find it some idea in
the position
he has only like three moves that would
even come to mind one is King E3 one is
G4
one is H4
I'll probably G4 of the main moves to
calculate G4
is like a direct we need to attempt it's
either winning on the spot or not right
we saw black basically has to play King
E7
because if you push the pawn then H4
comes and if you take on G4 then King G4
will likely win the g-pawn so
G4 is the first move that comes to mind
after you reject that you you move on to
King E3
after you reject that you uh start to
get disappointed
I loved how our chat pointed out
is the modern thinking pose well the
original thinker it is all about and I
think it was all about philosophy and
contemplation but this one's nothing
about that in 2023 the modern thinking
pose is indeed about the chest position
as you're pointing out Robert that very
often chess players tend to look away uh
and they might not even be looking at
the board but the only thing in their
mind the only thing that they're
actually thinking about is indeed the
position on the board calculating and
navigating through these variations we
see Yan once again looking away he is
trying to decide which is the option
that perhaps gives him the best chance
and perhaps makes ding really think in
this position and offers the biggest
problem for him to go wrong it is a
critical moment because once again if
ding is able to navigate it correctly in
just a few moves we will have a result
for game nine
I'm still thinking Jan will decide
between one of these two options that
we've been looking at G4 or King E3 uh
do you think Yan is also just trying to
come to terms with the fact because I
know that this happens when we're
playing right what has happened before
in the game the fact that he had all
these opportunities of capturing that
Rook on B5 the fact that it could have
been a more difficult task for dingler
and to hold this game is that something
that plays on a player on a player's
mind while in the end game all the
missed opportunities of what has
happened because sign me up for that
club happens to me all the time
and I think Fabiano has shown that chess
players have great memories sometimes to
a fault so it's hard to forget what has
happened in this game and sometimes hard
to forget what happened a decade ago in
some random game that was next to you uh
but in this context Jana Pomchi
undoubtedly is upset about how this game
has gone because he did have the upper
hand he was playing very well for good
portions of the game and that he'd let
that Advantage slip and what I like
about this is it demonstrates a
determination not just to Coast to the
Finish Line If draws or presents him he
will take them and he will win the match
by a point but he is not saying he's not
resting on his Laurel saying I have a
point lead that's going to remain he is
trying to end this match under his own
control he wants to win games and get to
that finish line so I think that Jan he
should be a bit upset with himself
that's the sign of any chess player in
any situation and I think that whether
or not he is a Rodan sculpture that he
is trying to find a way here to win this
game he knows that it should be a draw
but there is wiggle room there is an
opportunity for ding to go wrong and he
wants to capitalize that if he can trick
him
yeah I think he's still in the game mode
not in the disappointment mode that that
might come after the game if this ends
in a draw then he might be disappointed
but hopefully for his sake only briefly
because I think one of the good
qualities for chess players to be able
to get over things quickly
and
as we all know as NHS player knows
you're gonna have to deal with a lot of
disappointments a lot of missed chances
and you don't want that Weighing on you
or the tournament or even for the rest
of your career you want to be able to
get over it quickly and I'm sure that
he'll be able to you know uh clear his
mind of the potential mischances they
weren't even that big especially
compared to let's say ding's chances
yesterday
but the potential mischances that he
might have had in this game
just clear his mind of that and move on
to the next game the next next task next
opening whatever whatever it is
so but at the moment he's not thinking
about the previous moves in this game
he's just thinking do I have some
winning chances here if so uh what are
they
that is the big question where are his
biggest chances in this end game
undoubtedly Yan knows that Joy is the
most likely result but he's going to try
and milk this one out uh till the very
end we've also not
we've often seen ding being the one in
driving seat regardless of the fact that
Yan is the one who's leading the match
regardless of the fact that Jan has this
one point lead if you just look at the
games themselves very often ding has had
the upper hand so Jan really enjoying
this position he does have the extra
Pawn it's a game for two results so one
can totally understand his desire to try
to play this art till the very end and I
have to say I haven't seen Yan take this
much time in the opening or the middle
game as much as we're seeing him in this
end game is that something that
surprises you Robert
uh no I I think that Jan has played a
very good game for the most part uh of
course he spoiled some good chances and
he is going to regret it after the game
his father is talking about but he
remains up one of these so why not enjoy
his time where he's got an extra one and
he is going to hold on to it and try to
get it to the other side of the board
and get a queen so I think that Jan even
though he had some more chances earlier
on I mean a draw is not a bad result
when you're playing such strong
competition like you're against dingley
Ren and he had the upper hand throughout
the majority of the game he has nothing
to really be too hard on himself about
uh and I think it also changes the
trajectory because in game seven he was
worse for most of it he did win in
ding's time trouble in game eight he was
completely lost at some points he gave a
rook it was a Desperado it was a bluff
and it worked out but he actually was
worse for the large majority of those
two games and then here in game nine he
says well I'm just gonna be ahead for
the most part he played some great moves
he had some good decision making and he
may not score a full point but I think
it's a very good change of pace if you
will for young the Palm machine
and well on that note I have to bring it
up as well Robert check this out
I'm wondering if Favi has one too I
don't have one but I I just want to say
that I'm glad you guys have the small
mini Pawns
and that you don't have the Danny sized
Pawn hiding under your desk no we don't
because that would be that would be very
disturbing I've got the kid pawn and
I've got the baby Pawn as well
oh I have the baby Pond but it's
somewhere else so I need to go I need to
go find it
is in this end game three versus two he
is really trying to grind this down guys
how difficult is it for ding to be in
this position right it's been a long day
for him he's had to defend from the very
start from the opening another Black by
the way where he didn't manage to
equalize uh completely out of the
opening so still struggling there a
little bit with the prep when it comes
to the black pieces for ding what do you
think is going on in his mind right now
how confident is he feeling about this
to be able to hold this one
I think that he's he's feeling very
confident I mean the variations that he
has to calculate he's probably already
gone through them several times and
and it doesn't seem like white has an
abundance of uh dangerous moves here we
mentioned some of them
but I feel like ding has already
calculated to his heart's content and
he's not
probably overly concerned he knows that
the position is an objective draw for
sure and now it's just a matter of you
know what will Dion try and responding
to that but I don't think he's concerned
in the sense that he's worried his
position is bad he I'm sure he he knows
that it is a draw
more young things probably the more
content
it will be a Billy for the Chinese
Superstar to keep things under control
to go into the final five games as uh
with trailing with just a one point
margin and he also starts with the white
pieces in the next one but currently Yan
in a big Think Tank almost 20 minutes I
don't think Robert we've seen this
happen in the world championship so far
it's rare I mean John de Palm she
doesn't go that deep into the think tank
unless he since this is a very critical
moment that he can't just work out with
his very quick calculation skills and so
he's looking at this end game he's just
trying to find chances he's trying to
prolong the game even though both
players know it is objectively a drawn
position so for you on the palm machine
it makes sense to me I think he's doing
the right thing it's also instructive
for the many players who are trying to
improve their own game when you have a
situation like this and you may think
it's a Surefire a draw try to find ways
to challenge your opponent the most
don't just trade off the pawns so just
to show something very quickly of what
would be a very easy draw uh for uh
dangly Wren is like let's say you play
this H4 move and you give this Pawn up
and then you bring this king and you
bring this King here and I get this
check so essentially my point is you may
give away all the pawns and even if this
Knight comes here to win this Pawn this
is actually as easy as it gets for
dingley Ren he knows his one task is to
sacrifice this night for that pawn so as
soon as your Pawn pushes up to G4 I am
taking it and that is a draw because you
can't win with a lone night so this I
made it look simple just because I was
making very rapid moves but for young
apology he's like I don't want to love
that I want ding just have a couple
tough choices and we showed in other
variations that it can get tricky even
though the limited material should allow
a draw with best play
wow and Jan really trying to figure out
what is the biggest problem that he can
pose in the position this is his last
chance this is that critical moment
where he can ask the most difficult
question today and just hope and pray
that Ding might not be able to find his
way but it looks like this one will be
heading towards the draw and Jan would
maintain his one point lead well going
into game nine this is game nine these
were the odds that Ian had approaching
game nine and this is how it would
change based on the results of how this
game would end the outcome of game nine
if Yan would win today it would be a 94
uh odd to Yan winning the world
championship match with the draw our
chesscom stats team gives it a 78 chance
to win the match in favor of
janapamnushi coming into the game with
odds like this what are yans what is
yanza mindset Fabi
well I think that's for sure he he is a
big favorite uh regardless of whether he
won this game or or drew it in the match
just because we know we're nearing the
final stretch and he is ahead
and for the last few games I feel like
he has been the better player like for
for the game yesterday and for the game
before it really feels like ding was the
one making more mistakes
that being said this game is a
confidence boost today I think for sure
and it's it's going to come down a lot
to that next game with the white piece
that thing has can he continue to create
chances he's not going to have so many
games with white pieces left and you
can't really count on winning with black
it's just too difficult usually it
sometimes happens we saw that second
round but usually it's too difficult so
will he be able to create more chances
that's that's really going to be the
telling Factor
yeah that's going to be the big point in
the next one but there is action on this
one well Jan chose a third way to go for
a direct approach and this is a line
that we were looking at a potential Pawn
sacrifice on H4 but it's a temporary one
you just separate black spawns only to
go and pick them up a move later the
idea is not only to separate the pawns
but also to get that key F4 Square for
the white king and this was a line that
we looked at earlier Fabi Robert King F4
can uh appear on the board at this
moment hitting that F5 pawn and if black
tries to advance with his own King there
is a check on G6 forking that King and
that pawn on H4 I do see Yan reaching
out he's made the move King f4 on the
board 94 a possibility as we've been
talking about King E7 which one are we
expecting by ding
so I I have this little funny line to
show Knight to E4 I like the move
F3
oof apparently it's very bad but F3 my
ID was Knight to F2
and if King takes F5 then H3 makes a
draw
and if King to E3 there was this little
trig that's the only reason I want to
show is Lion King to E3 H3
and if King takes F2 a huge blunder H2
promotes the pawn
uh of course white if I would never fall
for this but uh I actually think that 94
loses maybe because of Knight's D3
maybe that's why uh the refutation is
option 96 you just want to go King E5 is
that your point
is King G5 a better version now
apparently it must be king E5 then
King E5 King E7 and is it just F3
or Knight F4 Knight G6 is that an idea
F3 I like it as well but yeah Knight of
four I was thinking might E4 but then F3
is it's pretty good then it comes with
example right
yeah
I'm not sure why F3 draws but I guess
there are some very good reason for it
that's a good question because F3 looks
so strong after King E7 and I'm
wondering maybe we should just try and
find out why Precision is required why
is F3 a check oh it's nice before yeah
and Knight takes uh King F5 93 of course
yeah
so so you can't fall for this so Knight
F4 actually defends that really
important G2 pawn it allows all these
sort of F3 things without dropping the
G2 Pawn
although there is like actually I
if you play F3 in this position let's
just make like a neutral move like King
D7
F3 Knight C4
King F5 Knight E3 King G5 my G2
oops ig2 92 loses yeah you can't do that
H3 and
it's typical uh typical sort of uh
pattern for how the Knight gets
dominated by a lone Pawn
so yeah all this is fantasy but it shows
that
dick is thinking I'm sure that he'll
figure out 94 93 but he is still
thinking about the move
the critical moment because Knight E4
also feels like such a natural move that
you could be really tempted to play
right because you want to try and trade
off as many pawns as possible in the
position you want to put pressure on
that F2 Pawn so it's not super hot but
ding definitely needs to find it we saw
that after 94 Knight D3 the eval bar
gives a massive advantage to White and
nepo could be staring at a win if ding
Falls for this so the other option that
you that we were discussing well perhaps
the only move that Ding has in this to
keep the position balanced is come come
forward with his own King get the get
that King moving to defend his pawns so
King E7 and here he's got to navigate
and evaluate what happens after the
check the Knight capturing on H4 because
visually it does look uncomfortable your
king and your knight it almost feels
like a Zug Swang right your king and
your knight is stuck defending that F5
Pawn
yeah and white can also maneuver if King
E6 here
I think maybe black should provoke F3
instead but here King is ignite to F3
starts to get a bit annoying because
King to F6 Knight to D4
and yeah I guess you go to G6 and it's
still
either side is holding on but it doesn't
look super Pleasant King to E5 Knight to
F7 it's again this this idea and the
King D6 Knight to G5
so
it's it's a little bit of an unpleasant
end game but probably
white just doesn't have enough resources
it's just too too few too few moves left
in this position you know white has so
few pieces left and that's the main
issue I I think that thing will thing
will not fall for Knight to E4 I think
he'll play King to E7
I mean after defending so heroically 94
would be too much of a heartbreak to
take in this one Fabi Robert what's your
take on this how difficult is it to be
precise in this moment for ding
I think that he is doing the right thing
he's continuing to do this anytime he
has a move that's in line with his
previous plan he knows he's ultimately
going to play it but he double triple
quadruple checks because if he makes an
inaccuracy now it's not just the game
over you lose we just saw 94 is a losing
mistake and for Yan he will capitalize
on it so I think that uh ding will play
King the E7 but he is just trying to
verify that these lines work out because
I think from a distance from afar it
looks like there could be some zooksvong
that cost you the game and so he's just
trying to put his pieces in the right
squares
wow yes this is the moment they need to
be precise now or things could turn
around very drastically for black here
ding has to find the move King E7 to
keep everything under control we're
gonna go into a shot break when we
return we'll find out if ding has been
precise we love that pose but there's
thinking to be done
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's been five intense hours of play in
game nine of the world championship
match between janapamneshi and ding
Loren in Astana Kazakhstan and
apparently after a heroic defense for
majority of those five hours dingler and
with that final moment where he needs to
find the precise move here and he's got
to make that move with the King stopping
one step forward or it could all be for
nothing it could all be in weight it is
a big moment for ding he has been
thinking for 10 minutes here Fabi you
said that Ding should be able to
navigate this without too much trouble
Robert you as well echoed the same
sentiment but a 10 minute thing does
that get you guys a little worried for
ding here
foreign
yeah I'm I'm
thinking that 94 could it could be a
trap it's I don't know if
what the thought process would be I'm
trying to figure out the thought process
like 94 let's say you see F3 Knight F2
is like a very
clean clinical draw but Knight D3 why
would you
prefer that like let's say you play
Knight D6 and you completely missed the
move King D5
you think only King to G5
maybe you think that's an easier way to
do it because then you play King to F7
or King to E7
and if not King E5 like maybe it's in
like 96 here and if not King D5 if King
to G5 then you think King E7
and you think this is a much easier
thing because after King takes H4 blacks
can gets to F6 and there's no King to L
on F4 anymore
so I'm trying to like work through the
process thought process of how you could
come to the conclusion in Knight to E4
and this could be a way you have to miss
King E5 and then you have to think this
is an easier pass to a draw
so I do see some Contours for uh you
know everything's easy for us because we
see the bar going up and down these are
really complex end games it's not clear
to players I I'm sure they both know
that this is a draw or at least they
have like a very strong suspicion but
they don't know exactly which move is to
draw which is not right so they have to
take out their own so it's possible
to make a mistake here it's not out of
the question in a rapid game I might
even not even be surprised if it if it
happens that someone plays Knight to E4
um
the reason why it worries me is because
obviously he is not 100 confident that
the most obvious move came to E7 Knights
and G6 King F6 Knight to H4
he's not 100 confident that confident
that this is a draw because he's
thinking I will get sugwanged at some
point here
and I'll have to like F3 because you you
don't want to learn it for check F3 King
F6 G3
and I have to allow the king into G5
and this is where his hesitation lies
he's thinking oh I don't really want to
allow this and he's worried King E5 here
for example might just be a losing move
because of f4 King E6 King G6 although
yeah this this for example is losing
um I don't know how black was drawing to
be honest but
but maybe there was some way so this is
the stuff that he's worried about and
then he might see the move Knight F7 and
it might
make him feel confident
instead of King to E5
you might see Anita sudden check
and then he thinks okay King g695
but still you're you see this King to G7
and you still feel a bit worried about
the position
even though yeah you assume that it
should be a draw some out but you're
still a bit worried like what's my next
move here
f4g I was trying to do this you know so
that's that's a beautiful way to draw
but G4 instead of G takes F4 right right
I'm just trying to show everybody the
king and Knight versus King will not be
a win but as Fabi is saying uh I was
trying to trick and he says no and G4 is
just too strong the pawn will push and
the King helps escort it to the other
side that will become a queen and the
Knight on H4 defends the F3 Pawn so Fabi
I mean you're right that this is
actually very deep this exact variation
here like at this moment after King G7
you think all right if my king moves I'm
losing contact with the F5 Pawn if my
knight moves somewhere say back to C6 uh
is there going to be some kind of f4 and
a potential zuke spawn going forward uh
what's the deal this Knight can also
reroute at some point so there are so
many things to consider here it's not
straightforward the engine often
misleads Us in the sense that we get a
sense of security because we know
without any degree of questioning that
it's this evaluation that it's even that
should be a draw but when you're at the
board after this grueling not just this
grueling game but this whole match the
atmosphere is intense the gameplay has
been a struggle it's it's definitely
somewhere you can go wrong and look at
things reactions he's looking at the
clock I I'm getting a bit nervous that
I'll bring it back to the live board
that he could make an error here I want
to explore that position a bit just
because it's like kind of personally
fascinating
after King to G7 Knight to C6 because
I'm reaching out for something I'm sorry
Fabi but yes you have to continue with
this analysis but every time he reaches
out I'm just so terrified that he might
pick up the Knight and because we've
seen those lines it would be game over
and this isn't any game right as was
seen in our favor of feature chat as
well if yeah wins this it could very
well mean match over as well so it's a
really critical moment
ding has to make the move King E7 and
every time he's reaching out for a piece
hard slightly fast
sorry continue with your line no I think
we we all want to see a draw here
because it would keep a great deal of
intrigue in the match while a loss for
ding would be pretty disastrous it
wouldn't decide the match but it would
make it really tough for him to make
comeback so uh I I do hope that he makes
the move King to E7 because it would be
a tragic way to lose but he's he's
looking very concerned very nervous and
when you get nervous that's the moment
that you make it he makes another move
he makes H3 and I see our eval bar
doesn't move so things to what is H3
first question it's upon sacrifice
Bobby that pawn was gone one way or the
other so after GH3 does he just want to
play King to E7 I I guess so
H4 King F6
we didn't consider it but it seems like
a perfectly uh
reasonable way of trying to make a draw
and maybe even easier than the kind of
long lines that we were considering
right because now H5 Knight to E4 and
then if the Knight gets to D5 that white
king gets pushed back F3 Knight C3
followed by oof maybe there's a oh
Knight Knight to C5 to avoid the 97
check yeah
you're absolutely right
and now Knight T6 and the king gets
pushed back and black makes a draw
okay we did see a capture on H3 Kingston
play so you know it's funny we see
brilliances as sacrifices for checkmates
for huge moves that win games but uh and
I wanna this allows him to potentially
make an easier draw because these pawns
are not connected connected pawns are
always useful because they can protect
one another upon's best friend is
another Pawn now the pawns are split
this Knight will be able to jump around
and start attacking them and that should
give ding the ability to hold the
balance so H3 may it be just a great
choice even if the evaluation bar
doesn't react it's just a really good
move that makes it easier for him to
accomplish his task
well it's very good for him oh sorry
Tanya no complete your Fabi
please take over
well I was gonna say it's very good for
him that the evaluation board doesn't
react because he doesn't want to see the
evaluation by react at all but yeah it
looks like a very practical choice
because in these in these kind of
positions of the eval bar
study just impressive defense step by
day we were looking at these different
options and it wasn't on our radar this
move wasn't a move that we actually
looked into so it just really shows the
kind of focus and resourcefulness that
Ding is bringing to this game just how
important it is to find these ideas that
just makes his process of defending this
very crucial game as easy as possible
and we saw the eval bar say it approves
things are still under control uh and
Robert a really nice Point made by you
that why give up that H4 Pawn for free
when in the process you can actually
disconnect White's bosses
foreign
but I love learning from the best
players in the world and for ding to
have that recognition that even if the
alternative was still a draw this makes
his life easier because these pawns are
split and that variation that Fabiano
brought up where you get to maneuver
your night around first you protect your
Pawn but you're gonna end up maneuvering
your knight around to C5 you're kick
this King out of here and the pawns
can't defend one another because they
are isolated rather than on adjacent
files so I think it was a really really
good choice I see you saying chat said
H3 uh Chet says all sorts of things I'm
supposed to believe you at every turn
but no on this turn it was a great move
indeed so dingley ran and chat Round of
Applause
I love it well done on that laundry here
I'm just kind of wondering like what is
White's best try because obviously Jan
is still searching hard for the idea
and I think Jan would probably beat chat
no disrespect meant
but I I'm thinking the move Knight C6 is
still an interesting try here
[Laughter]
that we were looking at putting pressure
exactly on that pawn on F5 jumping back
to D4 so let's say if black was to come
forward with the King to F6 you want to
start already putting a lot of pressure
94 and Knight E4 F3 might have two
I tough two
and if H4 you get Knight D3 and you're
you're stopping it all
yeah that that leads to a draw so is
there maybe F3 after King F6
so not Knight to D4 so I give that check
King to F6 and F3 and I take away the D4
Square would not be
Robert I saw you had two words F7 that
also looks like a good idea
yeah
H4 is it super easy I was wanting to get
my knight to a checking square but you
just took away all my squares
don't play Knight h8 because then Knight
to E5 well it's funny nice even King G6
is 95 right just trade them all yeah
well that's game over immediately oh
wait Knight h8 95 I'm actually not sure
if that
like into E6
it's not obvious to me it's just like
black is completely relegated to
passivity but how do you exploit it it's
shocking no it's just six H6 King E6 oh
my God that's insane that that position
holds
I mean this is ridiculous like
195 and somehow you still survive wow
wow
yeah but it's so difficult to put your
knight on h8 voluntarily and just from
far away just convince yourself that you
will be able to hold that position so
you've got to try and think of all these
uh of all these angles when you choose
the move that you want to pick up Knight
C6 check Robert and in that variation I
wanna I wanna take a look at the other
option how important is it for black to
actually voluntarily go to that h8
square is after F3 because Knight D4 we
saw 94 things are fine it's nightly five
a big enough accuracy it's not so yes
that's a good move sorry I was just
saying that it's approved and you're
stopping White's main plan so Fabi take
that Knight B5
Knight C3 coming in yeah
yeah exactly so it's not only stopping
Knight D4 but Black's only task in this
position is get the Knight to E6 or D5
give a check there and once you give
that check once White's King is forced
back you no longer have any attacks on
that F5 pawn and
you really can't like being one Pawn up
is not enough you need to win that F5
Pawn so if you're no longer attacking
with that with your king you you won't
be able to find a way to break through
Knight B5 is a nice move I don't see any
ideas for white here you can play Knight
to B4 but then Knight C7 again stops an
id5 check and prepares Knight to E6 and
I think at this point we can already
call a draw pretty much so what will you
try and ic6 doesn't seem to be
uh working out as a great test he's he's
definitely concentrated thinking hard
here does it help to start with F3 in
the live in the current position as we
have it F3 and then wait for your king
to make a move and maybe a better jump
with the Knight
yeah this is this is very logical
because King F6 allows Knight to D7
possibly
and King to E6 it might not really lead
anywhere but it's another thing for
black to consider so you might as well I
still think that I don't see where the
knight's going the Knight really needs
to
um like the C5 check doesn't work out
you kind of need to first put black and
zuzuong with the Knight on D4 and then
get your king in it's not about checking
the black king around so much
Robert and look at Jan he's I haven't
seen Yan in this pose so far in this
world championship match he's really
trying to find his best chance in this
end game where it lies the dingler and
with impressive defense there Robert
what do you make of yan the amount of
time he's spending right now how focused
he looks in this position usually even
in bad positions Jan almost looks
dismissive he comes on the board he
makes a move fast gets up immediately
he's got this confident demeanor
regardless of what the actual objective
eval is right now this is a very focused
Yan Robert he can sleep all day tomorrow
if he needs it is a rest day in Astana
so he doesn't have to come to the chess
board he can rest his brain and he must
be exhausted because this is a long
match uh but I think part of it is that
he he really respects dingley Wren so
when ding gets the white pieces Jan's
like oh what am I going to do because
let's talk about the last three games
that young had the black pieces uh in uh
game I'm losing track now game four was
it that was when ding one with white in
game six ding one with white in game
eight yesterday ding probably should
have and would have won with white in
like 98 out of 100 games but Jan did
survive that one so the England has
proven that he could take down
janapomchi when he gets the white pieces
so Jan doesn't want to just sit here and
be like okay I'll be fine in two days
I'll totally be okay with the black
pieces because evidence has shown that
he has not been very okay when he gets
the second move so I I think that it's
you know both focusing on the extra
material in this game but also giving
that nod that credit to dingly Wren like
hey I need to beat you when I have the
white pieces because you may beat me
when you get white
yeah I think that
that's why ding should be happy with
this result If he if he makes the draw
in this position that it's it seems like
he is not slipping up he's he's heading
that way towards a draw he could be
happy because not only has he beaten
Beyond twice in the last three games
with the white pieces
he's also uh as you mentioned got in a
winning position in that third game
which he didn't convert but he the
interesting thing is that he did it with
different openings every single time one
was a reverse Sicilian
he didn't like get an advantage from the
opening or if it was it was a very small
one then he got a London system uh you
know people don't play the London to get
an advantage from the opening they they
play it to get some sort of tough uh
long fight right and there he actually
did get some sort of uh Advantage but it
was you know a rather small positional
one which eventually turned into a big
one and then he plays a super sharp Nim
so all different approaches different
openings but somehow each game he's
getting chances it it's actually quite
inspiring I have to say that he's
somehow finding
um opportunities under every rock that
he looks under so London here himself
there it's it's uh for like a top player
or a strong player it's inspiring to see
um how he's managing to outplay such a
well-prepared and strong opponent as
young
and very often in these World
Championship matches we've traditionally
seen the approach of having these
openings and then finding a sort of a
slight deviation or an offbeat track
much later on but players tend to stick
to the main structure of the starting
moves right uh in your world
championship we very often saw the
Petrov appearing we saw Magnus dick to
his swashnikov there was only more
happening and then some deviation down
the road even in the Yan Magnus match we
saw the Catalan being repeated the
anti-martial being played out we'll hear
from the very start from the from move
number one we've been seeing new
openings by the players and I feel like
ding has been the one who's been leading
that Brigade and of course his team with
Richard rappo has got a big role to play
in that some of these openings that
we've seen happen often seem to be like
a one-game try including the London
where he can win singly well it was a
crushing Victory with the white pieces
or even the fourth fourth move H3 ID
yeah that we saw in the Queen's Gambit
decline by ding with the white pieces
can you tell us a little bit about these
one move opening ideas that we see at
the biggest stage being played out and
the importance of having those in your
repertoire for a match like this one
yeah so the reason why most opening
ideas these days are one uh game tries
is because let's say you go back you
know uh 15 years or 18 years
and you're analyzing with something like
Fritz eight
so some engine that people might not
even be familiar with these days uh
because you know everyone knows about
stockfish now and Lila and all that but
uh back in the day you know you play the
first movie E4 and then you decide you
want to analyze the night or so you
respond with C5 and Fritz says blunder
white has an advantage of 0.8 and those
were the days where you couldn't really
trust engines in the opening you
actually had to go super deep and really
dig and dig and dig to to figure things
out and even after an enormous amount of
digging it would still take a lot of
practical games and you know wins and
losses and uh trial and error for people
to figure out the right approach in
opening now once someone plays an ID
against you you enter into a computer
and the computer gives you every single
answer it tells you the truth in every
position uh or as close to the truth as
you can possibly imagine so the
analytical work now the burden is is
much lower it's it's much easier and
that's why you can't really repeat tries
because the computer just tells you the
answer right after the game if uh
that's even if you don't know it before
the game because for example we saw in
the last game that the ninja that they
played Jan actually knew the line in
quite a great
deal of detail
he knew what was going on it was just
that he didn't remember exactly
precisely all the details of the
position right but if ding plays out
again Jan will come you know super well
equipped and remember every detail and
there won't be a single place that thing
could surprise him in that in that
nimzoo with E3 and A3
that's why you have to jump around
because these are all one-game tries
it's not because chess changed is
because our anal analytical tools
changed
yeah wow and we see this line also being
played out that we were looking at so
Ayan goes for a direct approach gives a
check on C6 and just to close on that
topic that you were saying yesterday
with Anish and Robert we were talking
about the E3 A3 nimzoo approach and
Anish mentioned that you are The
Specialist of that nimso how did you
feel that being played out and the way
that it was handled with the with the
white Pieces by ding
well I picked this whole variation up
because grishop played it against me
in the last year one of the rapid Chess
Championship games
and he beat me rather convincingly like
I I basically didn't know what to do I
got crushed out of the opening I started
to play with the white pieces and I had
quite good results even after my
opponents knew that I was playing it
still the computer is kind of always
saying black is doing well and uh it's
one of those positions I know I just
said like the computer sees everything
but it's one of those positions where
the computer tends to overestimate
Black's position a little bit so
sometimes people search for those spots
where you can be misled and Analysis
because even though the position is
objectively good for black it's still
practically very difficult so if you're
if you're not analyzing super super
careful then you can still run into
difficulties in terms of um
you know what you analyze might not be
as easy as you think so that's why I
picked it up I I recognized as grishop
did uh although I have to admit he did
it before me that the variation is very
difficult for black or practical point
of view but the approach that Ding went
for this early 92 G3 was actually
um an idea of arama kobiance who's
maybe not a player who like
um everyone in chat would recognize
immediately but he's a strong Grand
Master and it's sort of his specialty so
I think one thing prepared his
inspiration was not grishuke it wasn't
me it was actually Jacobian
Robert we've got something
and we thought that this allows the
Black Knight to jump to E4 Robert would
that be just
a game over situation with this ending
in a draw coming into the activity with
Knight E4 right now for ding
it is indignotes it I can see base he
wants to move like he is about to grab
his Knight he's at the hopper to E4 he
doesn't have many moves that's the good
thing about his position he knows it
should be a draw and he doesn't have too
many options which means the options
that he will realistically choose from
at this point are going to still hold
that draw so Knight to E4 going after
the F2 Pawn that makes perfect sense you
just want to trade all the pawns off and
even if white pushes the pawn to F3
which has been valuable in some other
lines you can bring his Knight to F2 go
out for this H3 Pawn please take my F5
Pawn I'll gladly take your H3 we're just
swapping off material and it should
result in a draw and after H4 Knight D3
check gets her King out of here and you
see ding he's hovering he really really
want to pick wants to pick up that
Knight and I think he sees that the end
is near in a good way that the draw is
about to occur
yeah that's I think 94 he's got it you
we already saw his hand sort of hovering
he's getting ready to move that night
there I think it's coming right now
incoming 94 it's happening you should
stop for the night well it's back in 94
as Robert pointed out put that pressure
on the F2 Pawn the more bonds that get
traded the closer to the result you get
it's on the board 94.
F3 is the only reasonable chance I guess
and then you mentioned the move Tanya
Knight to F2
going deep into the enemy camp but
attacking H3 and attacking the D3 Square
so after H4 you have this very important
Knight to D3 check otherwise you might
be in trouble but Knight to D3 check
Chase is the king away
yeah because the other check you could
actually end up trapping your own Knight
after Knight F2 and if white was to go
H4 you've got to be a little careful
because Knight H3 Chuck the king comes
back and starts hitting the Knight and
there might be no way home after that
Robert yes show that that if you get a
little bit tricky here you tricked
yourself because the king comes back the
Knight goes to G1 and the Knight covers
E2 which means that this King can step
right back the Knight is trapped it's
lost that would be a win for wiper ding
he has this one under control he goes
Knight F2 and H4 looking pretty forcy
but King to G3 back the Knight still
goes to the D3 square and yeah Jan knows
that this game is about to conclude uh
Fair result I would say I mean John had
his chances early ding was saying no I'm
not going to lose this one I'm not gonna
suffer a two-point deficit and a new
score sheet you'll have to put his name
atop it but soon he'll also write the
result down
yeah
not only putting his name on top he will
have the signature soon he has navigated
all the critical moments to Perfection
what are Herculean defense this has been
by dingler in in what has been the
longest game of the 2023 world
championship match so far between these
two players Knight D3 check given Jana
famnashi falls back with the King to G3
so no draw offers yet but I also don't
see a way to kind of force matters here
for black I don't see a repetition I
don't see a way to trade more pawns so
are we expecting Yan to continue playing
for a while or will that surprise you a
little bit
I think we're gonna still be here for a
little while
it's it's still a position where you can
just try try for a while without any
risk
you might as well right I mean it's just
good Equity I guess
we can't blame him for playing us on but
it's not the
not a position where it feels like ding
would go wrong
under any circumstances unless like some
blackout happens I really feel like ding
is going to draw this but just out of
pure
um obligation Jan is going to try to win
as well
he has to right he's up a pawn there's
no reason not to keep going here uh you
know typically you don't want to Tire
yourself out but tomorrow is a rest day
he can relax and I think that's part of
the reason why he's played this on so
long if he had another game tomorrow I
think he probably would have just
allowed a draw earlier but he's spending
his time he's really working at the
board and I always like to credit people
who do that because if the game is going
to be a draw you can extend your hand
early or you could play it out
kind of rest is I'm trying to think do
we know what the players have been up to
in this world championship match during
the rest days because there's often such
different approaches I was when I was in
Dubai for the Yan Magnus match Magnus
was completely different during the rest
days we'd see him go out play sports he
would play basketball football Ian a
little more secretive one of the rest is
he even went and got a haircut I
remember uh Fabi what was that like for
you are we also are we seeing a
repetition right now
yeah we're still going to see some more
moves
so like I actually have some inside
information on what Yan Anthony have
been doing during the rest days I hear
they've been going to the trampoline
park with James Canty
I mean don't don't ask me how I know
this it's just
Abby so so during the London match we
were going to
um get massages that was like our way to
relax we would go to to get some a
massage and and uh walk a lot you know
we were in the city so
um I know that Magnus found some place
to do sports but we were just walking
around the city mostly and there was
still a lot of prep work that had to be
done and I was sort of telling guys like
you know Bruce Dunham and Christian were
there with me and
um I was telling them basically what
directions I thought were interesting
and what directions deserved work so
yeah there was a lot of Chess work to be
done but we were trying to find some
relaxation as well
and we didn't have a trampoline park
unfortunately
the trampoline park is still on fabi's
mind definitely to get that trampoline
chest going Robert and uh they're a
small bullet dodged by a Napo by dingler
and you definitely don't want to trade
off the knights that would be a lasting
fun ending but I think any other move
keeping the knights alive and it's still
a draw uh dingler and decides to get the
Knight on the queen side of the board he
goes night before and now Jan Robert is
he trying to get the king from the other
side does he want to March up the boat
for me 3d4
uh if he could he would gladly do that
especially because this Knight on F4
makes sure the king cannot pass the king
can't go to G6 the Knight covers the
square and even if the king went around
to H6 the Knight stops from going to H5
so this king is the only piece uh that
can help in terms of trying to win the
game but even if it were on D4 unless
you're getting a trade of knights a
black will just keep checking that white
king and go after the pawns like if this
King were on D4 the Knight would come to
C2 and maybe even over to E1 to go after
your Pawn so I just feel like uh it's
worth an attempt but it's futile this
the defense by dingley Ren has been spot
on
while ding thinks of his next move I
have another question about trampoline
chess Robert which one would you prefer
trampoline and chess or chess boxing
oh it depends who my oppon is am I
fighting fobby like what's what's going
on if it was Fabi it would definitely be
trampoline chess but if it was if
somebody who got on my nerves a little
more then I guess we have to go into
chess boxing
what do you think Bobby
I'm I'm still trying to stay away from
chess boxing at least for at least for a
few more years trying to protect the
head
and someday maybe we'll see but
trampoline chess seems pretty safe as
long as I don't fall in my head I'll
probably come out of that game alive so
that would still be my pick
um but you know I I had such a good time
watching the chess boxing event that
that Ludwig uh organized in I think it
was November right in Los Angeles
December yeah December of this embryo
yeah so it's fun it's fun
as long as someone else is in the ring
yeah I mean well I I want to see people
that I recognize like a lot of the
streamers I didn't know them but uh but
when Andrea and Dina and Lawrence and
Amman got into the ring then I was
personally invested I was like okay this
is this is fun this is exciting you know
yeah you guys were there watching it
if you had to have a chess boxing match
who would you pick as your opponent for
that I've got to put you on a spot for
this one
so like you know I've said that Anish
would be kind of we're probably in like
similar weight categories I guess but
I've spoken to him and he has not only
no interest in chess boxing but he
actually dislikes it
so
I don't think that he's he's a willing
opponent
um
so I'm not sure I don't know
but it's I'll think about it for a few
years and then we'll see
not a willing opponent would drop it
both Fabi and a niche I are very good
friends if they're actually took to the
boxing ring which as boxing who would
you be rooting for would you have a
favorite in that one well I thought you
were gonna ask me who would I choose to
fight so I'm glad you asked me this
version of the question uh who would I
root for
um I think we the Chess World wins to
see this happen because so many people
would watch you know it would be a lot
of fun for all who are going to be
entertained except for maybe Fabi and
Denise you both don't want to be there
but you know for everybody else actually
you know uh Fabi
I do have a question for you related
chess boxing
which of like the top 10 players would
make the best matchup
oh uh between me or just like in general
no just you don't have to be involved
because I know you don't want to be so
just choose people
I was actually gonna say that if I was
like fighting Hikaru that would be an
interesting one and that would also get
probably get a few views
but uh in general let me think so top 10
who's who's like currently
it doesn't have to be exactly top ten
you know who all the best players are so
okay
let's do something
fun like cruise ship against kramnik
well I think kremac would never ever do
it probably grishop wouldn't either but
that would be a fun one
oh wow speaking of a fun one are we
seeing a little repetition here a night
check and a jump back to D4
Dodge it one more time and play the king
forward to F4 we might be seeing a
result at this moment if he comes back
in E2 Knight before repetition
yeah it's
looking difficult to find ideas here
King F4 Knight D4 Knight C5 baby you can
give that one a try
yeah now this Knight can also give a
check yeah back here the knights are
just gonna dance around a bit also I
just thought of a potential chess boxing
match so probably what do you think I
don't think either of these players
would do it but in terms of age and you
know weight class strength Dominguez and
grishuk
Dominguez grishuk that would be
interesting but I feel like
grishu probably has
is maybe in a different weight class
I don't know I just approximated that
would be that would be fun I was also
thinking like okay let's go like yawn
I mean we're watching the world
championship so it might as well include
Jan and the
in the chest boxing who would he fight
Maxine
oh but Jana is definitely in a different
way category that's right
but Maxine was a good one he he Maxim
against uh
Anish
that would be fun to watch no no I mean
Magnus definitely outweighs him by by
quite a bit so I don't think that'll be
fair
all right just a little kingdom dance
and the night dance going on but you
could give a check and then come back to
D4 it's hard to go wrong in this
position it's been amazing to watch just
the way ding has actually kept his game
under control some very difficult
moments starting from the opening up to
the middle game and now we see he's
probably gonna just come back with that
Knight to the Central Square D4 and once
again the same position as we had it I
think Yan is slowly but surely giving up
on his ambition here and as I said no
King E3 no repetition Yan goes for a
different part putting that Knight on F4
why not you know let's keep this game
going what's the record for longest game
in world championship history I saw a
featured chat about it I think it was
around move 150 so we're on move 72.
they have 41 minutes left for Yan uh
this this could go on a while everybody
so you know Buckle in have a good time
maybe grab a little bit of a snack I'm
not hungry I don't know who would say
that but you know enjoy yourself because
this is an end game and for newer
players you often don't reach end games
and the white is up a pawn so I do think
many people would wonder why is white
not just winning why is white not better
it's because the pawn can't go very far
at some point white can push this Pawn
to H5 but as soon as you do the black
king will step into G5 and then the pawn
can go no further so oh ding as soon as
I say that breaks his King into the game
and I guess after King G3 he'll just
bring his King right back to F6 and I'm
just wondering Robert on that point can
white actually go H5 simply I'm thinking
if you take on F4 it's six and you might
not be in time to catch that pawn
oh you're not you're not in time but you
just go back King F6 and you're actually
happy to provoked H5
oh there's still H6 there so
the king cannot approach the pawn
but black probably just plays a move
like Knight to C6 I guess
and the punk also can't advance
so you'll play Knight to E5 You'll Play
Knight to F7 you'll eventually Corel
that pawn it'll take a little while but
you'll get there eventually
although this this formation it's like
there are some dangers in general not in
this position but sometimes you would
see this formation and you would think
like the pattern that kind of sets off a
few alarm Bells
agreed it looks like it could be a
winning configuration even if in
practice it is not but ding he has this
one under control uh he's just bringing
his King into the center he is ready to
sign those score sheets when the game
concludes but for Jan he's just trying
to figure out a way can he still be
challenging here uh that was one good
attempt by Tanya like just throw the
pawn up the board the black king would
not take the Knight it would have to go
backwards and that wouldn't be the end
of the world for black because as Fabi
said when you push the pawn that vacates
uh control of the G5 Square so let me go
right back over and try to snag that
pawn so I do feel like Jan knows that
the result is going to be a draw he is
just trying to testing a little bit and
I guess Bobby you played a world
championship right when you had a
position that you knew should be a draw
maybe you're up a pawn like this how did
you determine when to call a day a day
um well I think I was more on the
defending side of some of these I had I
had one end game which was very very
clearly
like I needed to play for a win and I I
exhausted every possible try I could
there and I was even objectively winning
at some point and then Magnus had one
Rook end game that I remember was very
unpleasant and he basically exhausted
that to like
until it was bone dry until it was not
even a single try left and that's kind
of magnus's General style that he's
going to exhaust a position he knows
it's drawn it was at some point a
question during this match because we
had a position that was you know typical
zero zero zero evaluation and we both
knew it was drawn
but still Magnus tried a bit and he was
kind of moving back and forth and so on
and in the press conference after
uh one person that one reporter asked
him
did you know that it was a draw
and he was like almost offended by the
question he was like of course I know
it's a draw but it's still you know I'm
trying to squeeze a little bit out of it
because that's how you
win games or you try to win games
I mean likewise here the players know
that's a draw and they've known it for a
while although I think at some point
they were both kind of questioning like
at that moment when ding was thinking
about H3 certainly it wasn't 100 draw on
their minds but uh at this point they
know it's a draw but still okay you try
to squeeze every little last bit out of
it so I actually I have a question
because we know that this game will not
be the longest game in world
championship history they're not going
to play another 80 moves but isn't the
longest game the one that we covered
game six of the 2021 that is the longest
right yeah Rakesh actually put it it was
a feature chat uh that was game six of
the 2021 world championship between
Magnus Carlson and Jana palmichi so that
is indeed the longest game in world
championship history and it beat up some
game by Corsair was that like or or who
was the previous record holder
you're asking me to remember that you
kidding me no I just remember we had
this discussion uh one and a half years
ago but
I can't remember which the previous
record holder was I don't remember our
conversations from yesterday let me go
check our WhatsApp messages but you
expect me to remember this yeah no I I
know what you're talking about but I
honestly don't remember I think it was a
court Story game but I I can't say with
any degree of certainty
um and that game six it was not just any
game it pretty much decided the whole
world championship last time Jan
napamishi was on this stage fighting uh
the match against Magnus and Bobby you
were talking about press conferences and
you know we've been so lucky as trust
fans where we've had the thoughts of the
players the players are obliged to be at
the press conference share their
thoughts their emotions after the match
and it's been amazing to watch these two
uh in these press conferences but I want
to ask you from a player's perspective
right out of a game and sometimes the
game lasts very long sometimes the
result doesn't go your way
I know that you had 12 draws in your
match against Magnus but it's still it's
still a duty that you have you have to
go for the press conference how is it
from a player's perspective dealing with
that and of course the questions that
are asked
yeah it's not always fun but we kind of
accepted as a occupational hazard and
also we're you know top chess players do
pretty all right financially so it's
it's pretty normal that we have
professional responsibilities and that
we give a little bit back to the public
and that we sometimes
even if you're very upset you you should
go to a press conference sometimes
organizers uh are very lenient with that
and they're you know they don't want to
torture the players
but for a world championship I think you
definitely expect that the players show
up to the press conference give their
thoughts I mean this is a you know once
and two year event it's not every day
that you have a world championship so
it's expected that you want to hear the
thoughts of the players after
and
yeah like my personal
sort of
um I wouldn't say relationship but my
personal opinion of like press
conferences and chess has been pretty
mixed I remember sometimes
going to a tournament a closed
tournament with all the best players in
the world and then they open it up to
the Press uh for like the
pre pre-tourmet press conference and
then it's just crickets and not even a
single reporter asks a single question
and then you just feel like what are you
doing there I mean you have you have
magnesity over the number two to ten
player in the world and uh and you're
not asking any questions then what's the
point of like even having the Press
there so it's I think it's generally
good you know to have
engaging press conferences it's good for
the outside public it's good for the
spectators and so on
um
yeah Robert as a commentator is there a
is there a moment that you can remember
from all the press conferences that
we've seen that has sort of left an
impact on you what we've heard from the
players
wow okay well there are definitely some
negative things I can think about but
I'll take this one and and think of a
positive when Magnus lost to Hikaru at
the speeches Championship final but
still came on and didn't interview this
was his own choice he actually
volunteered to come on and talk about it
because he had such a good time playing
that match and he was talking to me and
Dania uh Daniel nerdiski for like a half
hour or something like that so that is
actually one of the best moments I would
say uh from a post-match interview that
I've been a part of so I think that you
know Fabi is right that it's necessary
for chess to continue growing and
succeeding and for the public to get the
players thoughts because in chess unlike
in let's say professional sports you'd
always get a moment where you can
pinpoint okay in that basketball game
why did you make that spin move there
into that double team like that's not
what you get in them and it wouldn't
really make sense but in chess because
this complete information game it's all
laid out on the board in front of you we
do get a lot of analysis get here
players thoughts their you know their
fears their concerns they're
overconfidence at times and I think
that's just human nature and it's really
great to see that unfolds I like press
conferences uh I wasn't used to them
when I back when I played they were few
and far between but I love that every
big chess event that we have we get to
interview the players and see their raw
emotions because it's a humanizes them
in a way that I think chess historically
has not benefited from
I couldn't agree more with everything
that you just said it's so special to
actually get their thoughts and their
feelings after a game and we're super
lucky to have that when the players
answer and respond to these questions I
was actually watching that interview
Robert that you and Dania had after the
speed test Championship with Magnus and
Hikaru and it was brilliant to see
because even though Magnus lost it was
clear just the love that's there for
this for that format and and for the
games that he had and the competition
the Rivalry between these two it was
incredible but I think uh the other
moment that actually came to my mind
when you mentioned the Magnus lost I
thought you were going to refer to the
2016 World Championship Match where
Magnus was the one who actually lost the
first game uh to karaoke and he's the
one who who was trailing uh Sergey
karyakin in that match I think it was
Game nine or game eight uh chat will
correct me on that but what happened
after that we saw the emotional toll
that that took on Magnus and he came for
the press conference and immediately
just decided that he did not want to to
be a part of it Sergey was doing his
interviews and Magnus actually walked
out of the press conference uh very
often Fabi there is this emotional
turmoil that goes on in players and
sometimes you just don't want to face
any of it
yeah yeah I can understand his
frustration how upset he was I think he
even accepted a fine for that because it
was kind of obligatory and he was fined
a certain percentage of the price on
five percent which is quite a lot of
money so he he must have been pretty
upset uh I mean of course for for Magnus
it's not about
you know let's say the world
championship is much more important than
just the money itself so
uh I can understand his his frustration
how upset he was
on the other hand it's kind of expected
that that you do follow through with it
and I think with time he sort of
um
curbed his emotions when he was losing a
little bit
he's not as upset usually when he loses
as before I think we see the same in
like let's say Hikaru and other players
that with time it just becomes more I
guess you're more used to it uh also you
put things a bit more in perspective
like you realize you know one loss is
not the end of the world as very often
young players realize or or think that
you know I just lost this game and I
remember when I was like 12 years old I
would think every single loss is the end
of the world you know it's like some
great tragedy and now I don't even
remember these games that I played when
I was 12.
um but yeah with time with time that
changes for sure
do you remember the game we played when
we were like 10 and you beat me in
Argentina yeah I remember that game oh
so you don't remember your games when
you were 12 but you remember that game
when we were like you know I don't
remember how young we were I remember
the games that I win Robert oh okay okay
well oh so you know I actually remember
when we were like
we were playing in New York because for
members of the chat who who uh who don't
know our origin story like we both grew
up playing in the same chess scene in
New York City and with the same chess
coach uh Grandmaster Miron share and so
we played a lot as kids
and I remember I don't remember the
result I just remember the opening it
was that fried liver attack it was some
crazy game when we were like seven years
old or eight years I don't know
something like that and I don't remember
the result but I remember the room that
we were playing in it's like a very very
vague memory just like scattered details
um that sounds like a setting for a
horror movie so I'm a little concerned
about for the two of us I don't think
we've ever recovered but I just want to
sorry to
bring you into that conversation and
then Sidetrack back to the game but I I
think it was a nice idea by janapamichi
that's instructive and he just moved his
Knight away but if we can bring up an
analysis board quickly uh this was kind
of a cute try where if dingly Ren got
very active and tried to bring his King
up to H5 this is gonna backfire because
the white king would slap to H3 to
defend the pawn and black is in suksmong
if it were a White's move then white and
super strong you might have to move your
knight away otherwise you'd lose your
pawn and the Black Knight would enter
but in this case black has to move back
the white King enters you lose this Pawn
you lose the game so I just wanted to
point out that variation
yeah that's a very relevant detail and
the writing's on the wall it's a draw
yes and exactly as you pointed out it
was a mutual zigzong and dingler and
managed to get his Knight the F Bonds
were swapped and handshakes game nine
and we see that
did you see that he feels it he's
disappointed with this result with how
the game ended shaking his head in
disbelief there a big moment a big
missed opportunity he feels it and wow I
haven't seen Yan like that after a game
Robert
and he probably felt that that was a
potential match Clincher if he won this
game he had a two-point spread over
dangly Wren then yeah I was probably
like I'm gonna be the world champion but
dingley Ren held his ground he was not
going to allow Yan to take this game and
that's huge I mean that emotion we saw
from Jan that is a bit surprising I mean
he was never that clearly won but he he
was never winning he was just better and
to see that from him I mean I don't know
if that's a good sign actually
maybe he thought that the night ending
was winning at some moment
and because it was close
and maybe he really felt like he was
very close to winning and maybe he
thinks he missed something although that
wasn't the case as we saw he they played
absolutely correctly uh and the game was
always balanced in the end game
yeah maybe it was just that he felt he
was close throughout the game it's just
like he was always on top but just never
never quite enough to win
had his chances he tried but what an
impressive Herculean defense by the
Chinese Superstar dingler and holding
his own in a marathon game and that
means we will be going into game 10 with
Yanda Panda she having just a point
margin and Robert you pointed out a win
in this match would essentially ha win
in this game would essentially mean A
match Victory the thing would need a
miracle out of that one now while the
end game phase was one that we knew
would end in a draw with the opening and
the middle game had some big moments
some big chances there Robert take us
through these critical moments that we
saw that demanded full attention and
fantastic defense by ding yeah Fabiano
interject wherever you find in an
interesting moment but the opening stage
was in Auntie Berlin I almost forgot
because it was so many hours ago but
after Knight F6 Jan napamshi wanted no
part of the main line so he made the
move D3 which has become the main line
so Fabi after this opening stage with
Bishop C5 and C3 where was the first
critical Moment In Your Eyes
I think that the first critical moment
was probably when ding played them with
Queen to C7 it's quite deep into the
opening phase
but this is all quite known Theory
and this Knight to B8 maneuver that Ding
played was known and Rook to the E1 here
and I think it's still Theory with Rook
to d8 and H3 and I saw a bit of surprise
when ding played C6 in this position but
it's still a very normal move and only
when he played Queen C7 we were
surprised
or even even Knight to A6 I think we
were already quite a bit surprised that
the Knight was going in that direction
but Queen C7 especially we thought the
Knight was going to C7 suddenly he
blocks the C7 Square for the for the
Knight but he's playing so quickly it's
clear that he has prepared this
but dink has and we saw his idea was to
play Bishop Buffet Knight C5 but we were
still surprised by this
uh this direction from ding
yeah it was an interesting choice from
him and then he followed it up after
John's I really liked this move after a
bit of time Bishop A2 is a mysterious
move it did block some key variations
from dangly Ren we talked about one of
them being that if the bishop dropped
back white with only then bring the
bishop to E3 and after Knight C5 a move
like Rook to D1 if you play Bishop E6
white then gets the take on C5 and ruin
your Pawn structure with Bishop takes E6
so it's kind of a waiting game at this
stage but Fabi after Bishop A2 we saw
the move B5 taking advantage of the
bishop not being on that diagonal and I
think this was maybe the first really
critical moment of the game where
dangling played Rook B8
yeah Rook to be it was a movie we were
critical of and I think in hindsight
absolutely correctly so it led to a lot
of difficulties for black and it was the
whole reason why he was on the back foot
the entire game
If instead he had played the move that
you suggested Bishop to f8 a pawn
sacrifice and we were also considering
taking on A4 but I especially like this
move and if white takes the pawn
the move is preparing Knight C5 and if
white takes it on B5 the Knight 65 comes
anyway
and it has a direct thread of Bishop to
A6 trapping the queen along with ideas
of Knight to D3 and although white is up
a pawn the concrete factors in the
position give black more than enough
compensation
and he would have had no troubles I
don't think Young would have taken the
pawn and we would have seen a totally
different kind of game instead ding
played Rook to V8 which was a crucial
tempo
because he depends upon which probably
wasn't going to be taken anyway
and now Jan had time to play Knight to
H4 and get an initiative and this is a
position of one tempo if black is
getting Bishop Buffet Knight C5 in one
go here he's doing great but if not then
he could come under a dangerous attack
and he brought his Bishop back the queen
came up to F3 this was what you were
indicating should happen a while back
after B takes A4 Bishop takes H6 a very
big moment in this game if the pawn took
on A6 the queen gets to take the Knight
that pawn on G7 was doing double duty
protecting H6 and F6 at the same time
this would be a huge issue for the king
especially with the bishop waiting on A2
trying to deliver a checkmate with a
potential Rook lift a knight jump or
Rook swing and that would be a mating
attack so instead of taking on H6 we saw
that Ding he goes
it went in with his Knight to C5 and
after Knight G6 grabs this Pawn on B2
this was some Brave stuff from dingly
Red
yeah I really like how ding played this
part of the game especially in Knights
of C5 I think that was very important
and the point was not to take on B2
immediately because you very crucially
need some intermediate Rook to D3
tactics
so rather than take the pawn immediately
and allow Bishop G5 which would be very
very dangerous for black he played
Knight C5 with the idea of disturbing
White's harmony with the move Rook D3 at
a crucial moment for example after
Bishop G5 Rook D3 here
and then we saw a line which we kind of
thought was possible but we weren't 100
sure because
after Knight C5 White had a lot of
potential options we were talking about
Bishop G5 here we were talking about
Rook B1 we were talking about some crazy
stuff sacrificing everything on the king
side to break through
but the way young played very logical
with 19 G6
it was indeed and I mean I think just
this press conference is about to start
so I'm noticing that and so just to go
to this moment here I think this was a
huge moment in time where instead of
taking this Rook on B5 we saw a trade of
Bishops after that it felt like the the
advantage was never really there this
would have been a totally different game
had he taken on B5 absolutely a very
exciting game we've got the players in
Astana let's head over and heard from
them at the press conference
with the question to Jan nepalmaneshi
Ayan you seemed quite disappointed when
the game has ended
um can you please share your thoughts
about the game
uh well it was
I guess not much after the opening
but I guess after
after like this Rook B8 move I thought
like he should have played bishop f8 and
psychopone
but after rugby 94 I think that there is
like very very nice Initiative for white
um
I'm in
probably there were like different
different ways to
uh to build up maybe maybe I could I
should have tried not Bishop takes H6 I
played it attempty but maybe something
like Knight F5 also made some sense yeah
uh trading capturing on on H6 budget
looked like so so nice but actually I
never could find
um like any decisive
blows a lot of nice tactics but I mean
okay I ended up going through this dry
position and um I mean from from some
distance I missed this Rugby field
before
and yeah it's uh it looks Jewish though
uh of course I could I should have post
more problems in the end game but um
yeah somehow it was not so you know not
so simple to to move my pawns forward
and uh yeah I guess the night end game
um
uh looks looks maybe dangerous for black
but
probably a joke
thank you very much
what did you feel about the United game
what was the evolution uh I would I
would like to ask journalists and the
audience a little bit of Silence it's
really difficult to
here
please
so I will repeat the question uh to
think how did you feel about the night
end game and what was the evaluation of
the position after The Rook trade
well first I thought it was an easy draw
but I realized it's not so simple
especially after the position he played
King F4 if I go Knight the E4 it might
lost because this 396 King E5 and he has
many waiting moves here also if I go
King seven I was expected also lost
position with two pounds and then he can
go King G5 if
he has a chance
and
during a game I thought maybe H3 is the
only move to to save the game
right to talk a little bit from the from
the beginning today you had the 20
minutes advantage on the clock uh right
after the opening have you felt
comfortable with your opening Choice
today
yeah this line I prepared some time ago
but then maybe Rook dp8 as he said is
too slow I'm totally missed his ideal
Knight H4 queen of three I should have
played Bishop my face but I was afraid
of take take Queen takes Knight C5 and
P4 and I couldn't find the continuation
after
this position maybe I have some chance
here I should spend more time on this
position
right thank you and Jan you you had a
long thoughts and then you decided to
play Bishop to A6 Bishop to A2 on the
Move 16. uh can you please walk us
through this moment and share the idea
behind this move
ah it was no idea
I mean actually I wanted to play uh
let's say put my knight on C4 so in case
of Bishop f8 meet the bishop e390 29 C4
uh so I was struggling to find a useful
move so maybe I should have just played
I don't know like laughing like like
Bishop D2 bishop f8 and here okay D1 and
then Bishop E3 but of course the
position is like very dry yeah so it
slowly becomes like drawish so uh I felt
like maybe bishop A2 is trickier so I
combine like uh I prepare like 92.9 C4
at some point and and also
um
and then also let's ask black if black
can make a useful move as well
so perhaps okay I could try something
like before at some point yeah like
prepare before but yeah I mean these
burning structures yeah
um a dry yeah
yeah right and also at this moment when
you decided not to capture the uh
exchange they work on B5 and instead you
decided to capture the bishop light
Square Bishop
um
what was your the reason that you made
this decision why you didn't capture the
road
well I probably
um thought it's like it's just too good
uh the position after
um I mean after I grabbed an exchange
it's
if I'm not winning by force it becomes
like
I wouldn't say double-edged but It's
Tricky of course yeah okay like those
Pawns
and I mean black has some plan yeah like
now it goes to F6 like another night
maybe to B3 or something okay I mean it
should be winning I believe for white
but I mean at least some nice chances
but it wasn't clear and uh as it was in
the game I I'm a little bit missed the
idea of Queen C6
and I mean it takes really it takes a
while to capture this A4 Pawn because
yeah this Rook takes C3 tactics is quite
nasty so perhaps I would just have
played something like Bishop C1 instead
of Queen E2
and I guess it should be like very nice
very pleasant position for white but uh
yeah Alice
and then also in this end give me a
suddenly after rookie four maybe I
should have tried F3 or something yeah
like maybe to to keep up some pieces and
then okay come up with Eddie Arrow K4
and yeah but I think it was like never
something very real and yeah he defended
develop it seems
thank you ending also the same same
position when Jan decided to take the
bishop only six uh which move you wanted
more to see on the board Bishop takes
the Rook was your best option that
European could play or Bishop E6 well
Bishop E6 camera totally shock
I thought he will take the look
and then maybe rookie D1 Knight F6 and
then to see what happens
but takes the bishop is totally a shock
but actually after that he's still
better
it was not something that I expected
that I'm hoping for
also I have two still I have to fight
for the Eco after he takes a bishop
right thank you I don't have more
questions for the moment so I would like
press to ask the questions now please
thank you my client Jessica
people are really
openings played in this I'll start again
uh just a second we need to change the
microphone we need to
we need a technical help because
microphones
okay I'll start again uh ding I think
people have been really enjoying the
number of different openings that we've
seen But even Fabiano Carolina said that
it must be really hard to remember all
of your preparation when you keep
changing openings so especially because
you're getting different structures so
have you been able to memorize or recall
all of your preparation or has it been
difficult because you've been changing
openings so much against E4
yeah sometimes it's difficult but today
the idea is I remember the idea Queen C7
with something with bishop and face
those idea is very clear to me so I just
I recall it still in the game I just
need to
uh did not didn't miss
um the
the order I just need to re recall which
was the best move order to reach this
kind of position
okay thanks
thank you next question please
um
uh hello everybody we are from March TV
and the question is to ianushi Yan why
did you choose Berlin position
what was the reason behind
um
no because uh
what
um
foreign foreign
well actually it wasn't a surprise for
me because whites had a good position
and they didn't have much problems and
actually there were perspectives and
there were there were not any decisive
moments to get to have some decisive
Advantage so the Berlin was okay for me
and it's normal to have it in such games
thank you very much next question Garcia
from El Pais I have a question for each
one please Ian what feeling weighs more
now in your mind you keep your one point
Advantage One More Day or you lost a
good opportunity to win again and for
Leland
from one to ten how do you evaluate your
self-confidence right now
thank you for the question
um I guess
it's like the same like try to make good
moves try to do my best and uh yeah and
see what happens
the confidence of what to win the
overall match or to win the next game
or confidence in yourself
my in general I guess right
but it had to be something to win the
match or to win next game
to win the match or win the match
um five
thank you
you saw the face of him right
I saw some some something from this side
do you have more questions yeah there's
questions for both players I've actually
heard several people online say that at
various points in this match they're
actually yelling at their screen while
watching which I've never heard of
before but they're so emotionally
invested in the game and I'm curious
have either of you ever watched someone
else play a chess game and you've gotten
so emotionally invested that you yelled
at the screen or anything like that I
can maybe start with Grand Master young
to promise you on that question
uh thank you for the question I guess
like every online tournament like
doesn't matter if I play or if I follow
I'm constantly yelling something yeah uh
constantly cursing and uh and so on yes
about Jokes Aside uh yeah it's quite
nice that people are
um yeah find the classical chess and the
match sorry exciting
thank you dink
I'm sorry can you repeat the question
have you ever watched a game online that
was not your game and you were so
excited about what was going on that you
yelled at your computer
like you were cheering for someone or
wish they had found a particular move
repeats the question again do you get
excited when you watch other people play
online
which other people put in yes people are
getting very excited watching your games
uh uh I'm not excited to watch the other
games playing online
that's fair enough I guess
all right do we have more questions
uh I see we don't have more questions
but we have Twitter segment and Jesse
will bring some of the questions of the
spectators in social media
hello Jesse February here my first
question is from Alex for Deng
are you more confident in your time
management now compared to your previous
games
well it's
it's connected the time management the
quality of the moves
the
the length of the calculations it's all
connected
so I spent less time to calculate today
about the quality you see jobs a lot
all right thank you next question next
question is for nepper how many pink
shirts did you bring with you
for real yeah
enough
alrighty
all right so after the game do you ever
go back and watch the commentary or read
comments on social media to see what
people say this question is for both of
you
um yeah and let's go with you first uh
uh I try frankly I try to restrict
myself because once you start like
I mean the problem is like so many
people making comments through yeah I
can on every in every like major chess
Channel there is separate commentaries
so uh once you start like
digging into the topic uh yeah it
basically there is there is a chance it
will consume like uh the rest of you
know your free time sir better not to
even start
right thank you
if you would like to answer this
question after the game if you watch uh
commentary or some comments
yeah sometimes I will follow it because
despite of this
it's very hard to totally uh
keep away from all the social media
because the tournament's so long even if
you decided not to follow but at some
point
you're back to some the same routine at
some point right so you have not
uninstalled any social media
applications how about you young
because I think in one of your
interviews you said that at the previous
world championship match you have
uninstalled some of the applications how
about this much have you uninstalled
some of the applications to focus more
yeah I guess a couple of weeks before
the the thing
okay
thank you do we have more questions
Jesse yeah I have one more question so
given how exciting the match is so
instead of writing a book about it
uh
I mean since I'm still a player not uh
not not an offer I guess yeah
for now for now my duties yeah more
simple yeah just
play some chess
right there was the question to Yan or
we also want to know about doing sure
since what about your writings yeah it's
not my job
thank you thank you very much do we have
more questions from press
uh I will not ask more questions because
it has been really long day for players
tomorrow will be day off and the next
round will resume the other day at 3 P.M
local time so thank you very much for
coming here and answering our questions
[Applause]
the players having some fun there at the
press conference always really nice to
see and as Ian mentioned he has to play
some chess while he has to play his best
chess because after game nine this is
where we stand in the world championship
between these two amazing Fighters a
dingler and his leader is trailing yeah
with a one point lead a colossal game
nine a big long fight finished in a
peaceful result it ended in a draw the
game was full of ups and downs and that
means she goes into game 10 as the
leader of the match but leading by the
smallest margins just a point ding he
has done it in the match before he's TR
he has managed to strike back twice he
needs to do it one more time to level
the score very interestingly he
mentioned that he gives his confidence
in this match a 5 out of 10. and Bobby
I've got to ask you we saw the
frustration and disappointment in nepo
when the game ended is this a huge
confidence boost for ding
I think it is definitely a confidence
boost and we said before the game even
started that this was an important game
for him to
stop the bleeding a little bit because
the last two games were both rather
disappointing to put it mildly if not
tragic for his his chances in the match
and yeah it's very important that he
didn't lose the game especially since he
was in significant danger not ever
objectively lost but definitely in
danger
and I think it's also good news for him
that he has arrested
because he's going to need to prepare
something very poisonous very venomous
for Eon uh he's gonna need to try to
strike with the white pieces so it's
important he has a rest day to get his
variations in order get some ideas you
know he has his team of seconds we we
don't know entirety of his team but we
assume that he has a bunch of people who
might be searching for ideas here and
there searching for chinx and Jan's
armor and and certainly rest day helps
with that
yeah it comes at such a crucial moment
right before game 10 wedding will start
with the white pieces now ding had this
Monumental task to hold and defend this
game well for Jan it was very
frustrating being close getting to that
initiated but not being able to make the
most of it Robert how do you see these
two players handling this rest day and
what will they need to do to reevaluate
to step back to come back to that game
10 with ding starting with the white
pieces I actually think that Ding will
have a pretty happy rest day he drew
this game with the black pieces he was
in some danger in the earlier stages but
he held on and he actually didn't make
it look too difficult it was pretty
surprising by how confidently he handled
that game after having a disadvantage so
heading into game 10 where he gets the
white pieces let's not forget that this
is a longer match in 2023 than it was in
2021 they added two games of classical
chess that's good news for dingly red
who now has three games with the white
pieces remaining whereas Yonder Palm she
only has two so if dingley rent can play
like he did today and yesterday he will
have good chances to even up this match
because he is playing pretty good chess
he just needs to keep that confidence
level even higher than a five that he
said
yeah and we saw a very interesting take
in the press conference there about the
approach that the players have to the
commentary now as you mentioned Robert
going into the rest the very critical
point for both of them and a much needed
one but also the stock around them
following commentary two very different
approaches there and Jan mentioned that
he actually deleted certain social media
apps before the start of the world
championship match Abby I want to throw
one question to you right now about how
important is it to actually disconnect
from the social media and from this
pressure that built around the match
before this big stage
yeah I think this is a common wisdom
that's what I did before my match with
Magnus
uh I didn't have any social media I I
didn't even have my phone
I think I could still like talk to
people on rest days sometimes talk to
some friends but uh but I wasn't
checking Twitter or anything like that
for sure and uh before the candidates in
the Kansas which I won in 2018 I think
also I was basically taking a pretty big
rest from social media before the the
tournament started
yeah
wow okay so a big rest day coming up for
the players and this is our schedule
going into Sundays when we will be back
with game 10 but it is so important for
the players to make the most of the rest
that they have after the long game we've
seen them fight it out to the very end
uh in game nine thumbs at a very
critical point as ding who is trailing
Yana partnership by a point he will
start with the white pieces in game 10.
how crucial is that uh Robert that he
gets that time to really prepare for the
game and because he needs to maximize
every single opportunity at this point
could be even more important than we
ever could have guessed because of this
preparation leak I mean if that really
was the accounts of dingly Ren and his
second Richard report that means they
need to throw that out the window and
come up with something new uh the good
news is he gets the white pieces he has
a lot of time to prepare but Fabiano he
could speak this better than I can and
he said this before oftentimes
preparation helps the player with the
black pieces because uh you know you get
to work on your opening lines and you
know or think what might be coming and
that way you can work to combat that so
I actually think that the rest day comes
at a good time for both players Yana
palmchi and he has the lead he is a
fantastic fighter and you could see that
bit of dejection on his face not
maximizing the potential of his position
today but I think that both players
they're gonna go into the rest day and
they have chances yawns are better he
has the lead but ding is not out of it
not at all it is a match wide open Yan
leads by just a point the frustration on
Yan was indeed clear after the game and
even during the past press conference
now Robert you mentioned that this is
such a critical Junction for ding to
actually use the rest day to come up
with the best opening ideas you've seen
him come out with surprises in the world
championship so far but it's also been
such a long match for these two and Fabi
after playing a game that's almost
touching a hundred Moon Mark being in
this position where you've got to defend
for a long time how key is it to also
focus on getting some rest in the rest
they actually and not just about the
chess
I think that's the most important thing
coming into the final stretch of this
match it's going to be nerves it's going
to be tiredness and all the associated
things that come with that because once
your emotional state is a bit off you
your nerves are a bit frayed then
everything can fall apart it's not it's
not about the chest part you can be the
best chess player in the world and and
you can start to play a mistake after
mistake
not for any chess reason just because
you're not physically or mentally there
so so that's going to be super important
they both need to be rested tomorrow I'm
sure they'll do some work they'll do
some checking because I it's just hard
to stay away from Chester in a match you
know you're you're looking at the
openings you you're wondering what
you're going to play your next game so
they're definitely going to be involved
in the prep but I I think the majority
like 90 of their day should just be pure
arrest and trying to recover a bit of
energy
yeah who knows they might even find
themselves in the trampoline park we
will find out but definitely game nine
had the upsides for both these players
ding showing fantastic defense but for
janapamnishi as well he really created
his chances out of the opening he was
the one in driving seat asserting
pressure throughout but the result was a
draw Robert who do you think is happier
with the outcome of this game team ding
or team Napo well I like the way you
framed it Jana pomsi asserted himself he
may have won game seven but it's not all
about the scoreboard it was dingley Wren
who actually was out playing yawn
throughout that game before the stumbled
Finish Line so I feel like for Jana
Pomchi he's proven to himself that he
could outplay dingley Ren that in an
opening that his opponent knew better he
still had the upper hand and he has a
one point lead so a draw every single
draw gets him closer to a match Victory
but for ding Loren to draw with the
black pieces three white games remaining
I think both sides can take some
positive away from today and I think we
saw it in dingley wren's reaction in the
post game he is a happier person today
than he was the day before and certainly
more so than in game seven so I think
that both players they can be confident
they have been playing some great chess
there are some so many ups and downs and
there are so many ups and downs to come
yes can't wait for all the action as we
will return with a game 10 on Sunday
definitely it was a dramatic day of
Chess and one thing that stood out to me
was that Ding is still perhaps
struggling a little bit with his opening
with the black pieces we saw him sort of
fail to completely equalize today as
well with that move Rook B8 and then it
was all Yan he really tried to push this
to the very end but in the end thing
Lauren's defense was up to the task and
he keeps the balance at least the
balance in a way that he only Trails a
buyer point and he starts with the white
pieces I know one thing for sure we've
been talking about expect the unexpected
how unpredictable this is you know what
I'm gonna make a prediction guys I think
we're gonna have a decisive result in
game 10 and simply because this is such
a big moment for ding with the white
pieces we've seen so many decisive games
he needs to go all out the task is cut
up for him meanwhile yeah will try to
hold Grand as he does we will be back
with amazing action from game 10 Robert
Fabi today's been fantastic I know it
was a really long game and it's been a
long day for everyone including the
players and our chat as well but it's
been fantastic doing this with you guys
and chat while we leave you we will be
back on Sunday take a look at all the
fun that we had in game 8 and game nine
he's let young back into the game and it
looks like things are not going his way
at all anymore
if there's a draw I think that that is
actually a very good result for Ding and
I do think a loss today would be a
backbreaker we see e45 now here's a
question are we gonna see another
anti-martial or are we going to see
Berlin I think that of Berlin would be a
really smart choice by dick so we're
gonna see a very solid game for both
players I understand the impulse to
defend your Pawn England invested a lot
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
back into the game and it looks like
things are not going his way at all
anymore
if there's a draw I think that that is
actually a very good result for Ding and
I do think a loss today would be a
backbreaker we see e45 now here's the
question are we gonna see another
anti-martial or are we going to see
Berlin I think that of Berlin would be a
really smart choice by dick so we're
going to see a very solid game for both
players I understand the impulse to
defend your Pawn angler invested a lot
of time at that moment but Rook B8 that
was a mistake Jan didn't even think by
the way he just he moved he went Queen
F3 he's not taking he's not allowing
ding to defend that King side he's going
for the attack there are many options
here for dingly red but they don't feel
like opportunities Beyond the Palm
right now he's the one dictating the
action and he may very well win this
game if dingley Wren does not find a
solution this is an insane position I
just want to put this in that getting
these lines in this attack out of a
Berlin honestly only happens in the 2023
world championship match between Ding
and Yan and we do see pawns are coming
off the board right now after Brook
takes E3 it is heading towards the draw
I see you saying chat said H3 a Chet
says all sorts of things supposed to
believe you at every turn but no on this
turn it was a great move indeed so
dingley ran and chat Round of Applause I
think Jan would probably beat chop no
disrespect meant
to draw
foreign
[Music]